YEAH THAT'S RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED WITH OUR HEARING WILL
BE STARTING AS A SUB COMMITTEE
THAT'S WERE MISSING THIRTEEN
MEMBERS SO -- WILL GO AHEAD
GET STARTED BEFORE WE BEGIN I'D
LIKE TO GET PROVIDE INFORMATION
REGARDING TESTIMONY AT THIS
HEARING WANT TO ENSURE THE
RIGHTS OF ALL WHO PARTICIPATE
IN THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS --
SO THAT WE CAN BEHALF EFFECTIVE
DELIBERATION ON THE CRITICAL
ISSUES FACING CALIFORNIA AS
WE PROCEED WITH THE WITNESSES
AND PUBLIC COMMENT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS
THAT THE ASSEMBLY HAS RULES
TO ENSURE WE MAINTAIN ORDER
AND RUN AN EFFICIENT AND FAIR
HEARING WE APPLY THESE RULES TO
ALL PEOPLE WHO PARTICIPATE IN
OUR PROCEEDINGS ALL ME ALL MAIN
WITNESSES WILL BE TESTIFYING IN
PERSON WE ABOUT TO ME WITNESSES
FOR A MAXIMUM OF THREE MINUTES
EACH ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IS
AVAILABLE IN PERSON OR OVER THE
PHONE FOLLOWING THE TESTIMONY
OF THE MAIN WITNESSES TESTIMONY
WILL BE ACCEPTED ON A FIRST
COME FIRST SERVE BASIS NOT BY
WHETHER IT IS FOR OR AGAINST
THE BILL ALL PUBLIC COMMENT
NEEDS TO FOCUS ON THE BILL AT
HAND IS LIMITED TO THE NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ON THE
BILL ADDITIONAL RUN RELATED
COMMENTS WILL BE RULED OUT
OF ORDER AND WE WILL MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT PERSON TESTIFYING
THAT FACILITATE THE GOALS
OF THIS HEARING WE WILL NOT
ALLOW CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF LEGISLATIVE
PROCEEDINGS WILL NOT ACCEPT
BEHAVIOR THAT INCITES OR
THREATENS VIOLENCE EVEN VEILED
THREATS IN OTHER WORDS NOT A
DIRECT THREAT BUT WHEN THOSE
EASILY UNDERSTOOD AS ONE PLEASE
BE AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS OF
THESE RULES MAY SUBJECT YOU
TO REMOVAL OR OTHER IN FORT
WORTH FOR MISS ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION RESPECT FOR THE
PROCESS TO THE KOBE PANDEMIC
WE HAVE LIMITED SPACE FOR THE
PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE SO WE CAN
SURE EVERYONE MAINTAIN SIXTY TO
SOCIAL DISTANCE THAT EVERYONE'S
HEALTH PLEASE DO NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE YOU COMPLETE
YOUR TESTIMONY MAY LEAVE THE
HEARING ROOM OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT IF SPACE PERMITS WILL BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL
AFTER THE MAIN WITNESS TESTIMONY
THE COLIN FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE EIGHT FIVE
ZERO ONE ONE ZERO ZERO
YOU CAN FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND ON YOUR TV SCREEN
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN
TO DO SO WELL BEFORE THE AUTHOR
BEGINS PRESENTING ON THAT BILL
THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACED INTO THE U. ELIMINATE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE YOU SURE
LIVE STREAM YOU WILL REMAIN
ON A LIFELINE AND WE NEED TO
MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE
CALLED UPON BY THE MODERATOR TO
SPEAK HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE MODERATE MODERATED PHONE
SERVICE CALL THE COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE
TWO ZERO NINE SEVEN AND MY
STAFF WILL TRY TO HELP WE'RE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL WITH INSTRUCTIONS ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE YOU CAN
FIND THE EMAIL FOR THE COMMITTEE
THERE AS WELL THANK YOU FOR
BEING BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
WHILE ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE FACE BILLS WILL BE
HEARD IN THE ORDER OF THE DAILY
FILE TODAY WITH ONE EXCEPTION
MISS WEEKS WILL BE PRESENTING
HER BILL FIRST AND THEN WE'LL
GO BACK TO THE BACK TO FILE
ORDER I'M THE FOLLOWING BILL
-- A. B. TWO THREE SIX FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON IS
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT TODAY WE
HAVE A COUPLE OF OTHER THINGS
GOING ON WE HAVE A SUBSTITUTE
IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER LISA CALDERON
WHO WILL BE REPLACING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIA BONTA WILL
REPLACE THE DEMOCRATIC VACANCY
FOR TODAY'S HEARING WITH THAT
WE WILL GO TO OUR FIRST BILL
-- MISS WICKS YOU HAVE BEFORE
US AB TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE
EVERY READY GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL AND ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS IN CALIFORNIA THE
OVERALL MATERNAL MORTALITY
RATE HAS DECLINED BY SIXTY
FIVE PERCENT SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND SIX HOWEVER MORTALITY
MORBIDITY MORBIDITY FOR
BLACK AND INDIGENOUS PREGNANT
PEOPLE AND BABIES REMAINS
CONSIDERABLY HIGHER THAN THE
STATE'S AVERAGE IN CALIFORNIA
MOREOVER OTHER ANOTHER
POPULATION EXPERIENCING HIGH
NEGATIVE RATES OF PREGNANCY
RELATED AND BIRTH RELATED
OUTCOMES ARE INCARCERATED
BURNING PEOPLE INCARCERATED
WOMEN ARE MORE LIKELY THAN
NOT INCARCERATED WOMEN TO
HAVE COMORBIDITIES AND OTHER
CO EXISTING CONDITIONS THAT
CAN LEAD TO COMPLICATIONS
IN PREGNANCY DOULAS PROVIDE
PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL AND
INFORMATIONAL SUPPORT TO WOMEN
BURNING PEOPLE DURING LABOR
BIRTH AND IN THE IMMEDIATE POST
PARTUM PERIOD STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT YOU LOOK CARE CAN PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS AND HELP
ADDRESS DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH
NEGATIVE PREGNANCY AND BIRTH
OUTCOMES FOR COMMUNITIES WELL
CALIFORNIA'S TAKEN STEPS TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO DO A CARE
FOR LOW INCOME BREATHING PEOPLE
THERE ARE STILL SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
EXPERIENCE PREGNANCY RELATED
AT BIRTH RELATED COMPLICATIONS
AND CANNOT ACCESS TO A CARE
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE WILL
ESTABLISH THE BURNING JUSTICE
FOR CALIFORNIA FAMILIES ACT THIS
BILL WOULD CREATE A THREE YEAR
PILOT PROGRAM TO PROVIDE GRANTS
TO FUND COMMUNITY BASED TOOL
GROUPS AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
TO PROVIDE FULL SPECTRUM DOULA
CARE TO ONE WOMEN AND BURNING
PEOPLE WHO COMMUNITIES SUFFER
FROM HIGH RATES OF NEGATIVE
BIRTH OUTCOMES THAT ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICAL COVERAGE
AND TO INCARCERATED WOMEN AND
BURNING PEOPLE THIS BILL AIMS
TO ADDRESS ADVERSE MATERNAL
AND INFANT HEALTH OUTCOMES
BY EXPANDING DUAL ACCESS AND
RECOGNIZING THAT ALL FOR THE
PEOPLE INCLUDING INCARCERATED
PEOPLE DESERVE DIGNITY AND
BIRTHING I WANT TO THANK
OUR SPONSORS BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS ACTION PROJECT AND
WILL HAVE MY WITNESSES HERE A
SELF INTRODUCED RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU A GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ON THE MAFIA CARE I'M
A POLICY ANALYST WITH WALKING
FOR WELLNESS AND WALKING FROM
THE SECTION PROJECT WE ARE
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION COMMITTED
TO IMPROVING THE OVERALL HEALTH
STATUS AND WELL BEING OF BLACK
WOMEN AND GIRLS WE HAVE OFFICES
IN LOS ANGELES AND STOCKTON AND
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
NINE THE BIRTHING JUSTICE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CALIFORNIANS PILOT
PROJECT THIS BILL WOULD BUILD
UPON THIS OUR STATE EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE BIRTH OUTCOMES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS IN ADVANCE BIRTH
EQUITY BY EXPANDING ACCESS TO
DO WILL CARE CALIFORNIA HAS
MADE COMMENDABLE STRIDES TO
IMPROVE ITS MATERNAL INFANT
HEALTH OUTCOMES YET AND STILL
DEEP INEQUITIES FOR BLACK
WOMEN BIRTHING PEOPLE PERSIST
IN CALIFORNIA BLACK WOMAN --
FOUR TO SIX TIMES MORE LIKELY
TO DIE FROM PREGNANCY RELATED
CAUSES THAN OUR COUNTERPARTS
EVEN AFTER CONTROLLING FOR THE
GENERALLY MITIGATING FACTORS
OF EDUCATION AND SOCIO ECONOMIC
STATUS BLACK WOMEN BIRTHING
PEOPLE REMAINED AT HIGHER RISK
FOR MATERNAL MORTALITY AND
MORBIDITY MOUNTING RESEARCH
POINTS TO RACISM AND IMPLICIT
BIAS IN ADDITION TO OTHER
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH AS
FACTORS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THESE
INEQUITIES DOULA CARE HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED AS AN IMPORTANT TOOL
AND RESOURCE IMPROVING BIRTH
OUTCOMES COMBATING INTERPERSONAL
AND SYSTEMIC RACISM IN OFFERING
CULTURALLY CONGRUENT CARE YET
IT REMAINS A PARTICULARLY UNDER
USED RESOURCE WOMEN OF COLOR
FOLKS WITH THE HIGHEST RISK OF
POOR BIRTH OUTCOMES ARE MOST
LIKELY TO REPORT WANTING BUT
NOT HAVING ACCESS TO DO LIST
SERVICES THIS IS IN LARGE PART
DUE TO THE COST IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE THE ECONOMIC STATUS OF
BLACK WOMEN IS SUCH THAT WE MAKE
ABOUT FIFTY NINE CENTS OF EVERY
DOLLAR THAT A WHITE MAN MAKES
OUT OF POP OUT OF POCKET COSTS
FOR DOULA CARE THAT CAN AMOUNT
TO TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS PLACE IS
THIS IS THIS IS CENTRAL SERVICE
OUT OF REACH FOR THE MAJORITY
OF US A GROUP THAT IS OFTEN
OVERLOOKED ARE INCARCERATED
BREAKING PEOPLE ALMOST THREE
QUARTERS OF INCARCERATED
WOMEN ARE BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND
FORTY FOUR AGE RANGE WHEN MOST
BREAKING PEOPLE BECOME PREGNANT
BEAR CHILDREN SO IT IS LIKELY
THAT A NUMBER OF PEOPLE CAPABLE
OF GIVING BIRTH WILL ENTER OF
PRISONER JAIL WHILE PREGNANT
-- DURING THE POSTPARTUM PERIOD
WITH HIGHER WITH HIGHER RISK OF
ADVERSE BIRTH OUTCOMES ANOTHER
CO EXISTING CONDITIONS THAT
CAN LEAD TO COMPLICATIONS IN
PREGNANCY IF COMPARED TO NON
INCARCERATED WOMEN INCARCERATED
BIRTHING PEOPLE STAND TO BENEFIT
TREMENDOUSLY FROM TO LOOK CARE
THANKS TO AB SEVEN THIRTY TO
INCARCERATED PEOPLE CAN NOW
HAVE A DOULA BUT THERE'S NO
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT
THIS AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
NINE WILL ADVANCE EQUITY BY
ENSURING THAT MORE BIRTHING
PEOPLE PARTICULARLY THOSE IN
THE GAP WHO DO NOT QUALIFY FOR
MEDI CAL BUT COST REMAINS A
BARRIER HAVE ACCESS TO CRITICAL
TO THIS CRITICAL COMPONENT
OF PERINATAL CARE NECESSARY
TO ENJOY A SAFER BIRTHING
EXPERIENCE IT SEEKS TO REMOVE
THE COST BARRIER TO CARE WHILE
ENSURING THAT THE INVALUABLE
SERVICE THAT DO IS PROVIDE IS
RECOGNIZED AND COMPENSATED IN
THE SUSTAINABLE AND EQUITABLE
MANNER IT ALSO ENCOURAGES THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A PIPELINE OF
DO WAS CAPABLE OF OFFERING
CULTURALLY CONGRUENT CARE
EVERYONE DESERVING OF DIGNITY
IN THE SUPPORTS NECESSARY TO
INSURE SAFE HEALTHY ENJOYS BIRTH
EXPERIENCE THIS BILL RECOGNIZES
THAT AND PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO REALIZE THIS VISION AS PROUD
SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
NINE I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE GO
AHEAD HELLO YES I AM A LITTLE
NERVOUS THAT'S OKAY PUSH THE
BUTTON THERE THE BIGGEST FIVE
HI MY NAME IS NICK HEWLETT'S
-- I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM -- I ALSO
SERVE ON ALAMEDA COUNTY'S PAIN
PARAMEDIC EMAIL EQUITY AN ISSUE
THE STEERING COMMITTEE I'M ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE ROOTS OF LABOR
BIRTH COLLECTIVE I'M IN ADDITION
TO THOSE ROLES I'M A FULL
SPECTRUM BIRTH RECORD --
AND I'M HERE TO ADVOCATE FOR A
BI TOOL TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE
-- AS A FULL SPECTRUM BIRTH
RECORDS THERE'S THE BAY AREA I
SUPPORT PRIMARILY CLEAR BLACK
AND OTHER AND OTHER BREATHING
PEOPLE OF COLOR AS A FULL
SPECTRUM DOULA MY JOB IS TO
PROVIDE EMOTIONAL PHYSICAL
SUPPORT FOR BIRTHING FOLKS
AND THEIR PARTNERS I DO THIS
THROUGH A SERIES OF PRENATAL
APPOINTMENTS WHICH PROVIDE
RESOURCES THROUGHOUT PREGNANCY
AND THE POSTPARTUM PERIOD AND
ALSO PROVIDE RESOURCES FOR
FOLKS THAT ARE USUALLY UNHEARD
WHEN THEY GO INTO THE WHEN
THEY GO INTO THE HOSPITAL ROOM
I DO THIS THROUGH A -- I ALSO
PROVIDE POST PARTUM CARE FOR
THESE FOLKS AND PROVIDE A
MORE PERSONAL OUTLOOK WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE BIRTHING
PROCESS I KNOW SOME OF YOU
ARE THINKING WELL WHY DO WE
NEED TO DOULAS THEY'RE DOING
PRENATAL APPOINTMENTS POSTPARTUM
APPOINTMENTS THINGS THAT OBI'S
ALREADY DEAL -- IN REALITY
WE ARE IN A SHORTAGE OF --
BEES AND MIDWIFE'S SO THESE
FOLKS ARE ONLY HAVING TOUCHING
GO POINTS WITH THEIR CLIENTS
THEY'RE CHATTING WITH PREGNANT
FOLKS MAYBE TEN MINUTES MOTHER
CLIENTS THAT I WORK WITH THEM
ACTUALLY COME TO ME TO BE BRIEF
THE PRENATAL APPOINTMENTS THAT
THEY'RE HAVING BECAUSE MANY
TIMES THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEIR DOCTORS ARE EVEN
SAYING TO THEM I COULD GO
-- AND RATTLE OFF A TON OF
STATISTICS AND FACTS THAT YOU
ALREADY KNOW THE MOST DANGEROUS
PLACE FOR A BIRD IN PERSON TO
GIVE BIRTH IS A HOSPITAL AND
MY PRIMARY ROLE IS TO COME
IN AND PROVIDE COMFORT FOR
MY CLIENTS AS WELL AS ANSWER
ANY MEDICAL QUESTIONS THAT
THEY DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
ASKING RECOGNIZING THAT THEIR
VOICES USUALLY GO ON HEARD
SORRY -- WHEN I'M IN A BIRTHING
ROOM WHEN A PERSON IS A LABOR
MANY TIME DOCTORS ARE COMING
IN AND RUSSIAN TELLING THEM
THAT YOU NEED TO MAKE THIS
DECISION NOW OR YOUR BABY'S
LIFE IS IN JEOPARDY MY ROLE IS
TO COME IN AND REMIND THEM WE
CAN SLOW DOWN THIS IS YOUR BODY
THIS IS YOUR CHOICE YOU MADE A
DECISION TO HAVE A BABY AND NO
HOSPITAL'S GONNA RUSH YOU AND
TELL YOU WHAT YOU NEED TO DO
MANY TIMES -- DOULAS ARE
NOT RESPECTED WE'RE SEEN AS
UNIMPORTANT BUT I'LL GIVE YOU
ARE ACTUALLY A PERSONAL ANECDOTE
I WAS WORKING WITH THE CLIENT
THAT GAVE BIRTH IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA -- SHE WAS TOLD
THAT SHE WAS NOT PROVIDE THAT
SHE COULD NOT PROVIDE ENOUGH
BIRTH MARK FOR HER AND ENOUGH
BIRTH BREAST MILK FOR HER CHILD
THE HOSPITAL SAID HERE TAKE
THIS FORMULA WE KNOW YOUR BABY
DOESN'T LIKE IT AND THEY'RE NOT
HOLDING IT DOWN BUT YOU HAVE TO
DO THIS OR IF YOUR BABY IS GOING
TO DIE I THEN MET BOTH MY CLIENT
AND I TALK ABOUT HAND EXPRESSION
AND SHOWED HER DIFFERENT WAYS TO
MANUALLY GET MILK OUT HER BABY
GOT GAMES ONE POUND SIX OUNCES
AND THAT ONE WEEK TIME PERIOD
AND THAT'S A HUGE SIGNIFICAN
THAT'S A HUGE SIGNIFICANCE SO
WE'RE COMING IN WE'RE FILLING
THESE GAPS WERE PROVIDERS
DON'T HAVE THE TIME CAPACITY OR
UNDERSTANDING THANK YOU I
DON'T KNOW SORRY TO GREAT THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE GONNA STOP FOR
A SECOND WE HAVE A QUORUM SO
WE CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT
AND HAVE THIS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE COULD TAKE THE ROLE WHAT
YOU'RE WALDRON YOUR CURRY
ARAMBULA BIGELOW CORREO
LARA MAIENSCHEIN
MAYES MCCARTY NAZARIAN
RIVAS CALDERON
SANTIAGO BONTA YOUR
OKAY OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM
THE BILL SO
OKAY THAT WAS -- HANG ON A
SECOND I'M SLOW HERE TODAY
URRY AND WHO SECONDED IT
THANK YOU OKAY DR
ARAMBULA YES I THANK YOU -- WILL
-- SEE IS THERE ANY ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
NINE IN IN THE IN THE CHAMBER
HERE ANYBODY UP MAP WILL COME
TO THE MICROPHONE IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL FREE
SEE NO ONE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE -- WE
HAVE A MODERATOR THERE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME IN HER FIRST COMMENT
IS FROM LINE NINETY THREE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
I THINK YOU --
THE PROGRAM SOUNDS REALLY GREAT
I JUST HAD SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THE LANGUAGE USED OKAY THE --
SO THAT'S WHY I WHICH AND
SO I'LL POST UNTIL AMENDED
OKAY THANK YOU AND I AND I
RIGHT I SHOULD HAVE STARTED
RIGHT OPEN THE LINES I SHOULD
SAY THIS JUST WHEN WE HAVE
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE IS
JUST YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
IF YOU REPRESENT ONE AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL AND IF
YOU HAVE CONCERNS WERE HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THOSE IN WRITING THROUGH
OUR PORTAL -- AT ON HEALTH
COMMITTEE WEBSITE SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
CONSTRUCTION EXPECTS PERSON
PLACE THE NEXT COMMENT IS
FROM LINE ONE HUNDRED FOURTEEN
AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
GREAT MY NAME IS YOUR
LAST IN I'M SO LARA
SPEAKER DOURA YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION PLEASE
SURE I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT
-- I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THAT
EARLIER -- BUT I JUST WANT
TO LET HER KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW THAT THE MOTHER AND THE
FATHER ZERO THANK YOU HELLO
IT IS NOT REALLY CLEAR HERE
PLEASE -- YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION L. ORGANIZATION YOU
MIGHT REPRESENT PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU -- THE NEXT COMMENT
IS FROM NINE ONE HUNDRED NINE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
OKAY THE NEXT -- GOVERNMENT
TIMELINE OF OPENNESS NINE
NINETY YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
MY NAME IS LAURA MOORE HOUSE
FROM WOMEN'S HEALTH SPECIALISTS
TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CLINIC
THAT SERVES SIXTEEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS AND TWELVE RURAL
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA COUNTIES
AND WE SUPPORT AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY NINE PERCENT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE THE
NEXT KEVIN IS FROM LINE ONE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN HE
I REQUEST ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATION
NEAR OUT PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU THE COLLEGE LIVES
NEXT COMMENT IS FROM NINE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ASSEMBLY GENCO FROM ALL OF
AN ORANGE COUNTY INTO PART
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM NINE
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN HE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MANAGEMENT AFTER
A GIRL AND I LIVE IN A FABULOUS
COUNTY AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
NINE THINGS THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER PLEASE THE NEXT
LINE IS LINE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON ORINDA WAY
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT APOLOGIES
FOR NOT GETTING A LETTER IN
A KIND OF PROBLEM THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE THE NEXT
LINE IS FROM LINE ONE HUNDRED
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN HE
ONE HUNDRED NINE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN HI MY NAME IS
REALLY THE ONLY WAY ALIVE
AND WE NEED TO FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR NINETY NINE THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE THE NEXT
COMMENT IS FROM LINE ONE HUNDRED
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YES L. --
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA NINE IF
SUPPORTERS THE ONE HUNDRED AND
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM THE
LINE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTEEN
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN HELLO
MY NAME IS LUCY QUINTANILLA ON
BEHALF OF MATERNAL AND CHILD
HEALTH ACCIDENTS IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING
PLEASE AND THE NEXT CONFIDENCE
FROM LINE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
HELLO MY NAME IS BRIAN CAN I
REPRESENT A NEW WAY OF LIFE
REENTRY PROJECT AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
BUT THERE ARE NO CUSTOMER
COMMENTS IF YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR
MIA MY BUSINESSES MAKE MISS MISS
BONTA SORRY I JUST
WANTED TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING FOR THIS BILL
AND ALSO JUST TO ACKNOWLEDGE
AND RECOGNIZE BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS -- AND THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM IN AND AT INCOMING
IN COMING TOGETHER TO BE ABLE
TO CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE A
DOULA SERVICES I AS A BLACK
WOMAN ACTUALLY HAD ONE OF MY
SEVEN PREGNANCIES OUT WITH
I DO A LOT AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT IT WAS A MARKEDLY
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE THAN MY
OTHER -- BIRTH IT AND DELIVERY
EXPERIENCES SO ON APPRECIATE
THAT YOU ARE LIFTING UP BLACK
WOMEN ESPECIALLY AND ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE LOWER MATERNAL MORTALITY
RATES AS A RESULT OF HAVING
THESE PROGRAMS IN PLACE AND
I WOULD ASK THAT THE AUTHOR
IF YOU IF YOU ARE CONSIDERING
COST THERE IS TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY ANY OTHER MEMBERS
ST SEEN NONE THE BILL ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND BY DOCTOR
RANDY WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE
I WOULD HAPPILY TAKE YOU ON
AS A CO AUTHOR MISS BONTA
ANYONE ELSE WHO'D LIKE TO
JOIN AS WELL AND WE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OTHERS ARE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHAT I WOULD
AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW NOT VOTING RIO
LARA MAIENSCHEIN MAYES
MAYES AYE MCCARTY NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS
CALDERON CALDERON AYE SANTIAGO
BONTA AYE BONTA AYE
YOUR BILL IS A VOTE IS
OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPENING WAS DEAD ON THANK
YOU SO MUCH THIS BARKING
YOU HAVE BEFORE US AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY SIX
ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
SIX A VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL
THAT STRENGTHENS CURRENT LAN
REFLECTS THE DIVERSE CALIFORNIA
ELIMINATING GENDERED LANGUAGE
IN REFERENCE TO PARENTS LISTED
ON DEATH CERTIFICATES FAMILIES
TODAY AS WE ALL KNOW CAN HAVE
A MOM A DAD OR TWO MOTHERS TWO
FATHERS OR NON BINARY PARENTS
ALL FAMILIES DESERVE TO BE
REPRESENTED AND IDENTIFIED
CORRECTLY LEGAL DOCUMENTATION
REPRESENTATION HAS BEEN AN
ONGOING BATTLE FOR THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY TO GAIN FULL RIGHTS
I AM PROUD TO BE AMONGST THE
CALIFORNIA LAWMAKERS HAVE
ALREADY STARTED PAVING THE WAY
WITH CARVING INCLUSIVITY INTO
OUR LAWS AND ON TO OUR DOCUMENTS
YEAH I WANT TO GIVE CREDIT TO
-- PRO TEM ATKINS HAS BEEN A
LEADER IN THIS FIGHT WITH AB
ONE SEVENTY NINE AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHO REALLY STARTED
THE INCLUSIVITY IN CALIFORNIA
BY MAKING SURE THAT MALE FEMALE
OR NON BINARY INDIVIDUALS WERE
PROPERLY IDENTIFIED ON BIRTH
CERTIFICATES DRIVER'S LICENSE
AND COURT DOCUMENTS BUT WE'VE
YET TO GET THERE AS IDENTIFIED
IN THIS BILL AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO HAVE
AN INCLUSIVE CALIFORNIA WITH
THIS LAW CHANGE TODAY WITH ME
TODAY IN SUPPORT IS TOMMY MARTIN
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
QUALITY CALIFORNIA AND PHILIP
BATCHELDER WHO WILL AND GIVE
SOME OF HIS CLIENT'S TESTIMONY
TODAY WHO'S BEEN AFFECTED
BY THE CURRENT LAW THANK YOU
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY AFTERNOON
CHIANG COMMITTEE MEMBERS TOMMY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA WE ARE PROUD TO
SPONSOR THIS BILL WHICH WILL
NOT ONLY MAKE US DIFFICULT IT'S
MORE ACCURATE BUT BRING THEM
IN LINE WITH EXISTING LAW IN
CALIFORNIA THAT RECOGNIZES THE
DIVERSITY OF MODERN FAMILIES
HERE JUST ONE EXAMPLE LAST
YEAR WE SPONSORED THE BILL
AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BARRICADE HAND TO ADD NON
BINARY AS A GENDER OPTION TO
DUST CERTIFICATES AND WITHOUT
THIS BILL AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
SIX WILL BE IN A SORT OF LIMBO
WHERE THE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE DECEDENT CAN BE ACCURATE
BUT THE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
DECEDENT'S PARENTS CANNOT BE
-- WHICH COMPLICATES LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS FOLLOWING A DEATH
AND COMPOUNDS THE TRAUMA AND
GRIEF THAT PARENTS ARE ALREADY
EXPERIENCING FOLLOWING THE LOSS
OF A CHILD AND WE'LL HEAR MORE
ABOUT THE REAL WORLD IMPACT OF
THIS ISSUE FOR MY CO IN THIS
IN A MOMENT BUT OVERALL THIS
BUILDS UPON THE LEGISLATURE'S
WORK TO ENSURE THAT LGBTQ PLUS
FAMILIES ARE BOTH RESPECTED
AND REFLECTED IN CALIFORNIA
LAW SO WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT AS
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M READING
MY NAME IS PHILIP ABOUT CHILDREN
A LAWYER PRACTICING IN BERKELEY
AND I'M HERE TO READ A STATEMENT
FROM MY CLIENT DRUSILLA CEREN
I DO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY SIX TO
UPDATE THE STATE'S CERTIFICATE
OF DEATH FORM AFTER NINE YEARS
TOGETHER MY REGISTERED DOMESTIC
PARTNER AND I WANTED TO ADD TO
OUR FAMILY THAT THEN CONSISTED
OF MY TWO DAUGHTERS AFTER THREE
DIFFICULT YEARS OF TRYING TO
CONCEIVE MY SON A KIVA SERIN
D. MARIN US WAS BORN INTO A
FAMILY THAT WAS JUBILANT AT
HIS ARRIVAL I WAS THE FIRST
PERSON TO HOLD HIM BUT I COULD
NOT BE ON HIS BIRTH CERTIFICATE
BECAUSE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
ONLY ONE MOTHER AND ONE FATHER
COULD BE LISTED MY PARTNER
THE BIRTH MOTHER WAS LISTED AS
THE MOTHER WE PURSUE THE BIZARRE
METHOD THAT LESBIANS FOLLOWED
WHICH WAS TO REQUEST AN ADOPTION
THAT HAD TO BE EVALUATED BY
A SOCIAL WORKER WHO WAS THEN
REQUIRED TO DENY IT BECAUSE OF
THE LAW AT THE TIME THEN WE
APPEAL TO THE SUPERIOR COURT
WHERE JUDGE CAN CALL WHAT YOU
TO CREATE THAT I WAS A KEEP AS
LEGAL ADOPTED MOTHER I ACTIVELY
REMAIN HIS MOTHER THROUGHOUT HIS
CHILDHOOD IN OUR JOINT CUSTODY
ARRANGEMENT AND PAID CHILD
SUPPORT FOR ELEVEN YEARS WHEN
HIS OTHER MOTHER AND I SEPARATED
I KEEP IT WAS AN INDUSTRIOUS
HIGHLY SKILLED INTELLIGENCE
ANALYST WHO SERVED IN THE
MARINES I WAS DETERMINED TO EARN
ENOUGH MONEY TO RETIRE AT FORTY
AT THE TIME OF HIS DEATH AT
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS IN FEBRUARY
TWENTY SIXTEEN OUR RELATIONSHIP
HAS ONLY DEEPENED IN CONTRAST
HE RARELY SAW HIS BIRTH
MOTHER THIS LAWSUIT BROUGHT MY
DAUGHTERS GRANDCHILDREN AND ME
INEXPRESSIBLE PAIN THAT SCARCELY
LESSONS OVER TIME MEANWHILE
SINCE OUR SEPARATION MY FORMER
PARTNER AND I DID NOT HAVE AN
AMICABLE RELATIONSHIP SHE WAS
A VENGEFUL AND DISHONEST PERSON
AFTER A KIVA DIED SHE USED HIS
CERTIFICATE OF DEATH WHICH ONLY
BORE HER NAME AND FALSELY
CLAIMED TO BE THE ONLY LIVING
PARENT PARENT IN ORDER TO
COLLECT HIS ENTIRE EIGHTEEN
ANTI RETIREMENT ACCOUNT WORTH
ROUGHLY A THOUSAND A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS SHE ALSO
PURSUED WHATEVER INSURANCE
THE MARINE CORPS PAYS HIS
FIVE BEDROOM VIRGINIA HOME
AND ITS CONTENTS INCLUDING
BILLION WORTH THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS HIS AUTOMOBILE AND
OTHER ASSETS UNKNOWN TO ME
THE DEATH CERTIFICATE FIGURED
INTO ALL HER EFFORTS THOUGH I
CAN ONLY CONFIRM THAT IT WAS
DETERMINATIVE IN REGARDS TO
THE RETIREMENT ACCOUNT I DID
NOT NEED THE MONEY ALTHOUGH
OTHERS IN MY POSITION MIGHT
HAVE NONE THE LESS IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN WONDERFUL TO CREATE
COLLEGE FUNDS FOR HIS NEPHEWS
FOR EXAMPLE AND I KNOW A KIVA
WOULD'VE BEEN LIVID AT HIS OTHER
MOTHER WHO ARRANGED TO GIVE
WHAT YOU INHERITED OR STOLE
FROM HIS A STATE TO PEOPLE HE
HARDLY KNEW SHE DIED NOT LONG
AFTER HE DID ALL OF THIS IS
MADE LOSING A KIVA HARDER TO
BEAR BUT THE PIECE THAT STINGS
ME THE MOST IS HAVING BEEN
DENIED ONCE AGAIN AS A RESULT
OF CALIFORNIA'S DEFICIENT
DEATH CERTIFICATE FORM THE
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT A KIVA AND
I WERE LEGALLY SON AND MOTHER
I URGE YOU TO UPDATE THIS FORM
TO REFLECT THE MANY FORMS FAMILY
MAY TAKE AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
SIX ADDRESSES THE VERY IMPORTANT
EFFICIENCY OF HIGHLIGHTED IF
APPROVED IT WILL SURELY PROTECT
OTHER CALIFORNIANS FROM SOME
OF THE ANGUISH I'VE EXPERIENCED
THANK YOU DRUSILLA SARIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
SEE NON -- THEIR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT AND
SUPPORT OPPOSITION HERE IN
THE CHAMBER WHO WOULD LIKE
TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION C. NINE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES --
MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES WITNESSES CALLING
IN PLEASE LIST YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL AND ANY
ORGANIZATION YOU MIGHT BELONG TO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO COMMENT AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO IN THEIR FIRST COME
ADDITIONAL LINE OF ONE HUNDRED
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARED HER
MEMBERS MY MISSION A LARGE AND
COMPLEX ACCOUNTING -- THE ONLY
OPPOSITION I REALLY HAVE TO
THIS IS THE FACT THAT WHEN
YOU WHEN YOU WEIGH IN JUST
YOUR PERSON SEES ME JUST YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL AND ANY
ORGANIZATION YOU MIGHT BELONG TO
THE WATER STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU OKAY PERFECT THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE NEXT CALL IS K.
K. THE NEXT LINE IS ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HI THIS IS A BAD ONE IT CAN
YOU COUNT ACTION REPORT THANK
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE THE BILL
HAS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
ARE YOU ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS --
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU SO THERE
IS A MOTION BY MISTER MAYES A
SECOND BY MISTER NAZARIAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO PREPARATIONS WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE PLEASE AM I JUST WANTED
TO TOUCH ON WHAT YOU HEARD FROM
THEM THE MOTHER WHO SPOKE MY
SISTER AND HER WIFE HAD TO GO
THROUGH THE PAINFUL PROCESS
OF ADOPTING MY TWO NIECES
FROM ONE ANOTHER BECAUSE OF
THE ARCANE LAWS DIDN'T ALLOW
THEM TO BE CONSIDERED MOTHERS
UPON THE BIRTH OF MY NIECES
ANY IDEA THAT UPON THEIR DEATH
THEY WOULDN'T BE ACKNOWLEDGED IS
BEYOND REPROACH AND SO WE HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TODAY TO CHANGE
THAT AND I HOPE YOU'LL JOIN ME
IN DOING SO EXPECT ASPEN EITHER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADAM
SECRETARY THE MOTION DO IT IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED PREPARATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WHAT I WALDRON WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW NOT VOTING CARILLO
LARA MAIENSCHEIN MAYES
MAYES AYE MCCARTY
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS
CALDERON CALDERON I SANTIAGO
BONTA I BONTA HI
YOUR BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES IT'S
OUT WE WILL LEAD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER BRIAN
SHOP FOR I
HATE MATH
YOU HAVE AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR
FAN OF THESE NEW COMMITTEE ROOMS
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR --
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN A BILL THAT
WOULD CREATE THE ALTERNATIVES
TO INCARCERATION COMMISSION
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL AND WORKING WITH MY
TEAM WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS OUR STATE
HAS ROUGHLY TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED WE ALSO SPEND
OVER FOURTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
JUST IN STATE CORRECTIONS
EXPENDITURES WE HAVE USED OVER
THE YEARS INCARCERATION AS
THE FIRST CHOICE AND LAST WAYS
TO SOLVE MOST OF OUR SOCIAL
PROBLEMS OVER TEN PERCENT
OF PEOPLE IN CUSTODY HAVE
AN OPEN MENTAL HEALTH CASE
THERE'S AN URGENT NEED TO GIVE
PEOPLE ACCESS TO RESOURCES
ROOTED IN CARE AN OPPORTUNITY
WE STILL SPEND OVER A HUNDRED
AND TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
PERSON DON'T CARCERI PEOPLE
IN THE SYSTEM THAT EXACERBATES
THE ROUTE CONDITIONS OF
STRUGGLE POVERTY AND ADVERSE
HEALTH CONDITIONS STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE INCARCERATED HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER RATES
OF MORE BILL IT MORBIDITY AND
MORTALITY THAN TO THE GENERAL
PUBLIC A RECENT STUDY FOUND THAT
INCARCERATIONS STRONGLY CURRENT
A CORRELATED WITH DEPRESSION AND
HOSTILITY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
ARE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE LIKELY
TO DEVELOP PSYCHIATRIC DISORDERS
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE INCARCERATED
EXHIBIT HIGH BURDEN OF CHRONIC
AND NON COMMUNICABLE DISEASES
LIKE HYPERTENSION DIABETES
ASTHMA AS WELL AS COMMUNICABLE
DISEASES LIKE HEPATITIS HIV
TUBERCULOSIS MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS A REPRESENTATIVE
SAMPLE OF INDIVIDUALS RELEASED
FROM CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES
NOTED THAT MOST HAD AT LEAST ONE
PHYSICAL MENTAL OR SUBSTANCE
USE ELEMENT NEARLY FORTY PERCENT
OF MEN AND OVER FORTY NINE OVER
SIXTY PERCENT OF WOMEN HAD CO
ACCORDING OCCURRING DISORDERS
FOLLOWING THEIR RELEASE THESE
ARE JUST SOME EXAMPLES OF
THE REAL EFFECTS THEY CAN BE
BETTER ADDRESSED BY COMMUNITY
HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS AND
CARE BASED RESOURCES AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OVER A DECADE
OF THOUGHTFUL ORGANIZING LED
TO COMMUNITY MEMBERS PUSHING
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO
DEVELOP AND ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION WORKGROUP ROOTED
IN PUBLIC HEALTH AND CARE
WAS CHAIRED BY DR BOB ROSS
OF THE CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT
AND IT LED TO OVER A HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN RECOMMENDATIONS
INCLUDING TO ESTABLISH AN
OFFICE OF ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION THE COUNTY LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FOLLOWED SUIT
ON THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
IS SUPPORTING THIS BILL ONE
IMPORTANT THING TO NOTE THOSE
IN THOSE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE SOME
JURISDICTIONAL CONCERNS AT THE
COUNTY DID NOT HAVE THE FULL
AUTHORITY TO REALLY BUILD OUT
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE NEEDED
FOR FOLKS THERE WAS A ROLE FOR
THE STATE TO STEP IN AND RATHER
THAN FORCE THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
ON THE STATE OUT RIGHT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA GO
THROUGH THE SAME PROCESS OF
OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE
GONE THROUGH DEVELOP THOUGHTFUL
SOLUTIONS CONVENE A TASK FORCE
TO MOVE EXPEDITIOUSLY TO THINK
ABOUT HOW WE MIGHT BETTER SERVE
PEOPLE WITH THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE THAT IS ONLY EXACERBATED
BY CONDITIONS OF INCARCERATION
JOINING ME TODAY IS MARK ANTONY
CLAYTON JOHNSON IS THE FOUNDER
OF THE FRONTLINE WELLNESS
NETWORK IT'S AT THE
INTERSECTION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND INCARCERATION IS ALSO THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF DIGNITY
AND POWER NOW -- AND WITH THAT
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO THE CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M REALLY HAPPY TO BE
SPEAKING TO YOU TODAY ON THE
ROLE THAT PUBLIC HEALTH PLEASE
IN THIS IMPORTANT QUESTION
ON SAFETY AND WELL BEING FOR
OUR COMMUNITIES -- IT'S THE
PERFECT TIME TO ACTUALLY HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION AS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH FIELD IS TAKEN A FIRM
STANCE ON THE QUESTION IN TWENTY
TWENTY THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
HEALTH ASSOCIATION FORMALLY
ADOPTED A POLICY POSITION
THAT INCARCERATION IS IN FACT
A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS I CAN
BE REMEDIED WITH PREVENTATIVE
MEASURES AND ALTERNATIVES THE
FRONT MY WELLNESS NETWORK IN
FACT WAS FOUNDED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN RESPONSE TO A
LOCAL EXPRESSION OF THAT CRISIS
OUR COUNTY WAS MOVING FORWARD
WITH A THREE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR MENTAL HEALTH JAIL
PLAN IN A TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR WOMEN'S JAIL PLAN IT'S
WORTH NOTING THAT SIXTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE WOMEN'S JAIL
POPULATION I STRUGGLE WITH SOME
FORM OF MENTAL DISABILITY OR
TRAUMA WE WERE ABLE TO STOP
THAT PLAN AS PART OF A MUCH
BROADER COALITION BY PIPELINE
PUBLIC HEALTH PRINCIPLES TO A
VISION OF THE SOLUTION FOR US
A BUILDING THAT SOLUTION UP MEN
APPLYING THE PRINCIPLE TO CREATE
SOLUTIONS WHERE PEOPLE LIVE WORK
PLAY RATHER THAN RELYING ON THE
PATIENT TO COME TO US -- THE
LATTER IN THE CONTEXT OF HOUSING
CRISIS JOB INSTABILITY IN A DIRT
THE COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
HAS RESULTED IN A LOS ANGELES
AND A CALIFORNIA WITH THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE HAVE ONLY FOUND
ACCESS TO A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEADS ACCESS TO A CLINICIAN TO
A JAIL TERM OR PRISON SENTENCE
I WILL RECONSIDER THAT LAST
YEAR WAS THE DEADLIEST YEAR
IN ALMOST A DECADE FOR PEOPLE
INCARCERATED IN OUR COUNTY
JAILS I AM LOS ANGELES AND
AS CLINICIANS CONTINUE TO TELL
US THAT IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO
PROVIDE OPTIMUM CARE IN THE
JAILS THE IMPLICATIONS OF THE
OF THESE HEALTH IMPACT OF THESE
HEALTH OUTCOMES ARE PRETTY
GRAVE AND ALARMING STUDY OUT
OF VANDERBILT UNIVERSITY IN
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN SHOWED
US THAT FOR EVERY YEAR A PERSON
IS INCARCERATED THEY LOSE TWO
YEARS OF LIFE SPAN HOWEVER
THIS IS WHERE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH BECOMES A
MANDATE THAT LIFESPAN CAN BE
RECOVERED IF IN FACT PEOPLE
GET OFF PROBATION IF THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO HOUSING HEALTH CARE
MEANINGFUL EMPLOYMENT AND IF WE
AVOID JAIL INCARCERATION
PERIOD SECONDLY A NATIONAL STUDY
IN THE AMERICAN JOURNAL PUBLIC
HEALTH FOUND THAT INCREASES
INCREASED INCARCERATION
RATES AND LOCAL COUNTIES WERE
CORRELATED WITH MORTALITY
RATES INCREASING IN THAT COUNTY
BROADLY AND SO THE SPILLOVER
EFFECT IS VERY REAL LAWCENTER
COUNTIES YOU KNOW IS HOME TO THE
LARGEST JAIL SYSTEM IN THE WORLD
WITH THE LARGEST MENTAL HEALTH
FACILITY IN THE COUNTRY -- YOU
COULD IMAGINE OUR ALARM AS WE
CONSIDER THE BROADER HEALTH
IMPLICATIONS OF LIFESPAN ANXIETY
DEPRESSION SUICIDALITY IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD ADVERSE EXPERIENCES
AS WE COMB THE DATA AND FOUND
THAT BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
AND TEN AND TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN BLACK WOMEN ALONE HEADED
TOWARD ROUGHLY FIVE THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE YEARS
OF JAIL TIME IN THAT SIX YEAR
PERIOD LET NEXT WOMEN SIX
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS OF JAIL TIME IN
THAT SIX YEAR PERIOD THE TOP
FIVE REASONS FOR THOSE ARRESTED
INCLUDED A DRIVING ON A
SUSPENDED LICENSE THEFT FAILURE
TO APPEAR IN COURT SESSION
OF A CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE
AND D. WISE ADDITIONALLY
ARE COUNTY SPENT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY INCARCERATING
BLACK HOUSELESS PEOPLE FOR
SIMILAR CHARGES AND WHEN WE AS
CLINICIANS SAW THOSE CHARGES WE
DIDN'T SEE CRIMES WE SAW ACTS
OF SURVIVAL WE SEE ATTEMPTS
AT STABILITY WE SAW COPING
MECHANISMS THAT REQUIRED
UPSTREAM INTERVENTIONS AS
SOMEONE WHO CONTRIBUTE DIRECTLY
TO THE WRITING OF THE JAIL
LAST CARE FIRST -- DOCUMENT
AND REPORT THAT WAS APPROVED
BY LOS ANGELES COUNTY I'M
VERY PROUD OF THE PROCESS --
AND ENCOURAGED BY THE STATE
CONSIDERING A SIMILAR PROCESS
TO ADDRESS LONGSTANDING HARMS OF
PUNISHMENT AS A PARADIGM IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT WE BASE
ALL RECOMMENDATIONS ON PILOTS
THAT ALREADY ARE STANDING UP IN
THAT WORK EVERY DAY FOR EXAMPLE
IN LOS ANGELES OUR OFFICE
OF DIVERSION AND REENTRY --
DIVERTS PEOPLE WITH VERY SERIOUS
MENTAL HEALTH DISABILITIES
AND VERY SERIOUS CHARGES
INCLUDING VIOLENT CHARGES TO
COMMUNITY BASED CARE AND WHAT
WE HAVE FOUND IS THAT JUDGES
CLINICIANS DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
AND CERTAINLY THE COMMUNITY ALL
AGREE THAT THE SAFEST PLACE
FOR PEOPLE IN THESE CONDITIONS
IS COMMUNITY BASED CARE THE
SAFEST PLACE CERTAINLY FOR
THEM AND FOR THE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE THE OUTCOMES FAR FAR
OUTDO THE OUTCOMES INCARCERATION
IN TERMS OF RECIDIVISM IN TERMS
OF WELL BEING AND IN TERMS OF
SAFETY FOR THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
-- WHEN WE TAKE A SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH APPROACH
TO MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE
TO HOUSES NOUS INTO VIOLENCE
WE SEE PROVEN OUTCOMES AND
PREVENTION WE SEE REDUCTIONS
IN HARM'S AND VIOLENCE WE
SEE REDUCING RECIDIVISM IN
IMPROVING THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF COMMUNITIES NAMIK
COURAGE THAT ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN SEVENTY OFFERS US
A WELL CRAFTED GROUNDED AND
PRAGMATIC APPROACH TO APPLYING
THE STRATEGIES STATEWIDE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
SEEING NO ONE WOULD ANYBODY
IN THE CHAMBER LIKE TO TESTIFY
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
IT'S JUST WITH YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IS COME FOR
ONLY C. LEWIS ON BEHALF
OF DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
C. KNOWN WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES IN SECONDS BUT
YES BUT THE PHONE LINES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU
LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME THE
FIRST COMPANIES FROM LINE ONE
HUNDRED SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS
MARK HEATER ON BEHALF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM LINE
ONE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CURTIS LANE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM
NINE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM
WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON WHICH
QUESTION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM
LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
HELLO CHAIR AND MEMBERS
SENATE BILL WATERHOUSE
THE REPORT OF A
BEATING YEAH THANK YOU
OKAY NEXT COMPETITION
LIGHT ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
SHALLOW WATER ON THE BALLOT
PROJECT WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
THAT MEANS THAT PROGRAM ALL
OF AN ORANGE COUNTY AND I AM
INCOME SUPPORT THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM NINE
ONE HUNDRED TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN SACRAMENTO CALIF
ESSIE JUSTICE GROUP ABOUT
CO SPONSORS BY THE CAREFIRST
COALITION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU STOCKLEY'S
THE NEXT ONE IS FROM LINE ONE
HUNDRED NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
I DIDN'T REALLY KNOW WHERE
I LIVE OUR CORRESPONDENT
EIGHTY SEVEN STONE TEMPLE
THANK YOU THE NEXT COMEDIES
FROM LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
HI THIS IS THE WAY THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION THAT THE
COURT THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMPANIES FROM
LINE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
HI THIS IS THE AMBER ROSE BROKE
SOME DIGNITY AND POWER NOW
IN THE JUSTICE LA COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SIXTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMPETITION ONLINE
A ONE HUNDRED FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THE NEXT COMMENT
IS FROM NINE EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
ONE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HELLO THIS
IS JANE DINNER WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM I.
NINETY HERE LINE IS NOW OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
MY NAME IS DIANE THE GIRL
AND I AM CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT TO AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
ON BEHALF OF ALL OF US AND
THEN LOS ANGELES THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMPETITION
LINE ONE HUNDRED EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
HELLO MY NAME IS BRIAN CAN I
REPRESENT A NEW WAY OF LIFE FOR
ENTRY PROJECT WE ARE CO SPONSORS
ON A. B. SIXTEEN SEVENTY AND
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THE NEXT COMPETITION LINE ONE
HUNDRED FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HE HELLO MY
NAME IS ALTHOUGH MENDOZA
I AM IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM
LINE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN HI
MY NAME IS MARIE MCCLELLAN
WITH THEM LARGISH ACCESS
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
THE NET THE NEXT COMMENT IS
FROM LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
YEAH BROUGHT SOME DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL WE SUPPORTED VERY
STRONGLY THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMMENT IS
FROM THE LINE EIGHTY
FOUR HERE LINE IS NOW
OPEN HI MY NAME IS
RUBY GOOD TERRORISM
COLLINS A PORT THANK YOU
IF THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
MISTER CHAIR THANK VERY MUCH
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF MISS WALDRON HAS
A QUESTION FOR MR MAYES THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M
YOU'RE TAKING ON A BIG ISSUE
WHICH IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
ME PERSONALLY -- AS WELL --
I OWN A BUSINESS WHICH HIRED
PEOPLE WHO HAD BEEN PREVIOUSLY
INCARCERATED FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND I SAW YOU KNOW
UP CLOSE AND PERSONAL THE
STRUGGLE THAT PEOPLE HAD I MEAN
WE KNOW THE STATISTICS THAT
SHOW OF THE LEVEL OF TRAUMA
THE PEOPLE HAVE HAD IN THE LIVES
BEFORE THEY EVER COMMIT THE
CRIME NO ONE SAYING YOU KNOW
THEY THEY HAVEN'T COMMITTED
A CRIME AND YOU KNOW THERE'S
OPTIONS AVAILABLE WHETHER IT'S
-- PRISON JAIL TREATMENT
-- I THINK EVERYONE WOULD AGREE
WITH THAT BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
POVERTY -- THE PHYSICAL ABUSE
THE SEXUAL ABUSE ESPECIALLY
A CAR SORRY WOMEN IT CAN
BE AS HIGH AS IN THE EIGHTY
PERCENTILE WHO HAVE HAD WHO HAD
SEXUAL ABUSE -- PRIOR
TO THEIR INCARCERATION ARM
SO HAVING SEEN THAT AND
HAVING SEEN MY EMPLOYEES
EVERY TIME ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT OF THE TIME FALL OFF
AFTER ABOUT TWO YEARS AND
GET PICKED UP AGAIN AND GO
BACK INTO WHATEVER SITUATION
THEY WERE IN JAIL PRISON --
OR I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED TO THEM --
BUT I KNOW THEY'RE CAUGHT ONE
IN THE IN PARTICULAR HAD BEEN
STABBED IN I MEAN IT'S NEVER
A GOOD LIFE IT'S A CYCLE AND
YOU SEE IT NO MATTER HOW HARD
I TRIED AS A BUSINESS OWNER --
AND I HAVE A LOT OF IDEAS WHAT
COULD BE DONE FROM THAT ASPECT
BUT IT'S THERE'S SO MANY LAWS
AND PRIVACY AND ALL THESE THINGS
THAT GET IN THE WAY OF BEING
ABLE TO TRY TO HELP SOMEBODY
SO -- THAT BEING SAID
WHEN I WAS A FRESHMAN LEGISLATOR
I JUST HAPPENED TO BE SITTING
IN MY APARTMENT AND THERE
WAS A DOCUMENTARY ON ABOUT
THE LA COUNTY JAIL SYSTEM
AND ALSO THE WOMEN'S PRISON
AND HOW AND WE KNOW THE JAILS
ARE AT THE LA COUNTY JAILS
ONE OF THE LARGEST MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS THAT WE HAVE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND THAT'S UNFORTUNATE --
I SAW THESE WOMEN SITTING
AND THEY INTERVIEWED THEM AND
ASKED THEM HOW MANY TIMES HAVE
YOU BEEN INCARCERATED TWELVE
TIMES FIFTEEN TIMES TWENTY
TIMES AND IT'S LIKE THEY HAVE
CHILDREN EVERYONE OF THEM WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO THOSE KIDS SO I'M
I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE LONG TERM
EFFECTS OF FAMILY SEPARATION
THAT'S A BIG ISSUE THAT JUST
INCREASES THAT CYCLE AGAIN
INTO THE NEXT GENERATION SO
-- A COUPLE OF THINGS I IT
I THINK THE GOAL IS
THAT WE KNOW THAT WE EXACERBATE
THOMAS IN THING CARCERAL SETTING
SO HOW THE GOAL SEEMS TO BE HOW
CAN WE HEAL TRAUMAS AND BRING
PEOPLE TO ACTUAL RESTORATION
I THINK THAT'S YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO SO
IT I'LL SAVE MONEY SAVE
LIVES REDUCE RECIDIVISM REDUCE
CRIME IN THE LONG RUN SO
I SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY AND
THE ONLY THING I WOULD SUGGEST
IF YOU DO AN AMENDMENT IF THERE
COULD BE SOME LAW ENFORCEMENT
REPRESENTATION ON THE COMMISSION
JUST TO KIND OF SEE YOU KNOW
THEIR SIDE OF IT OR THEIR VIEW
OR TO BE HELPFUL IN
IT THIS I KNOW THERE'S A A LOT
OF FOLKS ON THAT ON THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SIDE THAT REALLY DO
WANT TO SEE PEOPLE GET RESTORED
SO THANK YOU BECAUSE WATER
CAN WE TAKE THAT AS A MOTION
THANK YOU SECOND BY MISTER
MISTER AND MISTER MAYES --
I WAS GONNA MAKE AT MAKE THE
MAKE THE MOTION -- MISTER
BRIAN -- WILL YOU'RE GONNA
LORD'S WORK HERE -- WE
-- HAVE AGREED ON SOME CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM AND WE'VE
DISAGREED ON -- ON SOME THINGS
-- BUT CREATING A COMMISSION
THAT IS GOING TO LOOK AT
ALTERNATIVES TO INCARCERATION
WHY WILL WE BE OPPOSED TO THAT
-- WE KNOW THAT IF YOU DO
SOMETHING WRONG -- YOU GOT
TO BE HELD TO ACCOUNT -- AS
A AS PARENTS I'M A NEW PARENT
I'M SURE THERE'S GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT OPTIONS THAT I'M GONNA
HAVE WHETHER I'M SENDING MY
CHILD PUT IN THE CORNER OTHER
WAYS OF BEING ABLE TO A TO DO
THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO PICK
THE SAME THING OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN THIS IDEA THAT WE
WOULD JUST PUT PEOPLE IN JAIL OR
PRISON AND THAT'S THE ONLY WAY
THAT WE'RE GONNA HOLD PEOPLE TO
ACCOUNT -- I THINK WE ARE LONG
PAST THAT THERE'S NO REASON
WHY WE SHOULDN'T TAKE A LOOK AT
OUR SYSTEM FIGURE OUT WAYS TO
BE ABLE TO HOLD A PEOPLE TO TO
AN ACCOUNT SO YOU'RE DOING THE
LORD'S WORK HERE -- -- AT ALL
I WAS GOING TO MAKE THE MOTION
ABOUT I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A AS A CO AUTHOR IF YOU HAVE ME
THANK YOU ANY ANY OTHER MEMBERS
C. NONE -- YOU HAVE ACCEPTED
THE AMENDMENT SAID THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT THE THERE
IS A MOTION BY MISS WALDRON
A SECOND BY MISTER NAZARIAN
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH LIKE
CLOSE MISTER BRYANT AT THANK
YOU TO THIS COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND YOUR FEEDBACK AND
THANK YOU TO MY FORMER C. MAY
FROM ACROSS THE AISLE WE'D BE
HAPPY TO ADD YOU AS A CO AUTHOR
THIS IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
WORK OUR COMMUNITIES KNOW WHAT
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS NOW AND I
THINK IT'S TIME FOR THE STATE
TO GO THROUGH THE PROCESS
OF KNOWING AS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE WALDRON
WALDRON AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW NO
REAL LARA
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MAYES
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE NAZARIAN NAZARIAN I
REQUEST RIVAS I CALDERON
SANTIAGO
BONTA I ALSO I
THIS YEAR YOUR BILL HAS NINE
VOTED OUT OF COMMITTEE WILL
LEAD THE ROLLOVER FOR OTHERS
AT ON THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CUNNINGHAM YES
PLEASE COME FORWARD
YOU HAVE AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BERS
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE EMT PARAMEDICS TO
COMPLETE A MINIMUM OF TWENTY
MINUTES OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AWARENESS TRAINING UPON ISSUANCE
AND RENEWAL OF THEIR LICENSE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AS WE ALL
KNOW IS THE FASTEST GROWING
CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE IN THE
WORLD CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN SEEING
INCREASES IN HUMAN TRAFFICKING
THE EXCEED ALMOST ANY OTHER
STATE EVEN ADJUSTED PER CAPITA
THIS BILL I BELIEVE BUILDS ON
TRAINING THAT THIS LEGISLATORS
PUT INTO PLACE AND AN ARRAY
OF OTHER INDUSTRIES INCLUDING
HOTELS MOTELS AIRLINES --
LAW ENFORCEMENT OBVIOUSLY
I THINK IT'S A LOGICAL NEXT
STEP AND BY GIVING PARAMEDICS
THE TRAINING TO RECOGNIZE THE
SIGNS THE HOPE IS WE PUSH MORE
REPORTING AND INTERVENTION TO
BREAK THE CYCLE FOR THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS THE FIGHT
AND FIND THEMSELVES ENCOUNTER
BY PARAMEDICS I'D ALSO LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT THIS DOES NOT
RAISE ANY FEES -- THAT THESE
TRAINING MODULES ARE PUT ON FOR
FREE BY PLAYERS PROJECT BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
-- BY UNITED AGAINST HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SO WE HAVE AVAILABLE
RESOURCES THAT CAN BE ACCESSED
TO SATISFY THIS REQUIREMENT
WITHOUT ANY ADDITIONAL COST FOR
THE LICENSEES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY BOOK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
NO OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANYONE IN THE CHAMBER RATHER
WISHING TO SUPPLY YEAH
REGISTER SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
YOU KNOW ONE WILL GO TO THE
A A BIT OF TELEPHONE LINES
MISTER OPERATIVE -- DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE
AND LAYS GENERAL VIEW WHICH
WAS NOT HAVE SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WAIT FOR A FIRST PARTY
BE JUST ANOTHER MOMENT
YOUR PATIENCE BE
JUST ANOTHER MOMENT
AND WE'RE GOOD TO GO
TO LINE NUMBER ONE
FIFTIES PLEASE GO AHEAD
BUT ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
SO I JUST JOHN JOIN THE CALL
THE JUST DO IT ALREADY TWO
ONE THREE I JUST ON THE CALL
AND SORRY THIS YEAR IN JUST
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
IF YOU REPRESENT ONE OF YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE
AND I KINDLY ASK -- BECAUSE WHEN
I WAS TALKING TO THE OPERATOR
COMES TO WHAT YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT CURRENTLY ISN'T ALREADY
ON THE TWO ONE THREE ZERO OR I
WAS ON ONE SIX SEVEN AND I
APOLOGIZE THAT'S OKAY THIS
IS THIS IS TWO ONE THREE ZERO
YES SO I'M CALLING TO SUPPORT
THAT THE -- THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NOBODY ELSE TO Q. THANK YOU I
THINK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
GOOD WE HAVE A MOTION BY
DOCTOR REGULAR SECOND BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY WHICH I TO CLOSE
MISTER CUNNINGHAM I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU THANK
YOU -- THERE IS A PROMOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT SO MA'AM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD AYE AND WALDRON WALDRON
I -- CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO LARA
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MAYES
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY I AM
IS THERE IN THIS AREA I
RIVAS RIVAS I CALDERON
CALDERON AYE SANTIAGO
BONTA I BONTA HI
ELEVEN THIS YEAR THE BILL
HAS ELEVEN VOTES YOUR BILLS
OUT WILL EITHER A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER SET UP THANKS MISTER
CUNNINGHAM -- MISTER GIBSON
WHAT WHAT MISTER GIBSON'S
COMING UP TWO WEEKS WE GET A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH INCLUDES ONE BILL
OKAY IT'S A BIT IT'S A MISTER
NAZARIAN IS A SECOND BY MR
MCCARTY IS AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON -- MEN SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHAT I
WHEN I WALDRON WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO LARA
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MAYES
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY I
THIS AREA THIS AREA AND I
REQUEST RIVAS I CALDERON
CALDERON I SANTIAGO
BONTA I WANT TO I
ELEVEN ZERO SO -- WITH
CONSECUTIVE PASSES LIBERAL OPEN
FOR OTHER STAT ON MISTER GIPSON
IF AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU COMMITTED
ALLOW ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX
WHICH SEEKS TO EXPAND THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDS THAT WILL
ALLOW -- MARKING COMMUNITY
MAR THE KING JUNIOR COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL TO COVER HOSPITAL
BASED OUT OF OUT PATIENT
SERVICES PROVIDING -- PROVIDED
IN THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
THIS BILL WILL ADDRESS HEALTH
THIS HELP EQUITIES INEQUITIES
IN THE SOUTH LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY FOCUSED ON THE
FUNDING SHORTFALL THE HOSPITAL
FACE CARRYING OVER ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PATIENTS
PER YEAR AND ITS EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT THE CIVICALLY THIS
BILL WOULD STOP THE BLEEDING
OF MLK HOSPITAL LOSING ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY ALL OF THESE HOSPITAL
BASED OUTPATIENT SERVICES
MLK HOSPITAL IS ONE OF THE
ONLY EMERGENCY ROOM IN THE
HEART OF SOUTH LOS ANGELES
SERVING SERVICING -- HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS
TO SUPPORT OUR COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL IS TO SUPPORT
OUR FRONT LINE WORKERS ARE
WORKFORCE AND THEIR FAMILIES AS
WELL COBIT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
AND IT'S DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
ON COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAS
ASSIGNED A SPOTLIGHT ON THE BOND
ABILITY OF OUR MOST MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED RESIDENTS MAR
THE KING COMMUNITY HOSPITAL
PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT
OF EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS
HERE ARE MEDICARE PATIENTS OR
THOSE WHO ARE UNDER SERVE
THE HOSPITAL IS CONSISTENTLY
RANKED AMONG THE TOP TWO
IN THE REGION FOR A NUMBER
OF COBIT NINETEEN PATIENTS
PATIENT NUMBERS WENT
UPWARD TO EIGHT THOUSAND
DURING THE HEIGHT OF THIS
PANDEMIC THIS SITUATION
IS SIMILAR POST PANDEMIC
AND THE LACK OF ACCESS TO
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS IS
STILL AN ISSUE IN THIS COMMUNITY
STOP LOS ANGELES HAS A DEFICIT
COLLEAGUES OF ONE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED DOCTORS IN THIS
COMMUNITY AND WHICH I WAS
RAISED IN THE COMMUNITY IN
WHICH IS NOW STAND ON SHOULDERS
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES
IN THE STATE FEELS THE BURDEN
OF THE WORK SHORTAGE CRIPPLING
NOT ONLY THE COMMUNITIES LIKE
TO WATCH COMMUNITY BUT ALSO
CALIFORNIA AS THE DEMAND IS
OVER IS OUTWEIGHING THE
PROFESSION WE MUST PROTECT THE
WAY WE SERVE OUR COMMUNITY THE
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
WAS PROJECTED TO CARRY FOR
ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND PATIENTS
A YEAR MARKET COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL CARES FOR OVER ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PATIENTS
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX
WILL EXPAND SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING TO MARTHA KING
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL TO ENSURE
THAT THE HOSPITAL IS ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE HOSPITAL
BASED OUTPATIENT SERVICES
THIS BILL WILL ALSO PROVIDE
A FLEX OF FLEXIBILITY TO THE
HOSPITAL'S NEEDS TO EXPAND
COMMUNITY BASED PREVENTION
AND DISEASE MANAGEMENT KERR
I WANT TO PAUSE THE MOMENT
AND AND SIMPLY INTRODUCE --
THE HOSPITAL DIRECTOR DR
ELAINE BACHELOR WHO IS THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER AT THE MARTHA
KING JUNIOR COMMUNITY HOSPITAL
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMAN GIBSON
-- COMMITTEE AS THE CEO OF
MLK COMMUNITY HOSPITAL I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX SOUTH LOS ANGELES
IS A PLACE WHERE DECADES OF
UNDERINVESTMENT HAS BURDEN TO
COMMUNITY WITH AN EPIDEMIC OF
CHRONIC ILLNESS AND SOME OF
THE WORST HEALTH DISPARITIES
IN OUR STATE THESE DISPARITIES
WERE REFLECTED IN THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT KOPET
HAD IN OUR COMMUNITY WITH CNN
DESCRIBING OUR HOSPITAL AS AN
EPICENTER OF THE CALIFORNIA
COBIT EPICENTER CENTRAL
TO THE HEALTH DISPARITIES
IN SOUTH LA IS A PROFOUND
LACK OF ACCESS TO HEALTH
SERVICES WITH THE COMMUNITY
DEFICIT OF THIRTEEN HUNDRED
PHYSICIANS OR HOSPITAL EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT HAS BECOME THE
PLACE RESIDENTS SEEK CARE
BECAUSE THEY COULD NOT OBTAIN
TIMELY CARE IN THE COMMUNITY
OUR EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT IS
FILLING SIGNIFICANT GAPS IN
BOTH PRIMARY AND SPECIALTY CARE
AS A RESULT WE PROVIDE OVER
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT VISITS EACH YEAR ONE
OF THE BUSIEST EDIE'S IN THE
STATE AND A NUMBER OVER TWICE
WHAT WAS ENVISIONED WHEN OUR
HOSPITAL OPENED IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN I'D LIKE TO SHARE A
FEW EXAMPLES OF PATIENTS WE
SEE IN OUR EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
A PATIENT WITH A DOMINO PAIN
RECENTLY PRESENTED TO OUR
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT BECAUSE
AN APPOINTMENT WITH HER PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIAN WAS SEVERAL
WEEKS AWAY OUR DOCTORS WORK
UP FOUND A LARGE ABDOMINAL TUMOR
THAT NEEDED IMMEDIATE ONCOLOGY
CARE PATIENTS WITH DIABETES
AND HYPERTENSION UNABLE TO
SEE THEIR PRIMARY CARE DOCTORS
PRESENT TO OUR EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT EVERY DAY ARE MERGING
TO DEPARTMENT IS THE SITE OF
ROUTINE CARE FOR WOMEN WITH
PREGNANCY RELATED COMPLICATIONS
ROUTINELY PROVIDING FOLLOW UP
VISITS AND MONITORING IN THE
E. D. BECAUSE OUR PATIENTS
CANNOT OBTAIN ACCESS TO AN
OBSTETRICIAN IN THE COMMUNITY
LACK OF ACCESS TO CARE HAS
TURNED OUR EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
INTO A DE FACTO MEDICAL HOME
FOR THOUSANDS IN OUR COMMUNITY
WITH THE WORST PAYER MIX OF
ANY INDEPENDENT FREE STANDING
GENERAL ACUTE CARE HOSPITAL
IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE HIGH
VOLUME OF MEDICAL PATIENTS AND
NO SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING FOR
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT SERVICES
OUR HOSPITAL IS LOSING MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS A YEAR ON THESE
SERVICES AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
NINE THE LEGISLATION THAT
HELPED ESTABLISH A HOSPITAL
PROVIDES STATE SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING FOR IN PATIENT CARE
BUT NOT FOR HOSPITAL BASED
OUTPATIENT CARE MOST OF WHICH
IS EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISITS
WHEN AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY NINE
WAS PASSED NO ONE ENVISIONED
THE OVERWHELMING NUMBER OF
PATIENTS WOULD NEED AND SEEK
OUR SERVICES NOR COULD ANYONE
HAVE ANTICIPATED COVE IT THE
COMBINATION OF LOSSES FROM
PROVISION OF EDIE SERVICES FROM
TREATING OUR COMMUNITY DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND PANDEMIC
XCELERATED INFLATION HAS MOVED
OUR HOSPITAL FROM A BALANCED
BUDGET TO AN OPERATING LOSS
THIS YEAR A LOSS THAT WILL GROW
LARGER EACH YEAR UNTIL WE
PROJECT BY TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
WE WILL NO LONGER BE ABLE TO
COVER OUR EXPENSES AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY SIX CAN CHANGE THE
SCENARIO AND I RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR IT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE YOU
ARE YOU SPEAKING SPACE --
CHRISTY WITH GOOD AFTERNOON ON
BEHALF OF THE HOSPITAL TO START
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AND THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP THANK YOU
THERE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
C. NINE WILL GO TO THE
AUDIENCE IS THERE ANYONE
THE AUDIENCE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
SEE NO ONE WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MISTER OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES
JUST YOUR NAME POSITION ON
THE BILL AND ORGANIZATION
IF YOU REPRESENT ONE PLEASE
THANK YOU AND ONCE AGAIN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION FOR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
WHEN YOU WERE LINE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
THEIR NUMBERS ON THE HAVE
TO UNITE HERE LOCAL ELEVEN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
YES -- I NUMBER ONE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
MISTER MEMBERS ADAM KEIGWIN
WITH ACTOR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT ONE NUMBER ONE FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU CHEN
MEMBER STATES BORDERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA AGENTS AND
HEALTH INSURANCE PROFESSIONALS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
AND I SAW THE ONE NUMBER ONE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
STONE AND THEN AFTER PEOPLE
IN PERSON AT THE CONFERENCE
SAY WHAT THEY WANT OKAY THEN
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
JUST YOUR NAME AND
POSITION PLEASE
AND LINE ONE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
AT THIS TIME I HAVE NOBODY
ELSE IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
WALDRON THAT'S FINE GO AHEAD
PLEASE THANK YOU OF
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR AS WELL
-- SO WE ALWAYS SAY THAT MEDICAL
NEEDS FIXING AND THIS
YOU KNOW BROUGHT TO MIND ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY WHEN THE ONLY
WAY FOR PATIENTS TO GET CARE
IS GOING TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM
AND YOU KNOW JUST THAT THE
FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
PROVIDERS THAT WILL ACCEPT
MEDICO ALL -- YOU KNOW
WE HEAR IT TIME AND TIME AGAIN
WE NEED TO HAVE THOSE INCENTIVES
SO THAT PROVIDERS WILL
START TAKING MEDICAL BUT --
YOU KNOW THE ISSUE SHOWS THAT
THIS IS THE RESULT ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY WHEN THE COMMUNITY
IS NOT ABLE TO ACCESS CARE SO
JUST THE WANTED TO MAKE
THAT COMMENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ANYONE ELSE MISTER BIGELOW
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD BECAUSE
IT'S NOT JUST AN ISSUE OF THE
L. A. R. FOR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR'S HOSPITAL IT'S A IT'S
A REAL ISSUE FOR ALL OF US THIS
IS HAPPENING THROUGHOUT EVERY
COUNTY THROUGHOUT EVERY HOSPITAL
I WISH TODAY WE COULD AMEND THIS
BILL INCLUDE THE ONES IT FROM MY
DISTRICT THAT'S ALMOST EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM THERE'S ONE
I HAVEN'T SPOKEN TO RECENTLY
R. A. FACING EMINENT CLOSURES
THAT'LL LEAVE OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES OR ALL OF THE PEOPLE
FROM JUST ABOUT EVERYWHERE
COME TO RECREATION AND SOME OF
THOSE MAJESTIC AREAS LIKE YOU
SOMEBODY MAMMOTH IT'S A PLACE
SOUTH LAKE TAHOE THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE NO EMERGENCY HOSPITAL
ANYWHERE CLOSE BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES OR THE FUNDS
TO TAKE CARE OF THEM AND I NEED
TO BE A BACK FILL FOR THEM AS
WELL I WOULD HOPE THAT AS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD THAT YOU
WOULD CONSIDER THE POSSIBILITY
OF EXPANDING YOUR BILL WELL I
KNOW IT'S PREDICATED ON JUST
A SINGLE SOURCE ISSUE THAT'S
A DISTRICT WIDE ISSUE I JUST
THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO FACE UP TO THIS ISSUE ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR ENLIGHTENMENT TO THIS AND
I WOULD APPRECIATE THE CHAIR
IF YOU GET A MOMENT SOMETIME
WITH THE COMMITTEE YOU COULD
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AS WELL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
SO ANYWAY ANYONE ELSE INCOMES
WE HAVE A MOTION A MOVE
THANK YOU AB SO I DIDN'T GET THE
SECOND FOR ON THE SECOND
OKAY OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER NAZARIAN THE SECOND
BY MISS WALDRON THE MOTION
IT HAVE YOU ACCEPTED OUR
AMENDMENTS I DON'T BELIEVE
YES SIR I HAVE ACCEPTED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THANK
YOU FOR CORD OUR TEAM TO MAKE
AN STRATONICE BIT THIS BILL
MAKE IT BETTER OKAY THANK YOU
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
IS THERE IN A SECOND I MISS
WALDRON THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
DIPS THANK YES THANKED THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND ALSO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WANT TO JUST
BRIEFLY TALK TELL YOU A QUICK
STORY -- IT WAS A LADY WHO
LIVED IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES
-- SHE SAID IN HER LIVING
ROOM -- IS GETTING READY TO
GET ON THE PHONE OF THIS YOU
FELT SOME CHEST PAINS -- SHE
FELT THAT IT WAS UNUSUAL CHEST
PAINS OUR HUSBAND WAS A TRUCK
DRIVER AND HE WAS THAT --
UNIONISTS -- AND CROSSTOWN
WITH CEDAR SINAI UP SHE
WAS HAVING A HEART ATTACK
CALLED NINE ONE ONE OF THE
PARAMEDICS RESPONDED AND TOOK
HER TO A MARTHA KING HOSPITAL
WHERE MARKING HOUSE BUT HAVE
A VERY SKILLFUL CARDIOLOGISTS
THE WORK ON SAVING HER LIFE
AND THEY DID MARKING HOSPITAL
WAS A TRAINING GROUND MANY MANY
YEARS -- FOR TRAUMA --
BECAUSE OF THE COMMUNITY WHICH
WAS IN AND STILL IS THEIR
DAY THAT ONE WAS WHAT WAS MY
MOTHER MY MOTHER MARKING
HOSPITAL SAVED MY MOTHER'S LIFE
I AM DEEPLY GRATEFUL OF FOR THE
THE THE THE THE SKILLFUL THE
GIFTEDNESS US OF OF THE DOCTORS
AND THE PROFESSIONALISM OF THE
FRONT LINE WORKERS -- BUT THEY
DO THAT WORK EACH AND EVERY
DAY THEY WILL NEVER TURN ANYONE
AWAY WHETHER YOU HAVE INSURANCE
OR NOT THIS HOSPITAL STANDS
-- AS THE CENTER OF THE HEART
OF THE STOP LOSS SANDERS
COMMUNITY WILLING TO ROLL UP
ITS SLEEVES MAKES NO DIFFERENCE
THE COLOR OF YOUR SKIN MAKES
NO DIFFERENCE YOUR MAMA IS YOUR
DADDY -- YOUR ZIP CODE THEY
HELP EVERY ONE THAT COMES THOSE
DOORS AND I THINK FOR ME AS
AS THE REPRESENTATIVE IS TO
DO EVERYTHING THAT I CAN'T TO
MAKING SURE THAT WE EXPANDED
SERVICES AND ALSO LOOK AT THE
FUNDING STREAM SO THAT MARK KING
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL CAN CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES TO THE
COMMUNITY THAT IT DESPERATELY
NEEDS I'M I'M HAPPY TO BE
JOINED ON THIS BILL WITH SENATOR
STEVE BRADFORD WE SHARE THIS
DISTRICT TOGETHER -- THE -- THE
-- THE W. O. C. A. C. WATCHED
LABOR COALITION THE LOS ANGELES
IN A NEWSPAPER S. C. O. C.
-- CAL THE UNIVERSITY MAKE IT
SALES AND THE LIST GOES ON AND
ON I ABSOLUTELY ASK EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU FOR YOUR I
THOUGHT RESPECTFULLY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR GIPSON MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE CHAIR AND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WHAT I WALDRON WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW I CARILLO
LARA MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MAYES MAYES
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN
THE SYRIAN I RIVAS RIVAS HI
CALDERON CALDERON I SANTIAGO
BONTA AYE BATA AYE
IF YOU HAVE TWELVE VOTES OF
THE BILL IS OUT WILL BE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD
ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH GIPSON
WE'RE GONNA GO WE'RE GONNA
GO SLIGHTLY OUT OF ORDER HERE
-- MISTER NAZARIAN IS GONNA
BE UP NEXUS HE'S CHAIRING A
AGING A LONG TERM CARE IN A FEW
MINUTES SO WE'LL GIVE HIM THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT HIS BILL
THE MAKING RUN BACK AND VOTE
ON EVERYTHING ELSE LATER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR THIS BILL
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY TWO THE
PRICE ACT -- TODAY FIRST
I'D I'D LIKE TO ALSO THANK
THE CHAIRMAN THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR AMENDMENTS AND --
THAT I WILL BE HAPPILY ACCEPTING
TODAY I DO ALSO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND ENERGY
AND THE WORK THAT YOU'VE ALL
PUT INTO THIS SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK AND DILIGENCE AND
I DO LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH YOU TO ENSURE THE
PROTECTIONS THAT WE'VE ALREADY
DISCUSSED SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
LAST YEAR I BROUGHT A SIMILAR
BILL BEFORE THIS VERY COMMITTEE
AB SEVEN FIFTY TWO THE BUILDING
CHOI THE SUPPORT OF THIS
COMMITTEE RECEIVING NO NO VOTES
-- PRESCRIPTION ABANDONMENT
RESULTS IN AS MUCH AS TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN OUR COUNTRY
IN AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE COSTS
INCLUDING BOTH THE COST OF THE
ABANDONED PRESCRIPTION ABANDONED
PRESCRIPTIONS THEMSELVES AS WELL
AS THE COSTS OF SUBSEQUENT CARE
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY FOUR OF
IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
WHICH SAVES PATIENTS THEIR
TIME AND MONEY AND WILL BUILD
BETTER TRUST BETWEEN PATIENTS
AND MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS WHO
PRESCRIBED THEIR MEDICATION
CURRENT LAWS AND REGULATIONS DO
NOT GUARANTEE THAT PATIENTS WILL
HAVE ACCESS TO THE FULL RANGE
OF INFORMATION PERTAINING TO
THEIR ACTUAL OUT OF POCKET COSTS
AT THE PHARMACY COUNTER UNTIL
IT'S TOO LATE IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE PATIENTS FOR PATIENTS THAT
ARE NOT ABLE TO KNOW WHAT THEIR
MEDICATION COST WILL BE AND ARE
LEFT WAITING UNTIL THEY REACH
THE PHARMACY COUNTER RATHER
THAN LEAVING PATIENTS IN A LURCH
OR IN THE POSITION OF HAVING
TO LEAVE THE PHARMACY WITHOUT
THEIR MEDICATION THE PRICE ACT
WILL ALLOW PATIENTS TO AVOID
THIS EMBARRASSMENT AND SHAME
OF NOT BEING ABLE TO AFFORD
SOMETHING THEY ARE PRESCRIBED
CAN YOU IMAGINE A SINGLE PARENT
GOING UP TO PURCHASE GROCERIES
AND FINDING THAT THE GROCERIES
ARE MORE EXPENSIVE THAN THEY
ANTICIPATED AND HAVING TO
PUT ALL THE ITEMS BACK ON THE
SHELVES AND GO BACK HOME AND
TELL THEIR CHILDREN THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE FOOD FOR THAT NIGHT
WITH THIS IS PRACTICALLY THE
SAME SET SCENARIO AT THIS KIND
OF PRACTICE WOULD BE UNTHINKABLE
WHEN PURCHASING EVERY DAY IN
THE SUBSIDIES FROM GROCERIES TO
GASOLINE WHY SHOULD PURCHASING
ARE NEEDED PRESCRIPTIONS BE ANY
DIFFERENT THE PRICE ACT WILL
ALLOW PATIENTS AND THERE FELT
A CARE PRESCRIBERS THE ABILITY
TO MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
THAT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT RELEVANT
COVERAGE COST AND UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT INFORMATION THE
TECHNOLOGY DOES EXIST THAT
YOU THIS GOAL WHY IS IT NOT
BEING UTILIZED TO ITS FULLEST
POTENTIAL HANGING IN THE BALANCE
OUR CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION WITH ME IS LIZ HELMS
AS MY WITNESS THANK YOU THANK
YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD AND TO MEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M SO EXCITED
TO BE ABLE TO BE IN PERSON IN
THE ROOM AGAIN IT'S BEEN A LONG
TIME CHAIRMAN WOULD HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LIZ
HELMS AND THE PRESIDENT CEO
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION OR WE'VE CAUGHT FOUR
SEASONS I GO FORWARD WE ARE
PLEASED TO BE THE SPONSOR OF
TWENTY THREE FIFTY TWO THE FOUR
SEASONS A COALITION OF MORE
THAN THIRTY LEADING STATEWIDE
CONSUMER HEALTH ORGANIZATION
SOME PROVIDER GROUPS THAT
PROMOTE COLLABORATIVE WORK OF
POLICYMAKERS INDUSTRY LEADERS
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AND
CONSUMERS TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH
OF CALIFORNIANS WITH CHRONIC
CONDITIONS AB TWENTY THREE
FIFTY TWO ENABLES DECISION
MAKING TO OCCUR WHERE IT SHOULD
BE IN THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE
BETWEEN A PATIENT AND THEIR
PHYSICIAN WITH THE ENACTMENT
OF THIS BILL PATIENTS WOULD BE
CENTRAL ACTIVE STAKEHOLDERS IN
THEIR OWN HEALTH AND WOULD BE
MORE LIKELY TO STICK TO THEIR
TREATMENT PLAN THIS BILL IS
CRITICAL AND TIMELY THE EASE UP
TIME CONSUMING AND FRUSTRATING
PROCESSES THAT WAY ON PATIENTS
THEIR PROVIDERS AND WILL IMPROVE
ACCESS TO ALL OF THE HEALTH
CARE FOR PEOPLE WITH CHRONIC
CONDITIONS AND DISEASES PATIENTS
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR
HEALTH CARE BASED IN LARGE
PART ON WHAT THEY CAN AFFORD
OFTEN YUP YET OFTENTIMES THIS
INFORMATION IS NOT AVAILABLE
UNTIL THEY REACH THE PHARMACY
COUNTER WHERE THEY MAY REALIZE
THE TREATMENT IS UNAFFORDABLE
AND MAY ABANDON THE MEDICATION
ALTOGETHER WE HEAR ABOUT THIS
ALL THE TIME DELAYS IN CARE
NOT ONLY WORSEN THE PATIENTS
STATE OF HEALTH BUT ALSO LEAD
TO INCREASED UTILIZATION OF
MORE COSTLY HEALTH CARE SERVICES
THEREAFTER THIS IS A SYSTEM THAT
DOES NOT WORK FOR THE PATIENT
OR HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS WHO
ARE THEIR OWN BURDENED WITH OUT
OF -- AND ADDED ADMINISTRATIVE
RESPONSIBILITIES AT A TIME WHEN
FAMILIES CONTINUE TO FINANCIALLY
STRUGGLE FROM THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IT IS CRITICAL
TO ADOPT PRACTICAL CHANGES THAT
IMPROVE AFFORDABILITY BY FREEING
UP EXISTING DRUG COST DATA
FOR PATIENTS AT THE POINT OF
CARE IN REAL TIME WHILE REDUCING
THE STRAIN ON PHARMACISTS AND
PHYSICIANS WHAT INTO THE COVER
MY MEDS TWENTY TWENTY TWO
MEDICATION ACCESS REPORT SEVENTY
NINE PERCENT OF PATIENTS HAVE
GONE TO PICK UP A PRESCRIPTION
TO FIND OUT THAT IT COSTS
MORE THAN EXPECTED IN THE SAME
SURVEY EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT OF
PROVIDERS AND FIFTY SIX PERCENT
OF PHARMACISTS SURVEYED SAID
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT NOTHING'S
PROVIDE PREVENT PATIENTS FROM
RECEIVING TREATMENTS THAT
COULD HELP THE MOST AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY TO OFFER SOLUTIONS
THAT WILL LEVERAGE EXISTING
TECHNOLOGY TO STRENGTHEN PATIENT
CENTERED CARE ENSURE DECISION
MAKING HAPPENS IN THE MOST
APPROPRIATE SETTING BETWEEN
THE PROVIDER AND THE PATIENT
REDUCE TEDIOUS ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS ON PROVIDERS INCREASE
ADHERENCE TO A PROGRAMMATIC
CATIONS AND IMPROVE QUALITY
AND ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIANS
WITH CHRONIC CONDITIONS FOR THE
MANY REASONS STATED WE STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR ALLOWING THE
FOUR SEAS TO EXPRESS OUR VIEWS
TODAY AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR MADDEN THANK YOU TERM
MEMBERS TO NINE REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE
IN SPEAKING WITH RHEUMATOLOGISTS
ON AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY TWO
THEY PROVIDE ME WITH SOME INPUT
AND EXAMPLES OUTLINING THE NEED
FOR THE BILL IT IS NOT UNCOMMON
FOR RHEUMATOLOGY PRACTICES TO BE
WORKING WITH NUMEROUS INSURANCE
COMPANIES WHICH MAY HAVE
BEEN TOTALED TWENTY TO THIRTY
DIFFERENT INSURANCE PRODUCTS
ALL WITH DIFFERENT BENEFITS
STRUCTURES COVERING DIFFERENT
MEDICATIONS WITH UNIQUE COST
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE PATIENT
ONE SOLO RHEUMATOLOGY PRACTICE
HAS FIVE STAFF DEDICATED TO
JUST WORKING WITH INSURANCE
COMPANIES AN EXAMPLE SHARED
WITH ME IS OF A RHEUMATOLOGIST
TREATING ADULT OR CHILD WITH
SEVERE ARTHRITIS DUE TO THE
SHORTAGE OF RHEUMATOLOGISTS
GETTING INITIAL APPOINTMENT
PRETTY PATIENTS CAN BE ANYWHERE
FROM FOUR UP TO AS MUCH AS THREE
MONTHS ONCE THE RHEUMATOLOGIST
SEES THE PATIENT THEY WILL ORDER
SOME TESTS TO UNDERSTAND THEIR
CONDITION BEFORE MEDICATIONS ARE
PRESCRIBED ONCE THE TEST RESULTS
ARE BACK A SECOND APPOINTMENT
IS NEEDED WHICH MAY TAKE AS
MANY AS THIRTY DAYS AT WHICH
TIME MEDICATIONS PRESCRIBED
FOR THEIR ARTHRITIC CONDITION
NOW NEITHER THE RHEUMATOLOGIST
KNOW THE PATIENT MAY KNOW IF
THE MEDICATION BEING PRESCRIBED
IS COVERED AND EVEN IF IT
IS COVERED HOW MUCH COSTS TO
THE PATIENT WILL BE ANCHORED
THE PATIENT ONLY FINDS OUT
WHAT THEIR COST IS WHEN THEY
GO TO THE PHARMACY IT IS NOT
UNCOMMON FOR PATIENTS ONCE THEY
LEARN THE COSTS TO OBTAIN
TO NOT OBTAIN THE MEDICATION
THIS THEN REQUIRES THE PATIENT
TO SET ANOTHER APPOINTMENT
WITH A DERMATOLOGIST FOR NEW
PRESCRIPTION WHICH CAN TAKE
ANOTHER MONTH THIS WHOLE PROCESS
OF TRYING TO GET PATIENTS
ON THE MEDICATIONS THAT ARE
EFFECTIVE IN AFFORDABLE CAN
TAKE MORE THAN THREE MONTHS
ALL THE WHILE THE PATIENT IS
SUFFERING FROM ARTHRITIC PAIN
IF THE PAIN BECOMES SO BAD
SOME PATIENTS WILL END UP IN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT SEEKING
TREATMENT A REAL TIME TOOL TO
KNOW WHAT DRUGS ARE COVERED
AND AT WHAT LEVEL WOULD BE A
TREMENDOUS BENEFIT FOR PATIENTS
PHYSICIANS AND PHARMACIES ONE
RHEUMATOLOGIST I SPOKE WITH
SAID THAT NINETY PERCENT OF THE
PRESCRIPTIONS THAT HE WRITES
CAN'T BE REPLACED UTILIZING
A DIFFERENT MEDICATION IF HE
KNOWS THAT IF THE MEDICATION
IS COVERED OR NOT AND WHAT THE
COST IS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY TWO WOULD
GIVE PATIENTS AND PHYSICIANS A
CRITICAL TOOL TO HELP PATIENTS
OBTAIN MEDICATIONS THEY NEED
AND CAN AFFORD IN A MORE TIMELY
MANNER FOR THAT FOR THESE
REASONS RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
PLEASE COME FORWARD YEAH
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
NICK LOUISE US ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS THAT WE HAVE TAKEN AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL -- WE SAW SOME
AMENDMENTS THIS MORNING THAT I
BELIEVE -- ARE GOING INTO THE
BILL OR THE WE UNDERSTAND WILL
BE TAKEN IN COMMITTEE TODAY SO
WE WE'VE PROBABLY SENT THOSE
OUT TO OUR MEMBERS FOR REVIEW
AND WE CERTAINLY DO NOT HAVE
ANY PROBLEM WITH THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL INDEED -- OUR MEMBERS
HAVE TOOLS THAT THEY CURRENTLY
USE THAT SUPPLY MUCH OF THIS
INFORMATION ALREADY THE QUESTION
IS WHETHER LEGISLATING THIS
YOU KNOW LEADS TO UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES ARE OPERABILITY
ISSUES FOR OUR MEMBERS SO I
YOU KNOW WE'LL WE'LL TAKE THOSE
AMENDMENTS BACK WILL REVIEW
THOSE AND THEN PROMPTLY RESPOND
TO THE AUTHOR THE SPONSORS IN
THE COMMITTEE WE HAD A VERY GOOD
OPEN DIALOGUE THUS FAR WITH THE
SPONSORS IN THE AUTHOR IN YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF -- AND IF THERE
ARE ANY FURTHER ADJUSTMENTS
NEEDED TO THE LANGUAGE -- YOU
KNOW WE LOVE THAT LEVEL OF
DIALOGUE TO CONTINUE MOVING
FORWARD IF NEEDED SO THANK
YOU VERY WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SO IN THE CHAMBER ANYBODY
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
WILL JUST BE TAKING YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION IF YOU'RE
REPRESENT ONE IN YOUR POSITION
THANK YOU MELISSA CORTEZ ON
BEHALF OF COVER MY MEDS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU WHAT ELSE
UP WITH JUST ONE ADDITIONAL
OUT ONTO MATT REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
SEE NO ONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES -- MISTER OPERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR PEOPLE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR
NAME POSITION AND ORGANIZATION
IF YOU REPRESENT ONE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
ON THIS ISSUE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND AND ZERO AT THIS TIME
THE FIRST COMMENT IS FROM
THE LINE OF ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ALEX CON PENSION AND
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMPETITION
LINE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN
WHEN YOU'RE ON BEHALF OF
AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS ALSO IN OPPOSED BY THE
POSITION AND WILL REVIEW THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT IS FROM LINE ONE
HUNDRED SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN -- STEVEN
CHOI JOKES REPRESENTING
THE ARTHRITIS FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT TIME IT IS FOR
BLIND ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST UP THE
WATKINS AT THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA LIFE AND
HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
WE APPRECIATE THE MOST RECENT
MEHMET'S WILL BE REVIEWING
THOSE THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ABOUT THANK YOU
THE NEXT TIME IT IS FROM LINE
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL DEATH
BUT THE PREY AND MCKINLEY
ON BEHALF OF MY CASTING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT CON EDISON LINE
ONE HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN
DAHLE MCCOY REPRESENTING
QUALITY CARE POLICY ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY TWO THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMEDIES FROM LINE
NINETY FIVE HERE LINE IS TO OPEN
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SYSTEM
ON MANTA FROM LOANS FOR LUPIN
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIRST
TEACHING THE NEXT
COMMENT IS FROM LINE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THE MAN TELEGRAPH THE NATIONAL
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS SOCIETY
REPORTED TO DEL THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMPETITION
LINE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
SURE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN DIABETES
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT IF
THE NEXT COMPETITION LINE ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN JOHN WERE GOING
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
CRIED CARE COALITION BOARD
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU
AND THERE WERE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS RESEARCHER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A RING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MOTIONS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MOTION BY DOCTOR REGULAR
SECOND BY MISS AGUILAR CURRY
SEEING NO I LIVE IN MOTION
IS DO YOU PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS THIS DOZEN
JOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION BY
THE CHAIR WHICH I TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
WORKING WITH YOU ON THIS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER NAZARIAN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT
I WOULD AYE WALDRON WALDRON
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
BIGELOW A REAL
LARA LARA NOT VOTING
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I MAYES
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN
AYE NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS
CALDERON SANTIAGO
BONTA BUT I
ZERO GET EIGHT VOTES THE BILL
IS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHER STATUS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL NOW GO TO MR MCCARTY
WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO FILE ORDER
SAFIA WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
A COUPLE OF ALTER WHAT IT WITH
THE WILL OF THE CHAIR OKAY
YEAH
THE STATE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FOR THAT CHANCE TO PRESENT TO
THIS BILL AB NINETEEN TWENTY
EIGHT YOU MAY LOOK FAMILIAR
WE HAD A A ROBUST CONVERSATION
ON THIS BILL A YEAR AGO
UNFORTUNATELY WAS VETOED BY
THE GOVERNOR AFTER A NEARLY
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN THE
LEGISLATURE I THINK THERE IS
ONLY ONE NO VOTE AND THAT WAS
UP I FOUND OUT A MISTAKE VOTE
NOT LOOKING AT YOU OVER THERE
-- I'M I'M BACK AFTER TAKING
A LOOK AT THIS THIS ISSUE
AGAIN -- AND WE HAVE READ
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE
AND LOOKED AT THE POTENTIAL
ADJUSTMENTS TO THIS AND MADE
SOME OF THIS IS ABOUT A CRISIS
WE HAVE IN OUR STATE RELATE TO
ADDICTION THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND PEOPLE REVOLVING
THROUGH THE SYSTEM -- WE KNOW
THE CURRENT SYSTEM DOES NOT
WORK -- WE KNOW THAT A SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DISORDER AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE AND SHOULD NOT
BE TREATED IN A PUBLIC SAFETY
SETTING IN IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM TOO OFTEN PEOPLE
THAT ARE ADDICTS GET SENTENCE
DOESN'T ADDICTS END UP COMING
OUT OF JAIL AS AN ATTIC SO WE
HAVE HERE IS THE INNOVATIVE IDEA
A THREE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM WHICH
WILL ALLOW THREE COUNTIES SANTA
CLARA SAN JOAQUIN AND YELLOW TO
OFFER A VOLUNTARY DRUG PROGRAM
FOR INDIVIDUALS BEING SENTENCE
FOR A DRUG RELATED CRIME JUDGES
WILL BE OFFERED WILL BE ABLE TO
OFFER INDIVIDUALS PARTICIPATION
IN THIS PILOT PROGRAM BASED
UPON THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
PROVIDERS AGAIN PARTICIPATION IS
KEY BECAUSE THEY MUST VOLUNTARY
LEE AGREED TO PARTICIPATE
AND THEY CAN LEAVE AT ANY
TIME WHICH OFF LOCUSTS ON NAY
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS TO THIS
AGAIN THIS IS A PILOT PROGRAM
MEANT TO PROVIDE ANOTHER
OPTION OTHER THAN INCARCERATION
JAILS AND PRISONS ARE OFTEN
FAILING PEOPLE WITH SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS THIS BILL PROVIDED
EVIDENCE BASED RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT AFTER INDIVIDUALS
COMPLETE THIS PROCESS IT WILL
HAVE THEIR FELONY SEALED THE
RECORD EXPUNGED AND THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO SERVE LAST TIME
IN THIS -- TREATMENT FACILITY
AND THEY THEN THEY WOULD SERVE
ANOTHER UNDERLYING SENTENCE HAD
THEY WENT TO A COUNTY JAIL OR
STATE PRISON WE ALL KNOW FAMILY
MEMBERS OR LOVED ONES WHO ARE
LOST TO THE STREETS ARE LOST TO
ADDICTION AND ARE DESPERATELY
LOOKING FOR HELP MANY TIMES I'VE
SEEN PEOPLE GO AND GO THROUGH
INTERVENTIONS PEOPLE SAY THAT
THAT'S NOT VOLUNTARY YEAH WHEN
YOUR FAMILY SHOWS UP AND SAYS
HEY YOU NEED HELP THEY GO AND
GET HELP THEY DIDN'T THEY DIDN'T
VOLUNTEER THAT DAY BEFORE BUT
THEIR FAMILY CAJOLE THEM TO SEEK
HELP THIS IS THE SAME TYPE OF
EFFORT HERE WE KNOW NEED LOOK
AT THINGS DIFFERENTLY TOO OFTEN
OUR OUR OUR HANDS ARE TIED WITH
THEIR OPTIONS I KNOW THERE IS
OPPOSITION AND CONCERNS BUT
I'LL SAY THAT WHEN WE FIRST
INTRODUCED THIS IDEA LAST
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WE HAVE SINCE TAKEN OVER FIFTY
CHANGES AND AMENDMENTS TO THAT
WE'VE LISTENED TO THE PEOPLE
OF CONCERNS TAKEN OVER FIFTY
SUGGESTIONS AND AMENDMENTS --
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO I KNOW
THERE ARE SOME -- SUGGESTIONS
HERE THAT WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMITTEE AND
SO YES FOR SURE I DO ACCEPT
YOUR COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
I KNOW THERE ARE SOME OTHER
IDEAS THROUGH THE OPPOSITION
THAT OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
I'M WILLING TO DISCUSS WHAT
WE'RE DOING RELATED TO THOSE
ISSUES AS WELL AND WE NEED TO
DO THINGS DIFFERENTLY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHETHER IT'S THIS
LOOK THE LOOK THE AT THE ISSUE
WITH CONSERVATORSHIP PEOPLE WITH
-- THAT'S HEALTH ISSUES THIS
IS ONE THING THAT WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON AND -- AND STEP UP OUR
GAME HERE IN CALIFORNIA WITH ME
TODAY ARE ONE OF THE COUNTIES
WHO WAS A SPONSOR OF THIS BILL
AGAIN WE HAVE YOLO COUNTY WE
HAVE SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND
AND JOAQUIN COUNTY AS A THREE
COUNTIES AND WITH ME TODAY
IS THE YELLOW COUNTY DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY JONATHAN
RAVEN THANK YOU SO HAVE TO TWO
PEOPLE TEST RIGHT RIGHT THEY
OKAY PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU A CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JONATHAN
RAVEN AND I'M THE CHIEF DEPUTY
OF THE YELL COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND I
OVERSEE ALL OUR MENTAL HEALTH
DIVERSION PROGRAMS AB NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT PROPOSES A LOCAL
TREATMENT ALTERNATIVE TO PRISON
OR JAIL FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE CONVICTED OF FELONY CRIMES
MOTIVATED MOTIVATED BY THEIR
ADDICTION BUT WHO POSED TO MUCH
RISK FOR A JUDGE TO RELEASE THEM
OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY SO THE
ONLY ALTERNATIVE FOR THE JUDGES
A PRISON SENTENCE AND THEN
SECURED RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
FACILITY WOULD NOT PREVENT THAT
PERSON FROM WALKING AWAY AND
POSSIBLY HURTING THEMSELVES
OR OTHERS AB NINETEEN TWENTY
EIGHT ENVISIONS CREATING A
SECURE HOSPITAL LIKE TREATMENT
FACILITY WITHOUT JAIL BARS AND
GUARDS WITH GUNS IT INCENTIVIZE
IS EJECTED FELONY OFFENDERS
SENTENCED TO PRISON TO
VOLUNTARILY CHOOSE THIS UNTRIED
INNOVATIVE APPROACH AND WE
CALL THIS PLACE HOPE CALIFORNIA
FROM A PERSONAL STANDPOINT IN
OVERSEEING ALL MEN ARE MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS IN COURT THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM YOU'LL
COUNTY I'VE SEEN COUNTLESS TIMES
WHERE INDIVIDUALS WERE READY TO
GO TO PRISON AND INSTEAD THEY
CHOSE OUR MENTAL HEALTH COURT
AND THEY GOT WELL AND THESE
WERE SERIOUS OFFENDERS WITH
VERY SUBSTANTIAL MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
ISSUES AN EXAMPLE IS A FORTY
YEAR OLD WHO WAS CONVICTED OF
FELONY COMMERCIAL BURGLARY HE'S
ALSO IT ADDICTED TO HEROIN HE
COMMITTED THE CRIME TO FEED HIS
DRUG HABIT HE'S BEEN TO PRISON
FOUR TIMES IN THREE YEARS AGO
WAS CONVICTED OF ASSAULT CAUSING
GREAT BODILY INJURY THROUGHOUT
HIS LIFE SADLY HE'S NEVER
GONE THE NECESSARY HELP TO GET
WELL CALIFORNIA WOULD GIVE
AN ALTERNATIVE JUST TO STATE
PRISON AND SOME HOPE FOR THIS
INDIVIDUAL HOPE CALIFORNIA
FACILITIES WILL BE DESIGNED
AND STAFFED BY TREATMENT
PROVIDERS AND THEY WILL DECIDE
WHO'S AN APPROPRIATE CANDIDATE
AND THEY WILL DECIDE WHAT THE
BEST TREATMENT PLAN WILL BE
ANOTHER INCENTIVE FOR THOSE
WHO CHOOSE AND SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETE THE TREATMENT INSTEAD
OF PRISON WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE
THEIR CONVICTIONS EXPUNGED SO
THEY WILL REGAIN THEIR DIGNITY
AND WHEN RELEASED TREATMENT
PROVIDERS WILL RECOMMEND A STEP
DOWN WHICH COULD BE RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FOR INTENSIVE
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT OR ANOTHER
ALTERNATIVE AB NINETEEN TWENTY
EIGHT IS A VERY MEASURED
PILOT BILL THAT ALLOWS THREE
COUNTIES OFFER THIS VOLUNTARY
TREATMENT ALTERNATIVE TO JAIL
OR PRISON THIS EXACT TREATMENT
MODEL HAS NEVER BEEN TRIED
THE DATA WILL BE COLLECTED TO
DETERMINE HOPE CALIFORNIA'S
SUCCESS AND WE TALK ABOUT
MEASURABLE RESULTS EVERY
SINGLE PROGRAM THAT STARTS
OFF AND HIS INNOVATIVE DOES
NOT HAVE MEASURABLE RESULTS
AND THEN AFTER TRYING TO
PROGRAM IT IS COLLECTED AND
YOU GET MEASURABLE RESULTS
TO SEE IF IT'S SUCCESSFUL OR
NOT WE BELIEVE THE MODEL WILL
ALLOW MANY ON INDIVIDUALS TO
GET WELL AND LEAD A PRODUCTIVE
LIFE I URGE THIS COMMITTEE
TO GIVE THIS PILOT PROGRAM A
CHANCE THANK YOU ECURIE
MUCH ANYONE ANYONE ELSE
AND MY NAME IS GERRY BURKE
I'M -- -- CASE MANAGER
RE EMERGING SCHOLARS --
REENTRY PROGRAM FOR FORMERLY
INCARCERATED AND SYSTEM IMPACTED
STUDENTS WITHIN THE LOS RIOS
DISTRICT AND I'M JUST HERE
TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT OF MY
EXPERIENCE DUE TO MY ADDICTION
I SPENT MOST OF MY YOUTH AND
EARLY ADULTHOOD DOING WHAT WAS
EVER NECESSARY TO FIND DRUGS
AND WAS IN AT A CORRECTIONAL
INSTANCE INSTITUTIONS AND
FACILITIES I GREW UP IN
AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE DRUGS
WERE THE NORM I DID ANYTHING
NECESSARY TO OBTAIN THEM FROM
GRAND THEFT AUTO TO STEAL
ANYTHING OF VALUE OUT OF MY
NEIGHBORS RAJ TO SELLING DRUGS
NOTHING WAS OFF LIMITS IT TO
OBTAIN DRUGS I VICTIMIZED MY
COMMUNITY TO FEED MY ADDICTION
OF MY SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES
WERE NOT ONLY DESTROYING MY LIFE
THEY'RE DESTROYING THE LIFE OF
MY FAMILY MY WIFE MY CHILDREN
AND BENCHLEY MY OWN SONS
-- MY STEP CHILDREN AS WELL
FOR OVER A TWENTY YEAR PERIOD
OF MY LIFE THERE WAS NOTHING
TO KEEP ME FROM USING NOT
INCARCERATION NOT THE LOSS OF
LOVED ONES OR EVEN THE BIRTH
OF MY OWN SON THERE ARE MANY
TIMES I THOUGHT ABOUT GETTING
CLEAN YOU KNOW THOSE DAYS BEFORE
-- I HAD THE TEST FOR PAROLE
OR YOU TO PROBATION AND I EVEN
THOUGHT ABOUT IT MANY TIMES
COMING HOME FROM WHATEVER
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY I WAS
COMING HOME FROM AT THAT TIME
YOU KNOW AT THAT POINT MY LIFE
I JUST WASN'T ABLE TO FUNCTION
WITHOUT THE USE OF DRUGS --
DURING MY INCARCERATION I WAS
NEVER OFFERED ANY SUBSTANCE
ABUSE PROGRAMS NOR WERE THERE
MANY ON THE YARDS I WAS ON AND
WHETHER THEY AND WHETHER THERE
WAS WANT IT AND WHERE THERE
WAS ONE THAT CAME WITH THE LONG
WAITING LISTS AND UNFAVORABLE
REPUTATION ON THE ART MANY TIMES
I WENT BACK ON PAROLE VIOLATION
SISSETON RECEPTION IN THE YARD
FOR FOUR TO SIX MONTHS THE ONE
DRUG PROGRAM THAT I WAS FORCED
INTO CAME AT THE END OF MY
THIRTEEN YEARS OF INCARCERATION
AND -- THESE FACILITIES HOWEVER
THE FIRST TWO MONTHS FOR IN
JAIL AND THAT WAS -- THE LAST
TIME I GOT LOADED IF IT WASN'T
FOR THE RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
FACILITY THEY SENT ME TO I WOULD
HAVE NEVER FOUND MY PATH AND
EDUCATION RIGHT RIGHT JUST
RECEIVED MY MASTER'S DEGREE LAST
MAY -- WHICH I BELIEVE LEADS
TO IMPORTANCE OF PARTNERING
WITH OUTSIDE NONPROFITS TO
GIVE THESE INDIVIDUALS THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
PLEASE COME ON UP YOU
GO UP TO THE TABLE HERE
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR WHAT IN
MEMBERS -- TYLER IN THE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES WE REPRESENTS --
COMMUNITY BASED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT PROVIDERS
AND WE ARE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT I'M WE WERE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TO THE PRIOR VERSION
OF THE BELL I'M AB FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO FROM LAST YEAR --
WE YEP YOU KNOW DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT I'M CREATING A LOCKED --
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROGRAM
-- IS THE YOU KNOW IN THESE
THREE PILOT COUNTIES WHICH
THE BILL HAS BEEN EXPANDED
TO YOU IS YOU KNOW WHEN
AFFECT COAL OR INEFFECTIVE
OUR MODEL OF TREATMENT I'M
A STRONG COALITION OF TREATMENT
PROVIDERS AND JUSTICE ADVOCATES
ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL AND
-- WE BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL KEY ISSUES WITH -- AB
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT FIRST OF
ALL THAT -- COERCED S. U. D.
TREATMENT -- IS NOT -- AN
EFFECTIVE MEANS OF TREATMENT
WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THE
CHOICE TO PARTICIPATE AND THE
SECURED RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
PROGRAM IS A FREE CHOICE WITH
INFORMED CONSENT AS -- YOU KNOW
IS THE STANDARD UNDER ARMED MEN
MEDICAL PRACTICE THE PERSON IS
FACING THE CHOICE OF GOING TO
INTO A -- YOU KNOW PRISON
SENTENCE -- OR GOING INTO
THIS -- TREATMENT PROGRAM AND
WE SEE THAT AS BEING A FALSE
CHOICE WHICH WAS OUTLINED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO STATEMENT LAST
YEAR I'M IN THIS CIRCUMSTANCE
THAT THERE THESE TWO CHOICES
YOU CAN'T REALLY MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION OF WHERE
YOU'RE GONNA END UP GO INTO
WHETHER OR AT THE END OF THE
DAY WHAT IS BEING SAID TO YOU
IS PROMISING TO BE AN EFFECTIVE
MODEL OF TREATMENT -- THAT
YOU'RE GONNA END UP GETTING
BETTER WE FIND THAT THERE ARE
MUCH MORE EFFECTIVE MODELS
I'VE OUR REGION ENGAGEMENT HARM
REDUCTION AND -- PROVIDING THE
PERSON HOUSING WRAPPING AROUND
SERVICES AROUND THE PERSON --
AS THERE'S -- ADDITIONALLY
THERE'S SOME AND SOME AMENDMENTS
TAKE AN THIS YEAR SAYING THAT
THE JUDGE WOULD DETERMINE THAT
THE DECISION WAS NOW KNOWING
VOLUNTARY AND INTELLIGENT I'M
IN THE BILL AND WE SEE THAT
THIS THAT LANGUAGE IS BEING
PROBLEMATIC IN THAT SITUATION
WHERE HOW CAN YOU MAKE
THAT KIND OF A DECISION I'M
ADDITIONALLY THERE'S BEEN SOME
EXCLUSIONS AND THE BILL AROUND
THE TYPE OF CRIMES WHERE THE U.
S. ARE NON VIOLENT NON SERIOUS
NON SEXUAL CRIMES THAT ARE
-- THE DRUG MOTIVATED ONES SO
WE DON'T SEE WHY THERE'D BE A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE THE PERSON
COULD NOT GO UNDER PROBATION
ENGAGE INVOLUNTARY TREATMENT
-- WE SEE A LOT OF ISSUES
WITH -- THE JUDGE DETERMINED
IN THE BANK THAT SENTENCE AS
WELL AS -- THIS GOES AGAINST
THE STANDARDS OF PRACTICE FOR
AROUND THE AMERICAN SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE NOT WHERE
THE PERSON SHOULD BE ASSESSED
AND THEN GIVEN AN OPTION OF
WHAT LEVEL OF CARE TO GO INTO
AS WELL AS THE OPTION FOR
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
-- MEDIC COW CANNOT COVER THE
COST OF THIS PROGRAM IT'S --
VIOLATES THE RULES I'M A STOP
THERE BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IN RESPECT WE ASK
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU IS GO AHEAD
THANK YOU CHAIR NUMBERS LISA
LEWIS HERE ON BEHALF OF DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THE DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE IS THE NATION'S
LEADING ORGANIZATION WORKING
TO END OF THE WAR ON DRUGS AND
REPAIR ITS HARMS BY BUILDING A
POLICY RESPONSE TO DRUGS THAT'S
GROUNDED IN SCIENCE COMPASSION
HEALTH AND HUMAN RIGHTS M.
WE ACKNOWLEDGE YOU KNOW THE
WORK THAT HAS BEEN ON DONE ON
THIS BILL AND THE AMENDMENTS
THE AUTHOR HAS TAKEN THAT THE
NOTED HOWEVER THE BILL STILL IS
NOT IN LINE WITH THE EVIDENCE
BASED MANNER IN WHICH HEALTHCARE
IS PROVIDED TO THOSE WHO ARE
FACING A SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
WE DO NOT DISAGREED THAT MORE
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS IN CALIFORNIA BUT
REPACKAGING IT PROVEN FAILED
POLICY IT WILL NOT WORK AND
FAILS TO ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES
SUCH AS POVERTY TRAUMA AND THE
ENDURING IMPACTS OF RACISM AND
OTHER FORMS OF OPPRESSION THE
BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM AS MY
COLLEAGUE NOTED STILL FAILS TO
ADDRESS -- THE GOVERNOR'S VETO
MESSAGE THAT COURSE TREATMENT
FROM FOR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
IS STILL NOT THE ANSWER THE
BILL STILL OPPOSED BY ALMOST ALL
OF THE STATE TREATMENT AS STATE
LEVEL TREATMENT ASSOCIATIONS
IN CALIFORNIA AND THE SCIENCE
IS NOT SUPPORT THE EFFICACY
OF COURSE TREATMENT AND ON THE
CONTRARY DEMONSTRATES IT IS
INEFFECTIVE AND COSTLY AFTER
RECOVERY IS NOT LINEAR IT OFTEN
WAS INVOLVES RELAXES AND FOR
THIS REASON WE MUST INSTEAD
INVEST OUR RESOURCES INTO
COMMUNITY AND TREATMENT AND
AND THE MOMENT ONCE A PERSON
IS READY TO TAKE THAT NEXT
STEP TREATMENT PROFESSIONALS
RECOMMEND MOVING AWAY FROM
MANDATED TREATMENT AND
INSTEAD TOWARDS EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACHES THAT WORK INCLUDING
LOW BARRIER COMMUNITY DRUG
TREATMENT OVERDOSE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS AND CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE OUTREACH AB NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT STILL THE TRACKS
IN THOSE EFFORTS AND WE DIVERT
RESOURCES THAT COULD BE BETTER
USED IN THE COMMUNITY WELL THIS
BILL HAS BEEN PROMOTED AS JUST
A PILOT TO TRY OUT IT IS NOT
THAT SIMPLE THIS WOULD STILL
NEED SUBSTANTIAL AGENCY WORK
TO ENSURE APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT
CONSIDERING THE FACT THAT TEACH
YES CURRENTLY DOES NOT REGULATE
LOCKED FACILITIES A SUBSTANTIAL
REGULATIONS WOULD NEED TO BE
DEVELOPED TO ENSURE THE SAFETY
OF PARTICIPANTS AND THE STAFF
AND BECAUSE IT DOES NOT FIT INTO
EXISTING LICENSURE REQUIREMENTS
FOR RESIDENTIAL SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT FACILITIES
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT COSTS
FOR ASM CRITERIA THAT'S REQUIRED
BY CURRENT LAW AS WE KNOW FROM
FIFTY YEARS OF ENFORCING THE
WAR ON DRUGS MEETING BECAUSE
OF COLOR BUT STILL BEAR THE
BRUNT OF THIS AND FORCE MET AND
MEMBERS OF THOSE COMMUNITIES
WOULD ALMOST CERTAINLY BE
DISPROPORTIONATELY FORCED INTO
LOCKS TREATMENT LONGER JAIL
SENTENCES AND INSTEAD IN SOME
CASES WERE CONCERNED EXPERIENCE
FATAL OUTCOMES SENSING A PERSON
TO A DRUG TREATMENT INSIDE
A LOCKED FACILITY IS STILL
CRIMINALIZATION IN AB NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT CREATES A FALSE
BELIEF THAT THE ONLY WAY THAT
A PERSON CAN ACCESS SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT IS
THROUGH ARREST AND PROSECUTION
FOR ALL THESE REASONS
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS AND NO
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE IS ANYONE IN THE
CHAMBER HERE TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
JUST YOUR NAME AND POSITION
ON THE BILL ORGANIZATION IF
YOU REPRESENT ONE SHE HAS HAD
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION
PROGRAMS AND PROFESSIONALS
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
C. NO LONGER THE PHONE
LINES MISTRUST BREGER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
IN THE FIRST KEVIN IS FROM
LINE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
PROBABLY ON A BENDER ON BEHALF
OF QUIET IN SAN FRANCISCO
IN OPPOSITION AB NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
SKYMET IS FROM LINE ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS STATE FOR JUST ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN TWENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT CAVENDISH FROM
LINE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YEAH BROAD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA VERY STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMPANIES FROM
LINE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
HI BRAD WILLIAMS THEY
TELL YOU CAL ACTIONS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT TIME IT IS FROM
LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMPANIES FROM LINE
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
HI MY NAME IS JENNY BEAVAN
MERYL WITH DIGNITY AND POWER
NOW IN THE CARE FOR CALIFORNIA
COALITION BECAUSE COURSE OF
TREATMENT NEITHER AFFECTED NOR
AN ALTERNATIVE TO INCARCERATION
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU FIRST NAME ORGANIZATION
ROBERT REPRESENT ONE AND AND
POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM
LINE ONE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN THE BILL
VANDER LANGLEY FROM NIELSEN
WORKS MORE ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF YOUR LOVE AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM
LIKE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
AMERICIUM COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
I I DO I HAVE SOME AND AND
I AND I THINK IT WITH THANK
YOU MISTER MCCARTY -- I KNOW
OBVIOUSLY THIS BILL CAME BEFORE
US LAST YEAR TO PASS OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND I DO HAVE
TO ADMIT I WAS I WAS A BIT
TORN THEN I'M A STILL A LITTLE
BIT TORN NOW -- ON THE ONE
HAND I FULLY UNDERSTAND YOUR
DESIRE TO PROVIDE ENHANCED S.
U. D. TREATMENT TO INDIVIDUALS
WHILE INCARCERATED HOWEVER I
CAN'T IGNORE THE OVERWHELMING
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THE
STEEP IN RESEARCH AND CLINICAL
OUTCOMES ABLE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND ACCORDING TO
WHAT YOU SAID TODAY YOU ACCEPTED
OVER FIFTY AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
NOT ONLY THEIR OPPOSITION BUT
ALSO THE GOVERNOR'S VETO FROM
LAST YEAR I JUST HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS SO FIRST OF ALL YOUR
BILL SUGGESTS THAT THE THE
OPIOID SUMMIT MONIES FOR FUNDING
THIS PROGRAM ARE YOU SUGGESTING
THAT THE STATE PORTION OF THE
SETTLEMENT FUNDS BE USED WOULD
BE USED OR WOULD INDIVIDUAL
COUNTIES USE THEIR SETTLEMENT
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT THESE
PROGRAMS INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES
AND MY FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS ARE
GOING TO BE TO THE OPPOSITION --
I HEARD -- ONE OF THE OPPOSITION
WHICH IS TO SAY THAT -- THAT
THEY DIDN'T BELIEVE THE MEDIC
HOW COULD YOU DO THIS SO SO CAN
YOU EXPLAIN MORE ON WHY MEDICARE
COULD NOT BE USED TO PAY FOR
AB NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT AS
WELL AS THE PROBLEMS WITH USING
THE OPIOID SETTLEMENT FUNDS
AND YOUR CHAIR WIDE FOR THE
QUESTION YEAH SO -- MEDIC HOW --
AS RESTRICTIONS ON IT IF
THE PERSON IS CONSIDERED AN
INMATE YOU CANNOT USE THE MEDIC
HOW TO END UP COVERING THAT COST
AVE AND THEN ALSO WE HAVE HAD
EXPERIENCES WHERE IF A PERSON
IS -- UNABLE TO HAVE FREEDOM OF
MOVEMENT -- IN THE CASES --
THE -- MC ARE PEAS WHICH ARE
-- MAIL CONDITIONAL RELEASE
PROGRAMS YOU CAN ALSO NOT USE
MEDIC HOW TO END UP COVERING
THE COST OF THAT CARE IT'S GONE
ALL THE WAY UP TO SEE A MASS SO
IN THIS CIRCUMSTANCE WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT MEDIC HOW COULD
BE USED TO COVER IT NATIONALLY
AND THE CIRCUMSTANCE AND LIKELY
MANY OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
WOULD BE EXPANSION POPULATION
-- IF MEDIC HOW COULD COVER THE
COST IT WOULD COVER UP TO YOU
YOU KNOW NINETY PERCENT OF THE
COST SO IT'S A SIGNIFICANT LOSS
AN EXTRA COSTS ON THE STATE
OR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THANK YOU
MY FINAL QUESTIONS COVER
MULTIPLE PART QUESTION HERE
SO CAN YOU DESCRIBE THE HARMON
CREEK WHAT WHAT HARM IS IN
CREATING A PILOT PROJECT
YOU KNOW FIRST FOR SECURED
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROGRAM
AND WHY THIS NEW CONCEPT IS
WRONG FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE SURE
HAVE A DANCER AND I APOLOGIZE
I DIDN'T ACTUALLY ANSWER YOUR
OTHER QUESTION ON THE OPIOID
SETTLEMENT FUNDS -- I'M SORRY
-- WE BELIEVE THAT THOSE FINE
SHOULD BE DIRECTED TOWARDS
ATKINS BATES PROGRAMS -- IT
THERE'S BEEN A LARGE COM YOU
KNOW COALITION -- I PRINCIPLES
PUT OUT THERE BY JOHN HOPKINS
UNIVERSITY ON IT THAT THESE
FUND SHOULD BE DETERMINED BY
I'M STAKEHOLDERS WITH A LOT
OF STAKEHOLDER INPUT ON BE
DIRECTED TOWARDS -- VICTIMS OF
THE WAR ON DRUGS AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THE FUND SHOULD BE USED FOR
PRACTICES THAT WE KNOW THAT WORK
LIKE HARM REDUCTION RECOVERY
RESIDENTS HOUSING I'M OUT REACH
AND ENGAGEMENT -- AND TREATMENT
MODELS THAT WE KNOW THAT WORKS
I'M ON YOUR SPECIFIC QUESTION ON
WHY WE BELIEVE THAT THE BILL IS
-- A HARMFUL TO CREATE A PILOT
PROGRAM WE'VE SEEN THAT PROGRAMS
LIKE THIS HAPPEN BEFORE AND
IN OTHER STATES WHERE THEY'VE
USED -- COERCED OR MANDATED
-- OR INVOLUNTARY TREATMENT
AND WE SEEN THAT THOSE MODELS
HAVE NOT ENDED UP WORKING IT
CAN FOSTER DISTRUST BETWEEN IT
BETWEEN THE TREATMENT PROVIDER
AND THE INDIVIDUAL THERE CAN
BE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THERE'S
INCREASED RISK OF OVERDOSE
FOR THE PERSON COMING OUT OF
THE PROGRAM AND WE SEE THAT
THESE -- TYPES OF SITUATIONS
BURNED BRIDGES AND AS WE'VE
SAID BEFORE -- BUT WE BELIEVE
THAT THE YOU CAN FOCUS ON --
INTENSIVE VOLUNTARY TREATMENT
AND SEE JUST THE SAME KIND
OF RESULTS OR IF NOT WORK
SITE BETTER RESULTS THAN YOU
COULD SEE UNDER THIS TYPE OF A
PROGRAM AS WELL AS WE SEE THAT
INDIVIDUALS DON'T HAVE TO BE --
IS THERE'S OTHER CHOICES BETWEEN
THESE TWO CHOICES THANK YOU
THANK YOU UP WOULD YOU CARE TO
COMMENT MISTER MCCARTY YEAH THIS
IS JUST A LOT TO MENTALLY UNPACK
THERE THAT LONG LIST -- BUT
DID NOT SELL AS IS IF THIS BILL
SAID WHAT A LOT OF THE ARGUMENTS
ROUTE LEADING I WOULDN'T BE
UP HERE AUTHORED THIS BILL
IS JUST NOT TRUE --
THERE'S A THERE'S NOT GONNA BE A
LONGER SENTENCE FOR INDIVIDUALS
WE CLEARLY SAYING THE BILL
THAT THEY WOULD SERVE LAST TIME
INTO THE STREET AND THEY WOULD
BE SENTENCED OTHERWISE AND
IT'S A FALSE CHOICE THAT THEY
COULD YOU KNOW HAVE COMMUNITY
WRAPAROUND TREATMENT AT HOME
THE INDIVIDUAL HAS TWO CHOICES
THEY CAN GO TO JAIL OR PRISON
TO BE SENTENCE FOR A TERM FOR
THAT SO THERE'S NOT GOING HOME
WITH AN ANKLE BRACELET GETTING
THE TREATMENT WHEN YOU WISH TO
AROUND THE CORNER THAT'S NOT
A CHOICE YOU'RE SOMEBODY IS
INCENTIVES THEY CAN CERTAINLY
DO THAT AND WE SHOULD DO WHAT
MORE THAN ANYWAY THE ISSUE HERE
IS WHAT PEOPLE ARE SENTENCED
FOR A SIGNIFICANT TERM IN
PRISONERS -- COUNTY JAIL HOW
CAN YOU WORK WITH THEM TO
ADDRESS ADDICTION ISSUE --
AND AS FAR AS THE IT IS BUT IT
IS WITH VOLUNTARY WITH THE DATE
PEOPLE CAN VOLUNTARY SAY YES
TO THIS AND THEY CAN VOLUNTARILY
LEAVE SO THERE'S A CHOICE SO
THIS WEEK WE'RE NOT FORCING A
SPARE OTHER WORDS IF IF I GET
A THREE YEAR SENTENCE MISTER
WOULD AND THAT THE PROVIDER
SAY OKAY WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU
PROGRAM YOU CAN DO TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS INSTEAD IN THIS PROGRAM
SO AFTER ONE MONTH I DECIDE
YOU KNOW WHAT NOT FOR ME YOU
CAN VOLUNTARILY LEAVE AND GO
BACK TO YOUR SENTENCE RIGHT
YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT FORCING PEOPLE
TO MAKE THIS CHOICE WE WE TOOK
THAT THAT NUMBER LAST YEAR
ONE OF OUR FIFTY AMENDMENTS --
SO YOU KNOW I THINK THAT WE
HAVE -- ADDRESSED THAT AND A
NUMBER OF THESE ISSUES WELL
THANK YOU I'M AYE AYES AYE WILL
STILL SAY I HAVE SIGNIFICANT
RESERVATIONS -- -- AS TO THE
MERITS OF A SECURED FACILITY
BUT I WANT TO GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON THE BILL IN THE HOPES THAT
YOU IN OPPOSITION CAN ARRIVE
AT A CONCEPT THAT WILL BE
CLINICALLY SOUND WHILE PROVIDING
TREATMENT TO POPULATION
WHOSE PRIMARY CRIMES ARE
RELATED TO THEIR OBJECTION SO
YOU'LL HAVE MY VOTE TODAY --
YOUR RECORD ALL UP AND AND
BUT BUT I RESERVE MY VOTE ON
THE FLOOR BASED ON HOW THINGS
HOW THINGS GO FORWARD SO AND
MISS WALDRON HAS A COMMON
SORRY I WAS OUT OF THE ROOM --
LAST YEAR I HAD A BILL WHICH THE
LANGUAGE IS INCORPORATED INTO
A BUDGET BILL ONE THREE THREE
THREE THAT -- LOOKED
AT THE ISSUE OF MEDICAL COVERING
PEOPLE WHO WERE INCARCERATED
AND IT PASSED IN THE BUDGET
BILL AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
COULD END UP BEING EVEN THOUGH
THERE ARE OTHER STATES AHEAD
BUT I THINK WE'LL BE WITH
THE FIRST ONE TO GET APPROVAL
OF FOUR FEDERAL WAIVER
WILL ALLOW FOLKS BUT IT'S ONLY
FOR THE NINETY DAYS PRIOR TO
RELEASE WHERE THEY CAN GET INTO
MEDICAL BEING ROLLED IN I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S HELPFUL
IN HYDE IN ORDER TRYING TO
DO BUT THAT IT WOULD THIS
WAITING ON THE WAIVER RIGHT NOW
OKAY ANY ANYONE ELSE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS
WE HAVE A MOTION
MOTION BY MR SANTIAGO
SECOND SECOND MINISTER FOR
I'M PROMOTION TO SECOND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH I CLOSE
REGARDING THAT THANK YOU AND
THIS IS NOT AN EASY ISSUE I
UNDERSTAND THAT -- AND I
APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE ONE
OF THE THINGS I NOTE IN IN
THE LETTER FROM THE -- WHEN
THE OPPONENTS THAT THE --
PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND CRIMINAL
DEFENSE COUNSEL AS OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED THAT'S I THINK
YOU KNOW A POSITIVE STATEMENT
NO IT'S JUST FLAT OPPOSE AND
I WILL SAY OF THAT FIVE THINGS
-- THAT THERE THAT THE SUGGEST
HERE UP TO THEM YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE DOING IN THE BILL
-- AND THEN A COUPLE OF HOURS
I THINK IT'S JUST THERE'S JUST
A MISUNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
IT DOES SO WE ARE WORKING TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE ISSUES
AND UNDERSTAND THIS IS A LONG
PROCESS AND YOU KNOW PEOPLE'S
OPINIONS ARE EVOLVING ON THIS I
WILL SAY YOU KNOW OUR GOVERNOR
-- HE HE HE MADE IT CLEAR THAT
HE'S SOMEWHAT CHANGES POSITION
ON SECURE TREATMENT OPTIONS
FROM FOR PERSONS SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS AND S. YOU AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS YOU
SEE THAT RIGHT HERE HAS A MAJOR
BILL THE SENATE'S GONNA COME
OUT OUR SITES BIG PART OF OUR
BUDGET DISCUSSION IS CARE COURT
SO YOU KNOW THESE THINGS ARE
EVOLVING BASED UPON -- THE THE
-- THE REALITY IN CALIFORNIA
SO -- I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND THE
IMPLIED COLLEAGUES AS WELL AS
ALL PARTIES AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR MCCARTY
SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS --
AS YOU PASS YOUR PREPARATION
SO MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE
WALDRON WALDRON AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY NOT VOTING
ARAMBULA REGULAR I BIGELOW
CARILLO LAURA
LAURA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAYES
MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA
RIVAS
CALDERON CALDERON NOT
VOTING SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE BONTA AYE AUTO AYE
YOUR BROWSER EIGHT VOTES
WILL LEAVE THE OF THE BILLS
OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON AND
THANK YOU TO THE WITNESSES
MISTER RAMOS
-- THE SECOND WAS THE
SECOND WAS THAT MR
SARGO THANK YOU FOR
I KNOW YOU WERE THE SECOND
I'M SORRY NICE TRY OKAY
IT WAS IT WAS THE FIRST
SO YOUR YOU WANT
TO TRY YOUR SECOND
OKAY DON'T CONFUSE ME ANYMORE
THAN I'M ALREADY CONFUSED PLEASE
MISTER RAMOS AND PLEASE DON'T
CONFUSE ME ANYMORE BUT THE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
WELL TO START OFF WITH EXCEPT
IN THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS --
FENTON ALL AN OPIOID OVERDOSES
AND POISONINGS -- HAVE BEEN
RISING AT AN ALARMING RATE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND IN OUR DISTRICTS MANY
OF THE VICTIMS OF OVERDOSES
ESPECIALLY WITH FENNEL HAVE NO
IDEA OF THE POTENCY OF THE
DRUG WHICH IS MANY TIMES MORE
POWERFUL THAN REGULAR OPIOIDS
THANKFULLY IN RECENT YEARS
MEDICAL ADVANCES HAVE BEEN MADE
WITH THE DEVELOPMENT OF PRODUCTS
LIGHTEN OUR CAN WHICH CAN
HELP THOSE IN TIMES OF NEED
AB SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVEN WOULD
GIVE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THE ABILITY TO
DISTRIBUTE OPIOID ANTAGONISE
PRODUCTS SUCH AS NOT CAN'T
APPROVED BY THE FDA TO ANYONE
WHO COMPLETES A FREE TRAINING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT NOT
ONLY WOULD THESE TRAININGS
INCLUDE INFORMATION ON HOW
TO EFFECTIVELY USE THE OPIOID
ANTAGONISE THEY WOULD ALSO
INCLUDE TRAINING ON RECOGNIZING
THE SIGNS OF ADDICTION IN AN
EFFORT TO BE MORE PROACTIVE
TO HEADING OFF A DRUG OVERDOSE
IN ADDITION TO THOSE THESE
TRAININGS AB SIXTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN WOULD ALSO GIVE LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT THE POWER AND
ABILITY TO CREATE OVERDOSE
RESPONSE TEAMS WITH THE SOLE
PURPOSE OF INVESTIGATING THESE
DEATHS AND FINALLY IN THE CARS
TOO OFTEN WE LOSE
LOVED ONES TO ADDICTION
WITHOUT REALIZING THEY ARE
AFFLICTED AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN WHAT A TEMP TO
CHANGE THE PERSPECTIVE IN WHICH
WE APPROACH THIS ADDICTION
AND PROVIDE US WITH A MORE
UNDERSTANDING VIEW OF THIS
CRISIS WITH ME TODAY
TO OFFER TESTIMONY IS
STEVE FILSON A RETIRED
SAMBAR DINO POLICE OFFICER
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
STEVE LOST HIS DAUGHTER OF
TWENTY NINE YEARS JESSICA
TO THIS OPIOID CRISIS
SINCE THEN STEVE HAS BEEN
INVOLVED WITH THE VICTIMS
OF ILLICIT DRUGS ACRONYM
VOID THE SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL AND EDUCATE AND BRING
AWARENESS TO THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU THANK YOU PLEASE
PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS STEVE OLSON I'M A
RESIDENT OF THE CITY OF HIGHLAND
ALONG WITH MY WIFE SHERRY AND
A FIVE YEAR OLD GRANDDAUGHTER
LARA I'M ALSO THE TREASURER
OF VICTIMS OF ILLICIT DRUGS
AND A RETIRED SERGEANT FROM THE
SENATE IN A POLICE DEPARTMENT
MOST IMPORTANTLY I AM JESSICA'S
DAD JESSICA WAS OUR TWENTY
NINE YEAR OLD DAUGHTER WHO DIED
BECAUSE OF FENTANYL TOXICITY
ON JANUARY TWENTY SECOND
TWENTY TWENTY SINCE THAT TIME
MY FAMILY AND MANY OTHERS
ABOUT TOGETHER AND DEDICATED
OUR LIVES TO THE PURPOSE OF
EDUCATION AND AWARENESS OF THE
EVER ESCALATING DEATHS DUE TO
VICTIMS UNKNOWINGLY INGESTING
THIS POWERFUL SYNTHETIC POISSON
ORGANIZATIONS SPEAKS OF THREE
OVERRIDING FACTORS FIRST OF ALL
FENTON ALL CHANGES EVERYTHING
SECONDLY BUT FOR PHANTOM ALL OUR
LOVED ONES WOULD STILL BE ALIVE
AND LAST FEDERAL IS A PROBLEM
THAT MOST DON'T EVEN KNOW
EXISTS EDUCATION AND
AWARENESS WILL HELP TO REDUCE
THE LACK OF KNOWLEDGE AND IS
THE FIRST AND MOST FUNDAMENTAL
STEP OF HARM REDUCTION WE'RE
BEGINNING TO SEE A BIT MORE
CONSISTENT MEDIA ATTENTION TO
THE PROBLEM BUT A MUCH MORE
AGGRESSIVE EFFORT NEEDS TO
BE UNDERTAKEN NATIONALLY AND
WITHIN OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
WE MUST REALIZE THAT A LISTED
FENTANYL IS FIFTY TIMES STRONGER
THAN HEROIN AND A HUNDRED
TIMES STRONGER THAN MORPHINE A
SUBSTANCE WITH THIS ADDICTIVE
AND FATAL POTENTIAL NEEDS THE
ATTENTION NECESSARY TO MITIGATE
THESE DEATHS TWO EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT COMPONENTS TO THAT
END EXIST IN THE LANGUAGE
OF BABY SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
FIRST WE KNOW THE LEGISLATION
PROVIDES THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
DISTRIBUTION FREE OF CHARGE TO
LOCAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ENTITIES
OF NALOXONE WHICH WILL PROVIDE
THAT POTENTIAL LIFESAVING
MITIGATING STEP TO HELP PEOPLE
BLOCKS ON DISTRIBUTED UNDER THE
BRAND NAME OF DARK CANDICE A
LIFESAVING MEDICATION THAT CAN
REVERSE AN OVERDOSE FROM OPIOIDS
INCLUDING THOSE POISONED BY
FENTANYL OFTEN GIVEN AS A NASAL
SPRAY NALOXONE IS SAFE AND
EASY TO USE IT QUICKLY REVERSES
AN OVERDOSE BY BLOCKING THE
ADVERSE EFFECTS AND CAN RESTORE
NORMAL BREATHING WITHIN TWO
TO THREE MINUTES AND A PERSON
WHO'S BROUGHT THIS SLOWED OR
EVEN STOPPED MORE THAN ONE DOSE
OF NALOXONE MAY BE REQUIRED
WITH STRONGER SUBSTANCES LIKE
FENTANYL WHEN THAT ARE INVOLVED
MOST IMPORTANTLY IN A TWELVE
MONTH PERIOD ENDING IN APRIL
TWENTY FOUR ONE OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND ILLICIT DRUG DEATHS
OCCURRED THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTRY
OF THE SIXTY FIVE PERCENT
WERE DIRECTLY ATTRIBUTABLE
TO FENTANYL TOXICITY SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND INTERESTINGLY
A STUDY FOUND THAT BYSTANDERS
WERE PRESENT IN MORE THAN ONE
THIRD OF THESE INCIDENTS ANYONE
CAN CARRY NALOXONE GIVE IT
TO SOMEONE IN NEED AND SAVE
A LIFE WITH THE RIGHT TOOLS
BYSTANDERS CAN ACT TO PREVENT
DEATHS THE LOCKS ON IS THAT
TOOL BUT SADLY IS NOT READILY
AVAILABLE TO ADMINISTER AND
ACCOMPLISH THAT LIFESAVING
TASK AB SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
WOULD PROVIDE THAT TOOL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
TESTIMONY NUMBER I'M
SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS THANK
HELLO MORE BUT IS THERE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
YOU KNOW WHAT IS ANYONE IN
THE CHAMBER LIKE TO SUPPORT
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITH JUST YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT MORE THANK YOU MY
NAME IS KRISTEN HERE FROM
ROCKLAND THIS IS MY
SON ZACHARY DID HERE
FOREVER SEVENTEEN HE WAS A
VICTIM OF FENTANYL POISONING
ON DECEMBER TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE YEAR THREE MONTHS
AND TWO DAYS AGO CDC REPORTS
A FEDERAL RELATED DEATH EVERY
EIGHT MINUTES AND MEASURES
LIKE THIS HOW BUILD BETTER
SAFEGUARDS TO ADDRESS THIS
SERIOUS PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE
OUR FAMILY IS STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF OF A. B. SIXTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
THE NUMBER OVER THE PHONE LINES
AND JUST A NAME AND POSITION
ON THE BILL AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
THE FIRST COMMENT IS
FROM THE LINE ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS TIME IT WORKED OUT
I AM THE PRESIDENT OF BOYD AND
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU
THE NEXT GOVERNMENT IS FROM
LINE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
-- ARMOR SHEET WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA SUPPORTED
HIM AND -- THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM
THE LINE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
HI AGAIN BY EACH MAN ON
BEHALF OF THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM LINE
ONE HUNDRED TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THIS IS A NOVEL AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE ALEXANDER
NOBLE FOUNDATION AND WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM NINE
EIGHTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
RIGHT EIGHTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
PLEASE LET ME TOO MANY
YES
HI MY NAME THREE BECAUSE
THERE IS AN UNCLE IN THE
PORT OF THE THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMPANIES
FROM LINE EIGHTY SIX
HELLO MY NAME IS PERLA MENDOZA
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM
LINE ONE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
MY NAME IS SURELY OFTEN ON THE
GRANDPARENTS OF A SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD VICTIM UPSET NOR
PLACE NAME AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS AT THIS POINT MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE DR REGULAR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANTED TO
TAKE A SECOND AND THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD HAVING
WORKED ON THE FRONT LINES
AND SEEING THE EFFECT THAT
MARTIN HAS BEEN SAVING LIVES
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO WORK WITH OUR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGENCIES AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE EMPOWERING THE
COUNTIES THROUGH THIS PILOT
PROGRAM I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING IT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISS WALDRON
THANK YOU AND I ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR BRING
THIS PHOTO ID AS A PROUD TO
CALL AUTHOR OF THE BILL --
IT'S SO NECESSARY WHEN WE
HEAR ABOUT JUST I MEAN IT'S
JUST INADVERTENT IT COULD BE
LACED ANY ANY ANYTHING OF
BE LACED WITH FRIENDS ON ALL
OF THIS IS A TERRIBLE CRISIS
THAT'S GOING ON AND I'VE
HEARD FROM SO MANY FOLKS IN
MY DISTRICT YOU KNOW WHO'S
WHO'S YOUNG SON OR DAUGHTER
HAS HAD THIS -- THIS THIS
TRAGEDY HAPPENED TO THEM
AND THE REALLY THE EDUCATION
AND THEY THE PREVALENCE OF THE
NOR CAN SHOULD BE SIMILAR TO
AN EPIPEN I MEAN THERE SHOULD
BE SOMEONE EVERYWHERE WHO HAS
THAT AVAILABLE AND IS TRAINED
TO USE IT SO URGENT I VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
SEE NO ONE THE BILL DOES ENJOY
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MID DR GRANULOCYTE
BY MR SANTIAGO THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO PUBLIC
SAFETY WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE
MISTER ROBERTS THANK GOODNESS
TRAFFIC YOU FOR THE COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS TIME
I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I BIGELOW
CARILLO LARA
I MAIENSCHEIN
MAYES MCCARTY
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN
RIVAS RIVAS I CALDERON
CALDERON I SANTIAGO
BONTA BONTA HI
LANCASTER YOU HAVE NINE VOTES
A BILL IS OUT WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER STAT
ON THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU TAKE MEASUREMENTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THIS RIVAS
AND THREE OF US HAS
AB TWENTY FOUR OH FOUR
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THE BILL
HAS A MOTION AND A SECOND GREAT
THANK YOU I'M GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY TEAM -- ON THIS ANALYSIS
I WILL ALSO BE ACCEPTING THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
SIX OF THE ANALYSIS AB
TWENTY FOUR OH FOUR WOULD GRANT
PACIFICA HOSPITAL OF THE VALLEY
AND EXTENSION TO SEISMICALLY
RETROFIT THEIR BUILDINGS WHILE
CONTINUING TO PROVIDE SERVICES
TO AN UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY AS
YOU MAY KNOW I REPRESENT THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY THIS IS WHERE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE -- THERE
WAS A AND IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR -- THERE WAS EARTHQUAKES
TOOK PLACE IN AND BOTH OF THOSE
YEARS THESE EARTHQUAKES CAUSED
HOSPITALS IN THE GREATER LA
REGION TO EITHER COLLAPSED
OR SUSTAINED MAJOR STRUCTURAL
DAMAGE FOLLOWING THE SILMAR
EARTHQUAKE THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED THAT ALQUIST ACT IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE WHICH
REQUIRED ALL NEW HOSPITAL
CONSTRUCTION TO MEET STRINGENT
SEISMIC SAFETY STANDARDS
TWENTY YEARS AFTER THAT
ALQUIST ACT WAS PASSED THE
NORTHRIDGE EARTHQUAKE PROMPTED
THE LEGISLATURE TO UPDATE
THE ACT IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR TO BRING OLDER HOSPITAL
BUILDINGS INTO COMPLIANCE
WITH STRUCTURAL REQUIREMENTS
THIS UP THE IN THE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ANOTHER BILL AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RADIUS REQUIRED
ALL HOSPITALS WITH STRUCTURAL
PERFORMANCE CATEGORY OR S. PC
ONE BUILDINGS TO SUBMIT A
BINDING APPLICATION TO OFSHE PAD
BY JULY FIRST OF TWENTY NINETEEN
THAT STATES WHETHER THEY PLAN TO
APPLY SEISMIC SAFETY STANDARDS
TO THEIR FACILITIES THIS BILL
ALSO REQUIRED OFSHE PAD TO GRANT
EXTENSIONS TO THE SEISMIC SAFETY
COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS IN THE
CASE OF REBUILDS REPLACEMENTS
-- RETROFITS BY JULY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO PACIFICA
HOSPITAL OF THE VALLEY HAS
THREE BOB AS PC ONE BUILT
INS THE HOSPITAL DEVELOPED
AND SUBMITTED A CONSTRUCTION
SCHEDULE BEFORE APRIL FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TO OFSHE PAD
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC DURING
THE PANDEMIC PACIFICA HOSPITAL
BECAME A REGIONAL SERVICE CENTER
FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO HELP
DECOMPRESS ALL HOSPITALS DEALING
WITH COVERT SINCE JANUARY
OF TWENTY TWENTY THEY HAVE BEEN
SERVING HIGH VOLUMES OF COVERT
NINETEEN PATIENTS INCLUDING
THOSE WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ISSUES ADDITIONALLY THERE WAS
EXTENDED PERIODS THROUGHOUT
TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE'RE CONTRACTORS AN ARCH
BUT INSPECTORS REFUSED TO ENTER
HOSPITALS TO DO OR INSPECT
CONSTRUCTION WORK OFSHE PEDS
FAILURE TO SEND CONTRACTORS AND
INSPECTORS HAS CAUSED A SUDDEN
SIGNIFICANT DELAY IN PACIFICA
HOSPITALS ABILITY TO MEET THEIR
MAY THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TWO DEADLINE TO COMPLETE THE
PROJECT -- IF PACIFIC A HOSPITAL
IS UNABLE TO MEET THE DEADLINE
FOR STRUCTURAL INCREMENTS THIS
YEAR THEY WOULD BE FINE TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER DAY FOR
EACH BUILDING AS A RESULT THE
PACIFIC A HOSPITAL WOULD BE
FINED FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
DAILY OR FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND MONTHLY THESE FINES ARE
NOT SUSTAINABLE FOR A HOSPITAL
WHERE EIGHTY PERCENT OF THE
PATIENTS SERVED ARE ON MEDI CAL
OR AND A MEDIC CAL MANAGED
CARE OF I TODAY I
HAVE A PRECIOUS MAYES CEO
OF PACIFIC A HOSPITAL OF THE
VALLEY PROVIDING TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
UNDER HERE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND HEALTH CARE
COMMITTEE WE APPRECIATE YOU
LISTENING TO US IN FOR TODAY I'M
MISRI THIS ACTUALLY GIVE A VERY
GREAT GREAT OVERVIEW OVER MY
NOTES IN TERMS OF THE HOSPITAL
LET ME GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT
DEEPER DIVE INTO THE CIVIC
HOSPITAL OF THE VALLEY -- WE
DO SERVE EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT
OF MEDICAL IN THE POPULATION
WE SERVE OVER SEVENTEEN ZIP
CODES OVER SOME OF HER EIGHTY
THREE THOUSAND -- INDIVIDUALS
AND THOSE SEVENTEEN ZIP CODES
I'M A GOOD FOR A GOOD FIFTY
TWO PERCENT OF OUR POSITION
OUR OUR PATIENT ADMISSIONS
ARE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PATIENT
ADMISSIONS AND AS THE PANDEMIC
HAS EXPOSED THE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES IN THE BAY HAVE A
HEALTH ISSUES THAT WE HAVE IN
NOT ONLY THE NATION BUT ALSO
IN CALIFORNIA AND IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL WE HAVE A
LOT TO HAVE A HEALTH UNIT I'M
IN A THIRTY NINE BAD LUCK TO
HAVE A HEALTH UNIT IN PACIFIC
HOSPITAL WE ALSO DURING THE
HEIGHT OF THE PANDEMIC AND
WHEN I HAD NINETY PERCENT OF
MY STAFF OUT AND HAD TO REQUEST
THE NATIONAL GUARD WE ACTUALLY
GREENLIT IN COLLABORATION WITH
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH TO
PROGRAMS TO TAKE IN HOMELESS
-- COATED POSITIVE PATIENTS
-- THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND THEN ALSO MEDICAL
PATIENTS ARE MEDICAL SURGICAL
FLOORS IN THOSE SURGED -- AREAS
THAT NOBODY ELSE WANTED TO TAKE
WE ALSO SURGED THE HOSPITAL TO
CAPACITY WE HAD A SEVEN BED I
SEE YOU A SEVEN BED ER BUT WE
SEARCHED OUR OUR HOSPITAL BEDS
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S URGENCY TO
ALL HOSPITALS TO TO OPEN UP ANY
SPACES TO OVER SIXTY ICO BEDS
ENTOLOMA THREE BEDS WE HAVE
CENTS INCLUDING UP UNTIL NOW WE
ARE SERVING OVER THIRTY SINCE
THE PANDEMIC THIS YEAR THREE
THOUSAND COVERED POSIT PATIENTS
JUST FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PATIENTS LONG -- DO TOO
MUCH OF WHAT OCCUPIED NOW H.
KAIT WASN'T ABLE TO COME OUT
AND AND DELIVER AND THAT WE WERE
NOT ALLOWED TO HAVE VISITORS IN
A HOSPITAL AND BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC WE WE DID HAVE SEISMIC
STOP -- WE HAVE SINCE SINCE
SPENT OVER SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
I'M TO DATE AND HAVE ANOTHER TEN
MILLION IN CONTRACTED SERVICES
TO GET TO GET THIS FINISHED
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY MOVE
FORWARD WE APPRECIATE -- YOURS
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
SEEING NONE -- ANYBODY IN THE
CHAMBER WISH TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION FOR THE BILL
I WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MISTER OPERATOR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF
YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
ON THIS ISSUE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND AND ZERO HE
IN OUR FIRST COMMENT IS FROM
LINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED
MEMBERS MEGAN LOPER ARE CALLING
IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT NEXT COME IT WILL
COME FROM A LINE OUT OF ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN THANK YOU AND
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MY DEVELOPMENT TO TO IT I AM
URGING THAT THE COMMITTEE TO
APPROVE TWENTY FOUR OH FOUR I
AM A COMMUNITY LIAISON --
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY AND I
THIRTEEN I ASK THIS COMMITTED
TO PLEASE PLEASE SUPPORT
DOING IT FOR ALL POLL IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE HELL
GOD THIS IS SOMETHING IN THE
VALLEY AND THE WHOLE ENTIRE
SOMETHING AN AMENDMENT AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THANK YOU
AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS MR THANK YOU BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
SO WE HAVE A MOTION FOR MISTER
FLORES SECOND BY MISS WALDRON
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WHICH LIKE
CLOSE THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH A MAN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT
I WOULD AYE WALDRON WALDRON
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY A. I.
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW
CARILLO LAURA LAURA
I MAIENSCHEIN MAYES
MCCARTY MCCARTY I NAZARIAN
RIVAS I REQUEST I CALDERON
CALDERON I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I. BONTA HI BONTA HI
YOU HAVE TEN VOTES THE BILL
IS OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
ANY CARRY MUCH THIS RUBIO
YOU HAVE AB
TWENTY FOUR OH TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
TWENTY FOUR OH TWO AND THE
COMMITTEE HERE TODAY AB TWENTY
FOUR OH TWO WOULD PROVIDE
CONTINUOUS MEDICAL COVERAGE
FOR CHILDREN AGES ZERO TO
FIVE IN CALIFORNIA MIKHAIL'S
PREVENTATIVE CARE RATES FOR
YOUNG CHILDREN ARE DISMALLY
LOW AND THE PANDEMIC HAS ONLY
INCREASED THOSE RATES AREN'T
WELL CHILD OF PREVENTIVE CARE
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT
WHEN NINETY PERCENT OF THE BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT OCCURS DURING THIS
PERIOD THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS RECOMMENDS
FOURTEEN WELL CHILD VISITS TO
ADMINISTER CRITICAL PREVENTATIVE
CARE -- SUCH AS IMMUNIZATIONS
AND TRACKING DEVELOPMENTAL
MILESTONES BECAUSE MEDICAL IS
THE PRIMARY SOURCE OF COVERAGE
FOR CHILDREN OF COLOR MEDI
CAL'S LOW PREVENTATIVE CARE
RATES DISPROPORTIONATELY DEPRIVE
CHILDREN OF COLOR OF ESSENTIAL
HEALTH SERVICES WORSENING CHILD
HEALTH INEQUITIES THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES HAS
DATA WHICH INDICATES THAT
ABOUT TEN PERCENT OF YOUNG
CHILDREN EXPERIENCED TURN IN
THE MEDICAL COVERAGE MEANING
THEY LOSE MEDICAL COVERAGE AND
THEN RETURN THE AMOUNT THAT
AMOUNTS TO ABOUT NINETY THOUSAND
CHILDREN AGES ZERO TO FIVE
A MEDIC CAL HAVING A GAP IN
COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR OH TWO WILL AND THESE
GAPS BY PROVIDING CONTINUOUS
COVERAGE CONTINUES COVERAGE
WILL IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
LOW INCOME CHILDREN WHILE ALSO
ADDRESSING THE AN EQUAL IMPACT
OF THE COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC
ON COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY AND I HAVE
A WITNESSES HERE GREAT THANK YOU
THIS GRANT THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
WOULD AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I'M KRISTIN GOLDEN TESTED WITH
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP HERE
AS A PROUD I'M A CO SPONSOR OF
THIS LEGISLATION -- TO STABILIZE
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN IN MEDIC CAL THIS
IS A BUILDING ON AN EXISTING
POLICY THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW A
MEDIC CAL CALLED TWELVE MONTHS
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE AND THE
PURPOSE IS THE SAME WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT CHILDREN ARE
MAINTAIN EARNING THEIR COVERAGE
-- AND NOT GETTING CAUGHT UP IN
AN ADMINISTRATIVE -- PROCEDURES
THAT -- WHEN THEY'RE ALREADY
ELIGIBLE WE DON'T WANT THEM
LOSING COVERAGE AND IT'S ALSO
SIMILAR TO THE PROCESS THAT
WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW DURING
THIS PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
WHERE ACROSS THE COUNTRY --
EVERYBODY IN MEDICAID IS ALLOWED
TO MAINTAIN THEIR COVERAGE
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS
IN RECOGNITION THAT THERE
ARE PARTICULAR PERIODS AND IN
TIME WHEN IT'S IMPORTANT TO
PRIORITIZE AND PROTECT COVERAGE
AND EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT
IS ONE OF THOSE TIMES THAT WE
WANT TO PROTECT AND MAKE SURE
CHILDREN KEEP THEIR COVERAGE --
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN RIGHTFULLY
POINTED OUT HOW IMPORTANT
HEALTHY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT
IS AND MAKING SURE THEY GET
THOSE VISITS ANY MISSING OF
TIME EVEN IF IT'S FOR A SHORT
GAP OF TIME A MONTH THREE
MONTHS OF MISSING COVERAGE
MEANS THAT THEY MAY MISS ONE
OF THOSE IMPORTANT FOURTEEN
VISITS AND THERE'S NO MAKING IT
UP THEIR CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT
IS HAPPENING SO FAST EACH ONE
OF THEM IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
AND HAS ALSO MENTIONED THIS IS
A PIVOTAL TIME FOR CHILDHOOD
EQUITY -- IN THAT THAT THESE
CHILDREN AS THIS IS THEIR START
IN THEIR LIVES AND MEDIC CAL IS
COVERING -- A THREE FOURTHS
OF THE CHILDREN IN MEDIC HOW
ARE CHILDREN OF COLOR SO THIS
IS OUR OPPORTUNITY MEDIC HOUSE
RATES UNFORTUNATELY ARE VERY LOW
RIGHT NOW AND PREVENTIVE CARE
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO MAKE AN
IMPACT ON THEM IS THAT WE START
MAKING SURE THEY HAVE CONTINUOUS
COVERAGE AND CAN GET THOSE
VISITS I'M I WANT TO REITERATE
THESE ARE ELIGIBLE CHILDREN
THESE ARE CHILDREN WE'VE ALREADY
MADE AN OBLIGATION TO COVER
AND WE WANT TO CONTINUE THAT
COVERAGE AND THERE'S NO REASON
WHY WE SHOULD BE A NOT HAVING
THEM HAVE CONTINUED COVERAGE
I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT --
IN UP IN WASHINGTON STATE AND
OREGON STATE THEY ARE SEEKING
-- PROPOSAL SIMILAR TO THIS
AND HAVE MADE SOME THAT MEANT
-- SUBMISSIONS TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR THAT SO WE'RE
FOLLOWING IN THEIR TRACKS LET'S
NOT LEAVE OUR STATE OUR CHILDREN
BEHIND AND IN THAT I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO
FOR HER CHAMPIONING OF THIS BILL
-- AND I THINK YOU'LL HEAR FROM
OUR NEXT TO -- SPEAKER ABOUT
HOW ON THE EXPERIENCE IS FOR
FAMILIES WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO
KEEP THEIR COVERAGE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN MEDIC CAL THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRPERSON WATER
MEMBERS OF THE FAMILY HEALTH
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DIANA
GARCIA I'M A DAD I'M POLICY
ANALYST AT FIRST FIVE ALAMEDA
COUNTY HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT
AB TWENTY FOUR OH TWO WHICH
WOULD MAKE MEDICAL CONTINUES
ELIGIBILITY AVAILABLE TO ALL
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
UNTIL THEIR FIFTH BIRTHDAY
FIRST FIVE ALAMEDA COUNTY IS
COMMITTED TO ADVOCATING FOR AN
ACHIEVING EQUITY WITH THE FOCUS
ON RACIAL AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE
TO ENSURE THAT ALL CHILDREN
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY ARE BORN
HEALTHY AND CAN ACHIEVE THEIR
FULL POTENTIAL OVER THE YEARS
ARE ALAMEDA COUNTY KINDERGARTEN
READINESS ASSESSMENT HAS FOUND
THAT DIFFERENCES IN KINDERGARTEN
READINESS ARE LARGELY
ATTRIBUTABLE TO INEQUITIES IN
ACCESS TO RESOURCES AND
THE GREATEST MOVABLE FACTOR
CONTINUES TO BE CHILD HEALTH AND
WELLBEING MEDICAL SERVES AS A
PRIMARY SOURCE OF COVERAGE FOR
OVER TWENTY PERCENT OF CHILDREN
AGES ZERO TO SIX AND ALAMEDA
COUNTY -- THIS COVERAGE OVER
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND CHILDREN
CAN ACCESS PEDIATRICS SERVICES
THERAPIES INCLUDING SPEECH
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY PHYSICAL
THERAPY AND APPLIED BEHAVIOR
ANALYSIS AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES MEDICAL COVERAGE
IS CRITICAL FOR THE HEALTH
AND DEVELOPMENT OF CHILDREN
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING A GREATER DEGREE
OF VOLATILITY AND EMPLOYMENT
INCOME AND HOUSING HOWEVER
OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE HEARD
COUNTLESS STORIES FROM FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING DISRUPTIONS IN
THEIR ACCESS TO CARE DURING
THEIR CHILD'S FIRST TWO YEARS OF
LIFE BECAUSE OF THE CONFUSING AN
OVER COMPLICATED REDETERMINATION
PROCESS AND ALAMEDA COUNTY
CHALLENGES LEADING TO PERIODS
OF LOST COVERAGE AT THE
MOST ARE MOST OFTEN CAUSED
BY OVERWHELMING AMOUNTS OF
PAPERWORK REQUIREMENTS TO SHOW
PROOF OF INCOME WHEN IT DOESN'T
ALIGN WITH THE TYPE OF WORK
FAMILIES TO TIGHT DEADLINES
BETWEEN THE TIME FAMILIES
RECEIVED A NOTICE FOR RE
CERTIFICATION AND THE DEADLINE
TO FILE LONG WAIT TIMES OVER
THE PHONE AND AND OFFICES FOR
SUPPORT AND CONTINUED FEAR DUE
TO IMMIGRATION STATUS ENTRANCE
MEDICAL LEGIBILITY SURE REMAIN
A STANDARD PRACTICE FOR CHILDREN
UNDER THE AGE OF FIVE AFTER
THE FEDERAL COVER NINETEEN
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY IS
LIFTED SO THAT CHILDREN RECEIVE
TIMELY ACCESS TO PREVENTATIVE
HEALTH SERVICES AS WELL AS
EARLY INTERVENTION TO MITIGATE
LEARNING DEVELOPMENTAL AND
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL DELAYS CHILDREN
NOT LOSE COVERAGE DURING THE
FIRST FIVE YEARS OF LIFE BECAUSE
OF ADMINISTRATIVE AND SYSTEMIC
BARRIERS THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT FAMILIES OF COLOR MEDICAL
FAMILIES ALREADY HAVE SO MANY
HURDLES TO OVERCOME JUST TO
GET BY GETTING ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE SHOULD NOT BE ONE MORE IT
IS IN OUR COLLECTIVE INTEREST TO
COLOR CULTIVATE THE CONDITIONS
NEEDED TO SUPPORT CHILDREN'S
HEALTH AND DEVELOPMENT
ESPECIALLY IN THE EARLIEST
YEARS OF LIFE SO EVERY CHILD
CAN REACH THEIR FULL POTENTIAL
AND TO CONTRIBUTE TO OUR STATE'S
FUTURE SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY FOR THESE REASONS
WE SUPPORT YOUR WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND AB TWENTY FOUR TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL HERE BOB
SEE NO ONE WILL BRING IT BACK
-- WERE ACTUALLY LESS PEOPLE
IN THE CHAMBER I JUST YOUR NAME
AND POSITION ON THE BILL IF
YOU'RE HIS SUPPORT OPPOSITION
THANKS GOOD AFTERNOON LINDA WAY
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
TIM MADDEN REPRESENT A
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINES OUT
MADAM MR ROBERT EXCUSE ME
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- IF
YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
AT THIS POINT TO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND AND ZERO IN THE
FIRST COMMENT WILL COME FROM
THE LINE OF NUMBER EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS KELLY
MCMILLAN AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MARCH OF DIMES AS THE
PROUD CO SPONSOR IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO FOUR OH TWO THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FOR THE
LINE OF LINE EIGHTY THREE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THERE BUT DON'T HAVE THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT AND SUPPORT
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM LINE
ONE HUNDRED SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HE LATER
ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN
SPECIALTY CARE COALITION AND
SUPPORT TEAM HERE -- THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMEDIES FROM LINE
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN HELLO
THIS IS KEVIN AND GO WITH
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM LINE
ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
WHEN EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
OKAY THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM
THE LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON
MEDICARE MEMBERS STEPPED
AROUND OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT
AS PART WE CAN GET A LETTER IN
ON PART THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMPETITION
LINE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
GOOD AFTERNOON MY COULD
THEIR CHILDREN OUT SPARKLE
SPONSORING SUPPORT YOU
THE NEXT COMMENT IS
FROM NINE ONE NINETY ONE
THANK YOU FOR TAKING ON
THE HAPPEN OUR FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT IF
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM
THE LINE ONE NINETY THREE
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS HELLO THEY TORE THE
HEALTH ACT OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
OH TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT TIME IT IS FROM
LINE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE
SHOULD YOU TELL ME TO TURN
MEMBERS J. CALCANEAL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LINE FROM CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES AND SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR OH TWO THANK YOU
THE NEXT TIME IT IS TO
REMIND ONE HUNDRED NINETY TWO
ONE REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION WERE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THE NEXT COMEDIES FROM
THE NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
JANE CAN -- WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THE NEXT CONFIDENCE FROM
LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETY FOUR
ELMER SHEET WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU YOU
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN CUBA
SECUREMENT WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
THE BILL HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM DOCTOR
GRANULOCYTE BY MR SANTIAGO
SHOULD THE BILL PASS OUT I WOULD
WAS IT BUT YOU
ALL RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT
REWIND WE HAVE A MOTION BY
DOCTOR ARAMBULA NO WE DIDN'T
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MID
AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND BY MR
SANTIAGO TO GET IT RIGHT FINALLY
I APPRECIATE THE FIRST
THE MOTION IN THE SECOND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE I'M JUST I'M JUST OKAY
AGUIAR-CURRY AGAINST THE
MOTION ARAMBULA GETS A SECOND
DO PASS TO PREPARATIONS
I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR AP EVEN AFTER THIS YES IT
HERE ABSOLUTELY I WOULD WALK ON
THAT THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU A MAN SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL BEFORE I
SCREW ANYTHING ELSE WHAT
IS LATE WE UNDERSTAND I WOULD
I WALDRON WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW
-- YEAH
LAURA LAURA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE A BASE
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN
RIVAS RIVAS III CALDERON
CALDERON AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE BONTA AYE BONTA AYE
LIVE IN THIS AREA YOU HAVE
ELEVEN VOTES A BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU APPRECIATE ALL OF
THE FOR OTHER SAT ON THANK YOU
OKAY MOVING TO THE NEXT ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE A. B. TWO ZERO
SEVEN NINE BY CHAIRMAN WHAT
FOR SAM I DO IS TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE EVEN THOUGH SAID NOT
TO -- FIRST
OF ALL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS PROUD TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY SEVENTY NINE
THIS COMMITTEE HAS SPENT
SIGNIFICANT TIME OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS WORKING TO
IMPROVE THE CARE THAT NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS RECEIVE I'M
PROUD OF MUCH OF THE WORK WE'VE
DONE BUT WE STILL NEED TO DO
MORE THIS BILL MAKE SOME NOTE
WORTHY AND IMPORTANT CHANGES AND
HOW SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
WILL MANAGE THEIR MONEY AND
IT WILL IMPROVE THE QUALITY
OF CARE THAT RESIDENTS RECEIVE
THE BILL REQUIRES A FACILITY
TO SPEND EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT
OF ITS TOTAL REVENUES ON DIRECT
PATIENT CARE MUCH THE SAME
WAY THAT INSURANCE COMPANIES
ARE ALREADY REQUIRED TO PUT
EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT OF REVENUES
INTO PATIENT CARE THROUGH THE
USE OF MEDICAL LOSS RATIOS
RIGHT PATIENT CARE INCLUDES AN
APPROPRIATELY SO STAFFING WAGES
BENEFITS THERAPY SUPPLIES
PHARMACY PLANT OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE LAUNDRY AND DIETARY
ALL THE THINGS THAT DIRECTLY
BENEFIT A RESIDENT OF ITS
OF A NURSING HOME NON DIRECT
CARE WON'T COUNT TOWARDS THAT
EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT REDUCE
SPENDING REQUIREMENT AND
INCLUDES ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
EXECUTIVE WAGES PAYMENT TO
MANAGEMENT COMPANIES HOME
OFFICE EXPENSES FOR PARENT
COMPANIES AND PROFITS PAID TO
CONTRACTORS ARE RELATED PARTY
ENTITIES AMONG OTHER THINGS WE
HAD A CONTENT PER COMPREHENSIVE
INTERIM HEARING LAST OCTOBER
ON LICENSING OF SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES HEARD MUCH ABOUT
WHAT ARE CALLED RELATED PARTIES
DURING THE TESTIMONY AND HOW
THEY CAN SIPHON PROFITS OUT
OF THESE FACILITIES MONEY THAT
COULD HAVE AND SHOULD HAVE BEEN
SPENT ON RESIDENTS FOR EXAMPLE
I DON'T WANT FACILITY OWNERS
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF LOOPHOLES
THAT ALLOW COMPANIES THAT
OWN SAY FIVE FACILITIES USE A
RELATED ENTITY THEY ALSO OWN
TO BUILD THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
EVERY MONTH IN ADMINISTRATIVE
FEES OR USE A LAUNDRY COMPANY
THEY ALSO OWN THE BILL EACH
OF THEIR FACILITIES WHAT
MAY BE OVER MARKET FEES FOR
SERVICES THE BILL BUILDS UPON
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT HELP OF FOR THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES
TO AUDIT NURSING HOME IT
MEDIKAL SPENDING AND FOR THOSE
FACILITIES REPORT FINANCIAL
INFORMATION TO DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
INFORMATION THE BILL REQUIRES
THE TO DO DEPARTMENTS TO
LOOK AT THE INFORMATION WHEN
REVIEWING THE FACILITY REPORTS
ON REVENUES AND THEN DECIDE IF
THE EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT SPENDING
REQUIREMENT WAS MET IF DOT DH
CS WHICH ALREADY HAS A MECHANISM
FOR CALLING BACK MEDICARE
PAYMENTS AND DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH WITH LICENSEES LICENSES
THESE FACILITIES REQUIRE THAN
PROVIDE REBATES TO THE PAIR'S
MEDI CAL MEDICARE OR PRIVATE
INSURANCE COMPANIES SIMILAR
TO THE MLR AS WE REQUIRE OF
INSURANCE COMPANIES WHEN A
STOP HERE I'M GONNA GIVE MY TWO
WITNESSES TO COVER ANYTHING I'VE
MISSED WE HAVE WITH US TODAY
CHARLENE HARRINGTON A PROFESSOR
IS PROFESSOR EMERITA UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO
REPRESENTING THE GERIATRIC
CIRCLE AND INFORMAL STATEWIDE
GROUP OF OF OF JERIT ACADEMIC
GERIATRIC EXPERTS THAT'S A
MOUTHFUL -- AT TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWO COULD TELL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR NURSING
HOME REFORM MS HARRINGTON HAS
DONE IMPORTANT RESEARCH IN THIS
AREA AND WILL BE ABLE TO TELL
YOU JUST HOW PROFITABLE THESE
FACILITIES CAN BE THESE BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THEIR GERIATRIC
CIRCLES STRONGLY SUPPORTS AB
TWENTY SEVENTY NINE BECAUSE
OF THIS BILL WOULD HAVE THE
EFFECT OF SHIFTING AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY ONE PERCENT OF REVENUES
INTO DIRECT CARE UP FOR
CLOSE TO A BILLION DOLLARS
IN CALIFORNIA WE THINK IT
WOULD HAVE FOUR MAJOR BENEFITS
FIRST IT WOULD INCLUDE ENCOURAGE
HIGHER STAFFING LEVELS AND WAGES
AND WE KNOW THAT MANY NURSING
HOMES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE HAD A
HISTORY OF INADEQUATE STAFFING
AND THIS IS BEEN ASSOCIATED WITH
HIGHER COVED NINETEEN RESIDENT
INSPECTION RIGHTS AND DEATH
RATES AND MANY OTHER SERIOUS
QUALITY PROBLEMS AT NURSING
HOME STAFF WAGES CONTINUE
TO BE LOW AND TURNOVER RATES
ARE AS HIGH AS FIFTY PERCENT
THE SECOND BENEFIT IS THAT IT
WOULD CONTROL EXCESS PROFITS
EVEN THOUGH PATIENT DAYS AN
OCCUPANCY RATES IN CALIFORNIA
NURSING HOMES DROPPED IN TWENTY
TWENTY THE PROFITS OF NURSING
HOMES WERE SIX PERCENT AND SOME
NURSING HOMES EVEN HAD FIFTEEN
TO THIRTY PERCENT PROFITS
WE ALSO KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
ARE ADEQUATE BECAUSE THE DAILY
RATES ARE NINETY ONE PERCENT
OF MEDICARE RATES IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND OF COURSE THE DAILY
RATES SHOULD BE UP FOR MEDICARE
SHOULD BE A LITTLE HIGHER
BECAUSE THOSE ARE FOR POST
ACUTE RESIDENTS THAT REQUIRE
MORE REHAB AND NURSING CARE
THE THIRD BENEFIT IS THAT IT
WOULD DISCOURAGE AND REDUCE
HIDDEN PROFITS AND HIDDEN
MANAGEMENT CAUGHT COST WHERE
-- AS -- DOCTOR WOULD MENTIONED
AT NURSING HOMES SIPHON
THIS MONEY OFF INTO THE ROOM
RELATED PARTY COMPANIES AND
FINALLY OF WE THINK IT WOULD
ENCOURAGE REDUCTIONS IN EXCESS
PROPERTY COST WE KNOW THAT SOME
PROPERTY OF OWNERS CHARGE
EXCESSIVE RATES STUDENTS TO THE
NURSING HOME COMPANIES AND SOME
HAVE LEASE AGREEMENTS THAT HAVE
THREE TO FIVE PERCENT INCREASES
BUILT RIGHT INTO THE LEASE EACH
YEAR AND THIS PULLS UP
REVENUES AWAY FROM RESIDENT CARE
IN SUMMARY OF THIS LEGISLATION
IS SIMILAR TO LEGISLATION
PASSED IN NEW JERSEY NEW
YORK AND MASSACHUSETTS LAST
YEAR AND THE BILL WOULD
HAVE IT ENSURE GREATER
FINANCIAL ACCOUNTABILITY AND
IMPROVED NURSING HOME QUALITY
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M TONY CHECK ITSELF WITH
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR NURSING
HOME REFORM IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWO ZERO SEVEN NINE
THE TIMING IS INTERESTING HERE
JUST YESTERDAY THERE WAS AN
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
HEARING WHERE THE NURSING HOME
FINANCING RE AUTHORIZATION
OF THE FINANCING SYSTEM RE
AUTHORIZATION WAS DISCUSSED
-- TO SOME DEGREE OF LENGTH
N. HERE IT IT'S VIRTUALLY
GUARANTEED THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO
PROPOSE GIVING THE INDUSTRY MORE
AND MORE MONEY EVERY YEAR THEY
GET RAISES AND EVERY YEAR THE
QUALITY STAYS ABOUT THE SAME AND
IT'S IT'S NEVER BEEN VERY GOOD
WHEN THE CURRENT FINANCING
SYSTEM WAS SET UP IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR THERE WERE BIG
PROMISES MADE THAT HEY WE GET
MORE MONEY YOU'RE GOING TO GET
BETTER CARE THINGS WILL IMPROVE
AND THAT JUST HAS NOT HAPPENED
I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
BILL WHICH WOULD WOULD BE A
MAJOR REFORM TO ESTABLISH A
DIRECT CARE -- MINIMUM
EXPENDITURE AS AS DR HARRINGTON
MENTIONED OTHER STATES HAVE
DONE THIS THE PANDEMIC HAS BEEN
DEVASTATING TO THE STAFF AND
THE RESIDENTS IN FACILITIES AND
IT'S TIME THAT WE REALLY ROLL
UP OUR SLEEVES AND GET REAL
REFORM AND WE STARTED LAST YEAR
WE HAD A NUMBER WE HAD FOR BILLS
THAT WERE VERY REFORM ORIENTED
PASSED LAST YEAR PART OF THE
PROTECT PLAN I THINK WE HAVE
SOME MORE WORK TO DO I THINK
THIS THIS BILL GOES A LONG WAY
TO DOING THAT AND IF IF YOU'RE
ALL INTERESTED IN SEEING WHAT
WHAT WE'RE GETTING AT YOU MIGHT
WANNA TAKE A LOOK AT A LAWSUIT
THAT WAS FILED IN NEW YORK STATE
AT THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
NEW YORK IS AHEAD OF US THEY
PASSED THIS LAW ON TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR THEY'RE SENDING SEVENTY
PERCENT REQUIRING SEVENTY
PERCENT OF THE REVENUE BE SPENT
ON DIRECT CARE IN THIS LAWSUIT
THE NURSING HOME WITH TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT NURSING
HOMES BANDED TOGETHER TO TRY
TO STOP THE IMPLEMENTATION THIS
LAW AND IN THEIR OWN COMPLAINT
THEY TALKED ABOUT AN AVERAGE
OF THREE AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS PER NURSING HOME BEING
SPENT ON THINGS THAT WERE NOT
DIRECT CARE AND WE'RE BEYOND THE
AMOUNT ALLOTTED TO THEM BY THE
STATE OF NEW YORK FOR NON DIRECT
CARE THREE AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS PER FACILITY THAT'S
REAL MONEY THAT COULD HELP A
LOT OF RESIDENTS SO WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU ARE DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER
SNYDER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
FACILITIES AND FIRST WANT TO
SAY THAT TO -- WE WE TRULY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
-- TO AND THE YEARS OF INTENT
THAT HE HAS WITH RESPECT TO
LOOKING AT QUALITY CARE I'M IN
NURSING HOMES AND AND WE HAVE
ENJOYED MANY CONVERSATIONS
AND DISCUSSIONS WITH IN THAT
REGARD AND I THINK FOR US --
THIS BILL AT LEAST AS IT'S
CURRENTLY WRITTEN WE DON'T
FEEL AT LEAST IN ITS CURRENT
FORM REALLY ADDRESSES WHERE WE
NEED TO GO WITH QUALITY CARE
AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO TALK
ABOUT QUALITY CARE I THINK THE
BILL IS MISSING A FEW ITEMS
THAT I'D LIKE TO JUST SHARE
WITH YOU TODAY I THINK FIRST
AND FOREMOST I THINK IT'S FIRST
IMPORTANT FOR -- THE STATE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT ARE REASONABLE
COSTS -- AND A PART OF THAT
IS LOOKING AT -- WHAT'S WHAT'S
STARTING TO BE REPORTED I HAD
TO -- H. CHI THE OLD ARE SPENT
-- AND SOME OF THAT INFORMATION
-- WHICH WE WORKED WITH --
SENATOR STERN LAST YEAR ON SB
SIX FIFTY LOOKS AT WAYS THAT
WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
TRANSPARENT NURSING FACILITIES
CAN BE TRANSPARENT ABOUT WHAT
THEIR COSTS ARE AND WHAT THEIR
TRANSACTIONS AND RELATIONSHIPS
ARE WITH THEIR RELATED PARTIES
SO ONCE WE'RE ABLE TO DETERMINE
KIND OF WHAT THOSE -- THOSE
TRANSPARENT RESOURCES ARE HOW
THEY'RE UTILIZING THOSE THOSE
RESOURCES THEN WE CAN THEN
TAKE THE NEXT STEP TO DETERMINE
MAYBE WHAT'S APPROPRIATE AND
WHAT'S NOT APPROPRIATE TO BE
SPENDING ON PATIENT CARE SO WE
THINK FIRST AND FOREMOST THAT
THE BILL AT LEAST AT THIS POINT
IS PREMATURE AND TWO WE THINK
THAT IF WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT ANY
TYPE OF RESTRICTIONS ON -- WHAT
A FACILITY SPANS WE FIRST NEED
TO MAKE SURE IF FOR ASSURING
QUALITY CARE THAT FACILITIES
-- PAID ADEQUATELY FOR THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT YOU KNOW WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO OUR PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
-- OUR STATE GOVERNMENT OUR
MEDICARE PROGRAM IS A PARTNER
WITH NURSING FACILITIES THEY
MAKE UP AT LEAST TWO THIRDS OF
THE PAYMENT FOR THOSE FACILITIES
ISN'T A MANY CASES WE KNOW FOR
A FACT THAT THEY UNDER PAY FOR
THE SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED
SO I DID WE STRONGLY BELIEVE
THAT THIS NEEDS TO BE LOOKED
AT -- TOGETHER BOTH WITH ARE
WE MAKING SURE THAT OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT FUNDS ARE PROBABLY
PAYING FOR PATIENT CARE BEFORE
WE DETERMINE WHAT RESOURCES ARE
APPROPRIATE TO BE SPENT OR NOT
SPENT AND THEN -- LASTLY I JUST
WANT TO MENTION THAT -- I'M
REALLY I THINK THE KEY CONCERNS
THAT -- CENTER AT LEAST FOR --
CALF IS AROUND THE DEFINITION OF
WHAT'S CONSIDERED TO BE PATIENT
CARE IN THE BILL RIGHT NOW -- IN
THAT DEFINITION LEAVES OUT WHAT
WE CONSIDER TO BE SOME IMPORTANT
PATIENT CARE RELATED COSTS ONE
BEING RENTS OR LEASES OTHERS
INSURANCE OTHER TYPES OF FEES
ARE OVERSIGHT THAT ARE REQUIRED
TO KEEP THE DOORS OPEN AND THE
LIGHTS ON AND ESPECIALLY RENTS
AND LEASES UNDERSTAND THERE
MIGHT BE CONCERNS ABOUT HOW MUCH
THAT IS OR OR WHAT THOSE AMOUNTS
SHOULD BE -- BUT IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE -- AREN'T FACTORING THAT
IN SO I APPRECIATE SAID THE
COMMITTEE'S TIME TODAY BUT M.
AND APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHAT -- BUT AT LEAST AT THIS
POINT WE HAVE IN OPPOSE POSITION
ON AB TWO ZERO SEVEN NINE
THANKS THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION IN THE CHAMBER
AT CHAIRED LIKE TO COMMENT
ON THE OPPOSITION IF THAT'S
APPROPRIATE SURE RESULT
THANK YOU -- THANK YOU -- THE
OPPOSITION FOR THEIR COMMENTS
AS WELL AS SENATOR STERN'S BILL
DOES NOT GO INTO EFFECT UNTIL
NEXT YEAR -- SO WE'RE GONNA
BE WAITING AWHILE FOR THAT
WE HAVE BEEN WE HAD A BILL
THAT'S LOOKING AT -- THAT WAS
LOOKING AT THE THESE OF THESE
THIRD PARTY -- RELATED PARTY
TRANSACTIONS WE'RE STILL WAITING
FOR THE RESULTS OF AUDITS
FROM THAT CAME UP YESTERDAY
I DO BELIEVE THAT THIS INDUSTRY
AND AND AND LOOK I DON'T I'M
NOT GOING TO CAST ASPERSIONS ON
THE ENTIRE INDUSTRY BECAUSE IT'S
NOT APPROPRIATE THERE ARE SOME
VERY VERY GOOD OPERATORS OUT
THERE BUT I BELIEVE THERE ARE
SOME OPERATORS THAT ARE NOT AND
-- WHEN IT GETS TO THINGS LIKE
RENTS WHEN IT WHEN IT WHEN AN
OPERATOR SETS UP A RELATED PARTY
ENTITY TO CHARGE RENTS THEY'RE
NOT DOING THAT TO GET THE
BEST POSSIBLE RATE THEY'RE
DOING THAT TO GET THE MOST
PROFIT THEY CAN'T OUT OF THAT
I'M ALSO VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE ENTRY OF VENTURE CAPITAL
INTO THIS SPACE MY UNDERSTANDING
BASED ON INFORMATION I'VE
READ ENOUGH I'M WRONG ON THIS
BUT I I BEG SOMEONE TO SHOW
ME DIFFERENT AND AND CORRECT
ME THE LARGEST AMOUNT OF
CONSOLIDATION ACCORDING TO
MED PAC IN HEALTH CARE RIGHT
NOW OR SEEN HOMES AND WHY
DO VENTURE CAPITALS GO INTO
CAP WAS GOING TO INTO THIS FOR
PROFIT SO THE IDEA THAT
THERE IS NOT THAT THAT THERE
IS NO PROFIT AT THAT OR THE
PROFITS ARE DIFFICULT TO COME
BY WHEN YOU SEE THE WAY THINGS
ARE HAPPENING IN THIS INDUSTRY
I DISAGREE
AND THERE ARE I KNOW THEIR
OPERATORS THAT THAT ARE NOT
THAT THAT THAT THIS DOES NOT
AFFECT BUT THEIR OFFERS THEY'RE
A STREAMLINED SOPHISTICATED
AND DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN
TO SIPHON OFF PROFITS AWAY
FROM PATIENT CARE THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS AIMING TO DO
AND I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU -- WE NEED
TO GO TO THE PHONE
LINES NOW MR OPERATOR
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
ON A. B. TWO ZERO SEVEN
NINE PRIVILEGE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
NINETY SIX A LINE IS OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON YES MEAN
PILOT ON BEHALF OF JUSTICE IN
AGING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SH AND
ONE MOMENT FOR OUR NEXT LINE
THANKS NINE ONE NINE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YES
MIXING MANGALAM HAPPEN NATIONAL
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS SOCIETY
AND SUPPORTED CAL THANK YOU
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU SO WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR
YOU KNOW THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE FOR CALIFORNIA I THINK
WE DON'T ALWAYS REALIZE THAT
EVERY DAY CALIFORNIA ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE TURN SIXTY FIVE
ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE WERE ALL
ON OUR PRIME HERE I THINK
WE ARE OF AFFECT THEIR
AB THIS COULD BE US ONE DAY THIS
COULD BE -- OUR FAMILY MEMBERS
TOMORROW AND THERE ARE A LOT
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE PART OF
THE SITUATION THAT MISSED NINE
TO REPRESENTS WHICH ARE GREAT
ACTORS THERE'S ONE I THINK
IS NAMELESS SHLOMO RESNICK
WHO IS A BAD APPLE THAT
MAYBE HE'S NOT REPRESENTATIVE
ALL YOUR MEMBERS BUT DURING
DATE CODED EPIDEMIC PANDEMIC
WE SAW FIRSTHAND WITH SOMEBODY'S
BAD OPERATORS ARE DOING TO
IT TOO TO CREATE PROBLEMS
ALL ACROSS -- THE GRACE OF
CALIFORNIANS SO THERE'S AN
ISSUE WITH LICENSING WHICH I
KNOW THIS COMMITTEE ADDRESSED
A FEW MONTHS AGO WHICH I I'M
PROPOSED PROBABLY SUPPORTED
BUT -- I THINK YOU'RE ON TO
SOMETHING -- A LARGER ISSUE HERE
LARGER ISSUE HERE -- MISTER
WOULD IN THESE -- CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS ARE INCREASINGLY
NEEDED IN THIS GROWING
INDUSTRY THAT THEY'RE NOT MONPA
OPERATORS THIS IS A LARGE --
-- IN INTEREST THAT YOU SAID
THERE'S VENTURE CAPITAL AND BLAH
PRIVATE EQUITY MINE IS GETTING
IN THIS BUSINESS CAUSES EXTREME
PROFITS BY THE AGING POPULATION
IN A FIRE FORMER COLLEAGUE
HERE MISS BROWN WERE HERE TODAY
SHOULD REMIND US AS THE SILVER
TSUNAMI SHE USED TO ALWAYS TALK
ABOUT RIGHT AND IT IS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE NEED MORE
MEASURES TO PROTECT OUR SENIORS
IN THESE NURSING HOMES SO
THANK YOU FOR THIS MEASURE MR
OF MR ARAMBULA THANK YOU
I AM GOING TO BE SUPPORTING
THIS MEASURE I THINK IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL FOR US TO
HAVE ESPECIALLY FOLLOWING UP
ON THE CONVERSATION THAT WE HAD
YESTERDAY -- YESTERDAY WE HAD
A LOT OF CONSENSUS ON THE NEED
FOR US TO HAVE TRANSPARENCY AND
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WILL GO
A LONG WAY TOWARDS US ACHIEVING
THAT I I DO WANT TO DIG IN
A LITTLE BIT IF I CAN ON THE
PERCENTAGE I AM LIKE THAT YOU
REFERENCED THE MEDICAL LOSS
RATIO AS THE AUTHOR WHO CODIFIED
HERE IT HERE AND CALIFORNIA --
BUT HEARD ABOUT WHAT OCCURRED IN
NEW YORK AND SO I WOULD LOVE TO
HEAR YOUR RATIONALE OR THINKING
AND -- FOR WHY WE SELECTED THIS
PERCENTAGE AND APPRECIATE THAT
MORE WILL GO TOWARDS PATIENT
CARE BUT WANTS TO HEAR YOUR
RATIONALE FOR THAT LIKE WELL
IT IT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
WE'RE DOING THIS WITH INSURANCE
COMPANIES THEY'RE ABLE TO DO
THAT THIS SEEMS LIKE A A
VALID STARTING POINT MY DOOR
IS ALWAYS OPEN IF THERE ARE
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS THAT
WE NEED TO MAKE WE'RE ABSOLUTELY
OPEN TO DO THAT BUT --
A CERTAIN ONE THAT STARTED FIFTY
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE A. SINGH NINE
ARE YOU ACCEPTING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS YEAH I PROPERTY
THAT FOR THE RECORD
-- WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY
VIZAG OUR KERRY IN THE SECOND
BY MR ARAMBULA WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR ABOUT THANK YOU
SO IT'S TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS OF THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD AYE WALDRON
NOW PHONING WATER NOT VOTING
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW
CARILLO LARA FLORIDA
VOTING MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I MAYES
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN
RIVAS RIVAS I CALDERON
CALDERON AYE SANTIAGO
BONTA I BONTA I
SO HAVE BY EIGHT TWO ZERO
AND WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR MORE ADD ONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU WE
HAVE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY SIX
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU MEMBERS -- AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY SIX -- INCREASES THE
TIME TO REGISTER WHY BIRTH
WITH THE LOCAL REGISTRAR FROM
WITHIN TEN DAYS WITHIN TWENTY
ONE DAYS AFTER THE BIRTH OF A
CHILD IN WORKING TO IMPROVE
SERVICES WITH THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY PROVIDENCE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY INITIATED A
BETTER BIRTHING PROJECT WHICH
LOCAL TRIBES AND AND WITH
LOCAL TRIBES AND LEARNED THAT
MANY NATIVE FAMILIES HELLO
CULTURAL TO TRADITION OF NOT
CHOOSING A NAME FOR THEIR
NEWBORN UNTIL THE TENTH DAY
WHEN THEY HOLD THE SACRED
CEREMONIAL BLESSING CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES A HOSPITAL TO SUBMIT
THE BABY'S BIRTH CERTIFICATE
TO THE LOCAL REGISTRAR WITHIN
TEN DAYS PUTTING UNDUE PRESSURE
ON THE FAMILY IT DOES NOT TAKE
THEIR CULTURAL TRADITIONS INTO
CONSIDERATION AND CHALLENGES
HOSPITAL STAFF TO FILE PAPERWORK
WITHIN THE DEADLINE IF THE
HOSPITALS THAT HAVE THE NAME
OF THE CHILD THEY MUST EITHER
NOT SUBMIT THE PAPERWORK FOR
THE PARENTS OR FILE BIRTH
CERTIFICATE WITH NO NAME
SHIFTING THE BURDEN ONTO THE
FAMILY TO FILE OR AMEND A BIRTH
CERTIFICATE ALONG WITH OTHER
TOP GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS LATER
ALL OF THIS TAKES TIME MONEY
AND RESOURCES TO ACCOMPLISH BUT
MOSTLY PARENTS TAKE FOR GRANTED
HUMBOLDT COUNTY IS HOME TO NINE
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN
RANCHERIAS IS SOVEREIGN NATIONS
AND OTHERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
HAVE THEIR OWN SPECIFIC BELIEFS
TRADITIONAL PRACTICES AND
CEREMONIES I BELIEVE THE STATE
SHOULD RESPECT THAT BY ALLOWING
ADEQUATE TIME TO COMPLETE THE
REQUIRED REGISTRATION PROCESS
WITH ME IN SUPPORT TODAY OUR DR
ANTOINETTE MARTINEZ FROM UNITED
INDIAN HEALTH SERVICES AND
COUNCIL MEMBER PHILLIP WILLIAMS
WITH THE EUROPE TRIBAL COUNCIL
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS DR ANTOINETTE MARTINEZ I AM
CHIU MARSH NATIVE FROM SANTA
YNEZ ANNA FAMILY MEDICINE
OBSTETRICS PHYSICIAN AT YOU UHS
UNITED INDIAN HEALTH A. P. L.
PUBLIC CLASS SIX THIRTY EIGHT
TRIBAL HEALTH CLINIC WE SERVE
HUMBOLDT AND DEL NORTE COUNTIES
EXCLUDING THE HOOP A RESERVATION
AND SERVICE AREA I'M ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE A. I. P.
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICAN INDIAN
PHYSICIANS OF WHO WHICH FULLY
SUPPORTS OF AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
SEVEN AND I AM ALSO AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION JADEITE
JUSTICE EQUITY DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION COMMITTEE IN JANUARY
THE CMA BOARD OF TRUSTEES
APPROVED A MAJOR ISSUES REPORT
ON RACISM AND OTHER BARRIERS
TO HEALTH CARE IT INCLUDES
RECOMMENDATION FOURTEEN WHICH
STATES THAT CMA ACKNOWLEDGE
THE HISTORICAL AND PRESENT
CONTRIBUTION OF MEDICAL RACISM
IN THE MEDICAL PROFESSION IN
INCREASING MATERNAL AND INFANT
MORTALITY RATE FOR BLACK AND
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES AS WELL AS
OTHER MARGINALIZED MINORITIES
POPULATIONS SO THIS DOCUMENT
UP SUPPORTS AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY SEVEN AND -- THIS
OF COURSE EXPENSE THE
TIME FRAME FOR REGISTRATION OF
AN INFANT'S NAME FROM TEN TO
TWENTY ONE DAYS INDIGENOUS
TRIBES WITH IN CALIFORNIA AND
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY HAVE
LONG HAD A HISTORY OF GENOCIDE
WITH FORCED FAMILY SEPARATIONS
CHILDREN SET TO BOARDING SCHOOLS
SLAVERY FORCED STERILIZATION
CHILLED -- AS WELL AS LOSS OF
LANCE CULTURAL PRACTICES AND
CEREMONIES AND ONLY SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT DID
NATIVE PEOPLES HAVE THE RIGHT
TO OPENLY PRACTICE THEIR
OF CULTURE IN CEREMONIES
SO NUMEROUS INDIGENOUS
TRIBES WITH IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE HAD TRADITIONS OF
POSTPONING THE NAME OF A
NEWBORN UNTIL AFTER TEN
DAYS HAVE PASSED SO
THIS CHANGE IN CRITERIA
ELIMINATES ONE LITTLE PIECE OF
STRUCTURAL RACISM THAT CAUSES
DIFFICULTIES FOR FAMILIES
REGISTERING THEIR INFANT
ENFORCES PARENTS IF THEY
GO BEYOND THE TEN DAYS TO
NAVIGATE OF COMPLICATED WEB OF
INSTITUTIONS -- CALIFORNIA
DATA CLEARLY SHOWS HEALTH
INEQUITIES AMONG INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES WOMEN AND FAMILIES
THERE REMAINS A LACK OF TRUST
IN THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
LEADING TO A DELAY IN CARE
AND A DISTRUST OF MEDICAL
RECOMMENDATIONS ALLOWING FOR
THE TEN DAY RULE IS ONE STEP
IN CREATING A SYSTEM THAT
RESPECTS AND ACKNOWLEDGES NATIVE
TRADITIONS THEREBY ELIMINATING
ONE PIECE OF STRUCTURAL RACISM
TODAY OUR VOTE IN FAVOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION IS REQUESTED AND
HIGHLY APPRECIATED THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION
YEAH A GOOD CHOICE
KIANA CHOI GOOD AFTERNOON
MAYOR CLING WHICH
MY NAME IS PHILIP WHIMS I'M A
MEMBER OF THE IRAQI PRIME THE
LARGEST TRIBE IN CALIFORNIA
BORDERS ARE CURRENTLY SERVE
AS A COUNCIL MEMBER FOR THE
NORTH DISTRICT SORRY
I'M ALSO CULTURAL
PRACTITIONER THE FISHERMEN
AND LEADER MY COMMUNITY
YOUR CARD IS ALREADY SUBMITTED
HIS FORMAL SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY SIX AND
I'M HERE TO PROVIDE THE
CONTACTED THAT SUPPORT
BEFORE I BEGIN I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE MANY NATIVE FAMILIES AND
SHARE THEIR PERSONAL STORIES
AND SPARKED A LEGISLATION
WE ARE HERE TO DISCUSS
THE STRUGGLE HAS GARNERED THE
ATTENTION OF THIS INSTITUTION
I THANK THEM WITH MY FULL
HEART AND HOPE THEY WILL REAP
THE BENEFITS OF THIS CHANGE
ALSO LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD FOR INTRODUCING
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
AND TO ALL FRIENDS OF INDIAN
COUNTRY INCLUDING ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ALMOST SENATOR MCGUIRE STAFF
ACTIVISTS AND MANY MORE
THE HISTORY BETWEEN TRIBES IN
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN FULL OF
CONFLICT WHETHER BY
DESIGN OR JUST LACK OF
CONSIDERATION OR RESPECT FOR
OUR WAY OF LIFE CALIFORNIA
LAWS AND POLICIES HAVE
OFTEN HARMED NATIVE PEOPLE
I'M HAPPY TO SEE THE BEGINNING
OF SHIFT TOWARD JUSTICE
ORDERS EXTENDING
A LIVE BIRTH REGISTRATION FROM
TEN DAYS TO TWENTY ONE DAYS IS
A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
THIS BILL WILL POSITIVELY
IMPACT MANY TRIBES AND
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE
AT YUROK EVERY VILLAGE AND
FAMILY HAS THEIR OWN WAY
OUR RELIGION CULTURAL PRACTICES
AND CEREMONIES ARE SACRED
I WILL NOT BE SPECIFICALLY
DISCUSSING THEM TODAY BUT
I WILL SAY THAT NO MATTER
THE PRACTICE EVERY YEAR
OUR FAMILY WILL BENEFIT FROM
HAVING MORE TIME BETWEEN A
CHILD'S BIRTH AND REGISTRATION
OUR NAMING CEREMONY
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN WITH
US FOR THOUSANDS OF YEARS
WELL WE ARE HERE OCT NO
WE NAME OUR CHILD WE'RE
SAYING THEM ON A PATH
FOR THE REST OF YOUR LIFE
WHATEVER NAME WE GIVE THEM
WHETHER TO PLACE AN ANIMAL
THAT'S WHAT THEY WILL BE THEY
WILL LIVE UP TO THAT NAME
ULTIMATELY THIS BILL IS ABOUT
RESPECTING TRIBES ARE MOVING
AWAY FROM PAST ATTEMPTS TO
ASSIMILATE US THE MODERN
CULTURE IS CONSTANTLY
EVOLVING AND MAKING STRIDES
TO BE RESPECTFUL TO THE MANY
DIFFERENT GROUPS THAT MAKE
UP THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THE TIME IS WELL OVERDUE TO
INCLUDE INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY TO
LOOK AT IS POLICIES AND PUT
AN END TO SYSTEMIC GENOCIDE
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE OF ANY SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION IN THE CHAMBER
CASING NONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES -- JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION PLEASE
THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT ON A BIG
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
FIRST WE HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE OF THE LEADING TO HELP
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
WEARING SUPPORT THANK YOU
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH MAKE
COMMENT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. GREAT
THANK YOU I WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS THREE OF US
THANK YOU DOCTOR WORD FOR
AUTHORING THE SPELL YOU I
AGREE THAT TIME IS OVERDUE FOR
RESPECTING NATIVE TRADITIONS AND
THIS BILL IS ONE STEP --
TOWARDS -- TOWARDS THAT END
IT MAKES SENSE -- SO I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
THEY ARE RECOMMENDED DACIAN IS
TO PASS -- AND WE HAVE A MOTION
WE DO HAVE A MOTION OF
THE AUTHOR IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- NATIVE AMERICANS
HAVE THE INHERENT RIGHT TO
EXERCISE THEIR SPIRITUAL AND
CULTURAL TRADITIONS MAYBE
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY SIX WILL
LAMINATE ONE BUREAUCRATIC
HURDLE ON THE TRADITIONAL
PRACTICES OF THOSE INDIGENOUS
TO NORTH AMERICA I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU OF THE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHAT I WOULD
AYE WALDRON AYE WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW NOT VOTING CARILLO
LAURA LAURA I MEAN TRYING
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAYES MCCARTY
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA
RIVAS RIVAS I CALDERON
CALDERON I SANTIAGO
BONTA I BONTA HI
TEN ZERO BILL PASSES
THEN WILL CLEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADD ONS THANK YOU
K. CAN NO LUIS
CHECK WE MEET AGAIN
HEY NEXT UP ITEM FOURTEEN
A. B. TWO SEVEN TWO SEVEN
DOCTOR ONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A CHAIR AND MEMBERS
-- THIS BILL WOULD UPDATE
AND MODERNIZE THE OUTDATED
LEGISLATIVE INTENT LANGUAGE IN
THE FIRST CODE SECTION AND THE
MEDICARE ACT WHICH ESTABLISHES
THE PURPOSE OF THE PROGRAM
THIS SECTION OF LAW WAS LAST
AMENDED IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
AND AS YOU KNOW THE PROGRAM
HAS CHANGED SIGNIFICANTLY SINCE
THAT TIME WOULD MAKE THREE
CHANGES FIRST PLACE REPLACE
THE PHRASE THAT THE PROGRAM
IS PROVIDING SERVICES TO AGED
AND OTHER PERSONS INCLUDING
FAMILY PERSONS MORE UP TO DATE
AND SPECIFIC PHRASE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS SECOND IT WOULD REPEAL
THE LIMITATION ON MEDICARE
ELIGIBILITY DESCRIBED IN THE
INTENT LANG INSTITUTE LANGUAGE
TO PERSONS WHOSE ASSETS ARE
LIMITED BUT WITH THE LATEST
CHANGE UNTIL JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR THE ASSET TEST
IS IT IS SCHEDULED TO REPEAL
AND THIRD IT WOULD DELETE IN THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT LANGUAGE THE
REFERENCE TO ANNUAL INCOME AS
INCOME PREDOMINANTLY DETERMINED
ON A MONTHLY BASIS WITH ME
IS LINDA WAY FROM THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LET LAN PARTY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
GOOD AFTERNOON LINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY PROUD TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN WHICH
WOULD UPDATE THE LEGISLATIVE
PURPOSE AND INTENT FOR THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM FIRST ENACTED
IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE THE
CURRENTLY WHICH IS OUTDATED
SINCE THE DUKE SCRIBES ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS AS AGED AND OTHER
PERSONS INCLUDING FAMILY
PERSONS THIS HARKS BACK TO
THE IDEA OF THE DESERVING
POOR THAT ONLY SOME LOW INCOME
PEOPLE ARE DESERVING OF MEDIC
CAL THE LEGISLATURE RIGHTLY
REJECTED THIS NOTION WHEN THIS
BODY EXPANDED MEDICAID HOW TO
INCOME ELIGIBLE ADULTS UNDER
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT MORE
RECENTLY THE LEGISLATURE HAS
TAKEN BOLD STEPS TO EXPAND
MEDICAID ELIGIBILITY TO NEARLY
ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE RESIDENTS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS OR ASSETS AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN MORE ACCURATELY
REFLECTS THE LEGISLATURES
PAST AND FUTURE ACTIONS TO
EXTEND MEDICAID ELIGIBILITY
TO ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS LOOTING THE ASSET
TEST ELIMINATION IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND THE PROPOSAL
TO CLOSE THE COVERAGE GAP BY
EXTENDING FULL SCOPE MEDICARE
TO ADULTS AGES TWENTY SIX TO
FORTY NINE IN THE NEAR FUTURE
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU OF ARE THERE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE
WHO HAVE OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT PLEASE COME FORWARD
SEEING NONE WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES -- NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ONLY
THANK YOU CAN LIVE IN GERMAN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
AGAIN ANY COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
THANK YOU OF BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
THIS REGIONAL RIVALS THANK
YOU AND -- WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND IT'S DUE PASS
RECOMMENDATION MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD AYE WALDRON AYE WALDRON
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
BIGELOW BIGELOW NO CARILLO
LARA OR NOT VOTING
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MAYES MAYES NOT VOTING
MCCARTY MCCARTY I NAZARIAN
RIVAS RIVERSIDE CALDERON
CALDERON AYE SANTIAGO
BONTA AYE BATA AYE
CARILLO HI
SENATOR TEN ZERO BILL IS
OUT WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADD ONS THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WE DO NOT HAVE ANYTHING ON
CALL TODAY WHICH IS UNUSUAL
-- THANK MEMBERS FOR FOR --
HELPING US GET THROUGH THAT WE
REALLY APPRECIATE IT SO WE WILL
GO TO THE TOP OF THE AGENDA
AND WE WILL ASK FOR MEMBERS TO
-- HAVE NOT VOTED TO BE ABLE
TO ADD ON TO THEIR VOTE SELF
SERVICE ITEM NUMBER ONE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BARRICADE HAND
THAT SECTOR PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS WELL
L. I. FLORA FLORA NOT VOTING
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY I REQUEST
RIVERSIDE I SANTIAGO
WELL THAT'S TWELVE ZERO WILL GO
TO ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B. SIXTEEN
SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIAN OPEN THE ROLE PLEASE
OPEN A ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CARILLO I CARILLO
AYE FLORA LARA NO
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
CALDERON CALDERON AYE SANTIAGO
OF TWO THAT'S TWELVE TO
TWO ITEM NUMBER THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUNNINGHAM AB
AT TWENTY ONE THIRTY PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS WELL I RIO AYE
FLORA FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I SANTIAGO
FOURTEEN ZERO THAT'S FOURTEEN
ZERO ITEM NUMBER FOUR A.
B. TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AREA I
RIO AYE FLORA FLORA I
SANTIAGO FOURTEEN ZERO
AS FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY AB NINETEEN TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BIGELOW BIGELOW NOT VOTING
CARILLO RIGHT RIO I MAYES
MAYES NOT VOTING THIS AREA
RIVAS RIVAS I
CALDERON I'M SORRY I
HAVE W. IS NOT VOTING
THE VOTING ZERO
THAT'S TEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW
BIGELOW NOT VOTING CARILLO
I MAYES
I'D NEVER SIX MISTER NAZARIAN AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY TWO MAYES
I REQUEST RIVAS AYE
CALDERON ELDER ON ICE SANTIAGO
ZERO THAT'S TWELVE ZERO ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN WAS OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS CARILLO
-- I FLORA LARA AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I SANTIAGO
FOURTEEN ZERO S. FOURTEEN
ZERO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS HE
BEAT SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO CARILLO
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES MAYES I THIS AREA
SANTIAGO
THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LUIS RIVAS AB TWENTY FOUR
OH FOUR PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
AND CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BIGELOW BIGELOW I'D CARILLO
I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAYES MAYES I
NAZARIAN FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
TEN AB TWENTY FOUR OH TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BIGELOW BIGELOW NOT
VOTING CARILLO I
MAYES MAYES NOT
VOTING THIS AREA
ZERO TWELVE ZERO ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE IN CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CORREO AEREO I FLORA
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES I'M SORRY HAVE YEARS I --
MCCARTY MCCARTY
I REQUEST RIVAS AYE SANTIAGO
ZERO ZERO ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
AB TWENTY SEVENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BIGELOW BIGELOW NOW
REAL RIO I
MAYES MAYES NOT VOTING
NAZARIAN SANTIAGO
NINE ONE NINE ONE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WOULD PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
OKAY BIGELOW
BIGELOW I I'M
NOT VOTING T¡I CARILLO
I MAYES
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY SIX
MAYES I THIS AREA
SANTIAGO THIRTEEN ZERO
THIRTEEN ZERO AND FINALLY
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN BY SEVEN
MEMBER WOULD PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE IN CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS NAZARIAN SANTIAGO
AND THE ONE DID YOU HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL CHANGE YOU
WANT TO MAKE ISRAEL WAS IT
OKAY AWESOME THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY THAT --
THAT CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF WAITING FOR A
COUPLE OF OTHER MEMBERS TO COME
CORRECT YEAH YEAH
ABSOLUTELY OKAY
SO WE WILL WAIT
FOR MR SANTIAGO AND --
MISTER NAZARIAN SO
OTHERWISE CLASS DISMISSED
THIS IS SPEECH TO MR MAYS
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE OF A
CHANGE WHICH BILL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO WHICH VOTE FIVE
AB FIVE AB NINETEEN TWENTY
EIGHT MCCARTY FROM NOT
VOTING TO SUPPORT T¡I SO
AB NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT FROM
NOT VOTING TO HI YEAH MAYES
NOT VOTING T¡I THANK YOU
ELEVEN TO ZERO SO THAT MAKES
OF ELEVEN TO ZERO THANK YOU
ANOTHER
YEAH OKAY
-- WE WILL GO LET'S GO TO THE
TOP OF THE ORDER LET'S SEE
WHERE WE OKAY SO ITEM
NUMBER ONE BARRICADE HAND AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY SIX PLEASE
OPEN A ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
MISTER BRIAN PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
THIRTEEN TWO THIRTEEN TWO ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY BY A MISTER CUNNINGHAM
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN ZERO FIFTEEN
ZERO ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX BY
MISTER GIPSON PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN
ZERO A NUMBER FIVE AB NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT BY MR MCCARTY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL THEM ON
THAT ONE YOU GOT HIM ON THAT ONE
AND ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY TWO BY MR ASSYRIAN
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I THIRTEEN ZERO
THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY FIVE MISTER
PATTERSON PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN
ZERO I REMEMBER EIGHT C.
I REMEMBER EIGHT AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN BY MISTER
RAMOS PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS AS
ARIAN SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I FOURTEEN ZERO A NUMBER
NINE A. B. TWENTY FOUR A
FOUR BY I SUPPOSE THAT WHEN A
NUMBER NINE I HAVE ABOUT TEN
DON'T HAVE A MODEL OF AN
ELEVEN AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEEKS
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I THIRTEEN ZERO
THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
ITEM -- AB TWENTY SEVENTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AS AREA
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
AND ONE AND ONE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
SIX OF I WOULD -- PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS IN THIS AREA SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE FOURTEEN ZERO
I REMEMBER FOURTEEN WOULD
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AS ARIAN
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I ELEVEN
ZERO ELEVEN TO ZERO OKAY THAT
IS IT EVERYTHING THANK YOU
MR SANTIAGO THAT CONCLUDES
THE BUSINESS OF THE ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE ARE ADJOURNED